ALAN ARCHULETA ATKINS EIGHT
BACKER FORGES BRADFORD COME BY
ADAM CORTEZ THREE DALLY DODD
DURAZO AIKMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROVE HERZBERG WEST SO HER TADO
JONES CAN LONGER LAYERED LLEVA
THE MON GLIDER MELINDA'S MIN
NEWMAN NIELSEN A TROUBLED PAM
BORTON TINO ROSSI. ZERO SKINNER
STERN AMBERG MY CASKEY WINNER
WILL. MEMBERS OF A QUORUM IS
PRESENT PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE REAL IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY SENATOR RUBIO AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING
AND WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR JONES. SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATE COLLEAGUES AS WE
COMMEMORATE THE TWENTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF NINE ELEVEN.
THAT'S REMEMBER ALL THE LIVES
THAT WERE LOST AND SAY THIS
PRAYER AND THEIR NAME. LEAVE
THE FAMILIAR FOR A WHILE. LET
YOUR SENSES AND BODY STRETCHED
OUT LIKE A WELCOME SEASON ONTO
THE MEADOWS AND SHORES AND
HILLS OPEN UP TO THE ROOF
MAKING NEW WATERMARK ON YOUR
EXCITEMENT AND LOVE. LIKE A
BLOOMING NIGHT FLOWER BESTOWED
YOUR VITAL FRAGRANCE OF
HAPPINESS AND GIVING UP ON YOUR
INTIMATE ASSEMBLY CHANGE ROOMS
IN YOUR MIND FOR A DAY. ALL THE
HEMISPHERES IN EXISTENCE LIVE
BESIDE AN EQUATOR IN YOUR HEART
GREET YOURSELF IN YOUR THOUSAND
OTHER FORMS AS YOU SAIL THE
HIDDEN TIED AND TRAVEL BACK
HOME. ALL THE HEMISPHERES IN
HEAVEN ARE SITTING AROUND AND
CHATTING. WHILE STITCHING
THEMSELVES TOGETHER INTO THE
GREAT CIRCLE INSIDE OF YOU A
MAN. KESSEN SENATORS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
FISH AND. HELLO SONG. MEMBERS
OF THE REMINDER PURSUANT TO
SENATE RULE THIRTY FIVE AND
SENATE RULE FIFTY SIX DEBATE
MAY BE LIMITED TO A TOTAL OF
FIVE MINUTES FOR THE AUTHOR OR
FLOOR MANAGER WHICH INCLUDES
OPENING CLOSING STATEMENTS AND
A TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES FOR
SENATORS WHO CHOOSE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE DEBATE.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL MOVE TO. THE INTERNAL
MEMORY BY SENATOR NEWMAN AND
SENATOR GONZALEZ. SENATOR
NEWMAN. GOOD MORNING COLLEGE.
AND MEMBERS OF THE CAPITAL
COMMUNITY. I RISE TO
MEMORIALIZE THE LIVES IN SPIRIT
OF MARK HANSEN A MEMBER OF OUR
SENATE FAMILY WHO DIED SUDDENLY
OF HEART FAILURE AT HIS HOME ON
THE MORNING OF WEDNESDAY AUGUST
TWENTY FIFTH. HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. MARK BRANDON HANSON
WAS BORN ON AUGUST TWENTY FIRST
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE AND BUY
SELL YOU CALIFORNIA TO CHOICE
AND RUSS HANSON WHO ARE HERE
TODAY WITH US IN THE GALLERY
ALONG WITH OTHER MEMBERS OF
MARK'S FAMILY. INCLUDING HIS
WIFE SHEENA. THEIR SONS JASPER
AN NGO HIS BROTHER STEVE AND
STEVE'S WIFE ERIN- AND THEIR
TWO CHILDREN MARK'S NIECE
NEPHEW ELLA. AND JACOB. MARKET
TENDED MOUNT WHITNEY HIGH%
SCHOOL INVITE SHOW YOU WHERE IN
ADDITION TO HIS STUDIES HE
EXCELLED IN SOCCER. ESPECIALLY
IN WATER POLO IN WHICH HE
EARNED ALL AMERICAN HONORS.
MARKETER TO COLLEGES SANTA
CLARA UNIVERSITY. WHERE HE
MAJORED IN PHILOSOPHY AND
POLITICAL SCIENCE IN WHERE HE
ALSO PLAYED IN SANTA CLARA'S
WATER POLO TEAM. DURING HIS
JUNIOR YEAR IN COLLEGE MARK
SPENT A SEMESTER STUDYING AT
AMERICAN UNIVERSITY IN
WASHINGTON DC. WHERE HE TOOK
WHAT TURNED OUT TO BE HIS FIRST
STEPS TOWARD AN EVENTUAL CAREER
IN ADVOCACY IN PUBLIC SERVICE.
STARTING WITH HIS TENURE THAT
YEAR AS AN INTERN ON CAPITOL
HILL. AFTER GRADUATION FROM
SANTA CLARA MARK WENT ON TO
EARN A MASTERS IN URBAN
PLANNING FROM UCLA. AFTER
COMPLETING HIS STUDIES AT UCLA.
MARKET A FRIEND TRAVELED FIRST
TO BARCELONA AND THEN ACROSS
EUROPE. AFTER WHICH MARK THEN
SPENT NEARLY A YEAR AND PUNISH
IRIS ARGENTINA. WORKING TOWARD
HIS GOAL OF BECOMING FLUENT IN
SPANISH. HAVING ACHIEVED THAT
GOAL IN TWO THOUSAND THREE MARK
JOINED THE PEACE CORPS WHERE
HIS SERVICE TOOK INTO LET'S SAY
BEHIND TOURISTS. WHERE HE DID
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT WORK AND
THEN YOU L. SALVADOR WHERE HE
SERVED AS AN ELECTION OBSERVER.
JASPER ATTENTION. THE OLDER OF
THE TWO WONDERFUL BOYS WAS BORN
IN DC I'M SORRY I MIGHT PITCH
THREE SHOULD BE ON PAGE TWO.
MARK WAS MANY THINGS A SMART
AND DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANT
AND INVETERATE ADVENTURER A
ROVING A CURIOUS INTELLECT AND
A TERRIFIC COLLEAGUE AND FRIEND
BUT MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE. HE
WAS A WONDERFUL HUSBAND SON AND
FATHER MARK WAS NEVER HAPPIER
WHEN PARTICIPATING. IN HIS
CHILDREN'S ACTIVITIES
ESPECIALLY JASPER SOCCER OR
WHEN SERVING AS THEIRFAVORITE
PLAYMATE OR THE LEADER OF THEIR
SHARED ADVENTURES. A SINGLE
FEATURE OF THEIR NEW HOME HERE
IN EAST LAND PARK WHAT'S THE
SOUND OF LAUGHTER PERCOLATING
OUT OF THE BACKYARD FROM MARK
JASPER AND ENZO AT THE END OF A
TYPICAL DAY. WE ALL MISS THAT
LAUGHTER JASPRIT ENSUING CHAIN
OBVIOUSLY MOST OF ALL. WE HERE
IN THE CAPITAL WHERE MANY WERE
STILL JUST GETTING TO KNOW MARK
IN THE MIDST OF THIS VERY
CHALLENGING YEAR WILL ALSO
DEARLY MISSED HIS SPIRIT. HIS
ENERGY HIS OPTIMISM AND HIS
IDEALISM. IF YOU LOOK UP IN THE
GALLERY YOU'LL SEE THAT JASPER
AND SO- MARKET SHARE AND I HAD
A WONDERFUL RELATIONSHIP THEY
WERE INTRODUCED. BY A MUTUAL
FRIEND IN DC WHO WHO KNEW. THAT
THEIR SHARED LOVE OF LATIN
AMERICA THEIR COMMITMENT TO
SOCIAL JUSTICE- THEIR FESTIVE
SPIRIT- AND THEIR COMPASSION
AND GENEROSITY MAKE THEM.
PERFECT MATCH- THEY FELL IN
LOVE INSTANTLY- AND FOR THE
NEXT TWO YEARS SEVERAL YEARS-
THEY DEVELOPED. A BOND THAT
BECAME THE FOUNDATION FOR THEIR
WONDERFUL FAMILY. WE HEAR THE
CAP OR MAYBE WE'RE STILL JUST
JUST GETTING TO KNOW MARK AND
MRS FELT VERY CHALLENGING HERE
WILL ALSO DEARLY MISSES SPIRIT.
HIS ENERGY HIS OPTIMISM AND HIS
IDEALISM. THE PHOTO OF MARKET
THE FUN OF THE CHAMBER CAPTURES
THE ESSENCE OF THOSE QUALITIES
WELL. THIS WAS MARK AS WE ALL
KNOW HIM HAPPY. ENGAGED SO FULL
OF ENERGY ALWAYS READY TO
CONNECT. AND CONNECT TO DO IT.
SINCE HIS PASSING I'VE BEEN
AMAZED AT JUST HOW MANY PEOPLE
MARK DONNELLY TOUCH. TOUCH
PROFOUNDLY. THE OUTPOURINGOF
GRIEF AND ADMIRATION AND
COMPASSION FOR PEOPLE WHO KNEW
MARK. BOTH BACK IN THE DISTRICT
HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND ALL
MANNER OF PLACES FOR AND WHY IT
HAS BEEN NOTHING SHORT. OF
ASTOUNDING. AND AS WE STAND
HERE IN THE CHAMBER TODAY. I'M
STRUCK BY TWO THINGS FIRST HOW
THIS SPACE POPULATED BY
GENERATIONS OF PUBLIC SERVANTS
AND ANIMATED BY PURPOSE AND
SERVICE IS EXACTLY THE KIND OF
PLACE THAT MARK WAS MADE FOR.
THE SECOND PART FOR ME NOW IS
AMONG THE SADDEST ASPECTS OF
THE PANDEMIC THE BECAUSE OF THE
RESTRICTIONS IT HAS IMPOSED
MARK NEVER REALLY GOT TO SPEND
TIME HERE IN THE CHAMBER IN THE
MIDST OF OUR WORK THE WAY IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN DONE. WHICH
SENATORS CHIEFS AND STAFFERS
PASSING IN AND OUT GATHERING
TOGETHER SHARING INFORMATION
GOSSIPING SOMETIME SCHEMING
SOMETIMES FEUDING BUT ALWAYS IN
CASE IN A SHARED ENDEAVOR THAT
WHAT FREQUENTLY IN PERFECT IS
NEVERTHELESS FUNDAMENTALLY
NOBLE. THIS IS SOMETHING WORTH
CONSIDERING ESPECIALLY AT THAT
MOMENTS LIKE THIS TODAY THE
LAST CHALLENGING PROSE OF A
LEGISLATIVE SESSION. MARK WITH
HIS IRREPRESSIBLE SPIRIT AND
IT'S ON REBUTTABLE OPTIMISM
NEVER LOST SIGHT OF THIS NOT
ONCE AND FOR THAT. I KNOW I
SPEAK FOR OUR ENTIRE TEAM WHEN
I SAY THAT WE'RE NOT ONLY
BETTER PUBLIC SERVANTS FOR
HAVING HAD THE CHANCE TO SHARE
THAT WITH HIM. BUT BETTER
PEOPLE AS WELL. THIS COMING
SUNDAY SEPTEMBER TWELFTH FAMILY
AND FRIENDS WILL CELEBRATE
MARK'S LIFE. AT ONE THIRTY PM
AT HOLY SPIRIT CHURCH HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. TO BE FOLLOWED BY A
BLOCK PARTY NEAR THE CHURCH ON
WHETHER WAY. HERE THIS MORNING
ON THE LAST DAY OF SESSION.
WE'RE DOING MARCH TOMORROW AT
THE START OF OUR DAY SINCE
NOBODY COULD EVER REALLY SAY
HOW THE LAST DAY OF SESSION.
WILL UNFOLD. AND AS WE MAKE OUR
THROUGH OUR WAY THROUGH THIS
DAY AND BEYOND. LET US HONOR
AND CELEBRATE THE MEMORY AND
SPIRIT. OF MY FRIEND MARK
HANSON. BY DOING GOOD WORK.
WHILE APPRECIATING THE GIFT
WE'VE BEEN GIVEN. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE. AND TO
BUILD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR NEWMAN CENTER- WORK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES- AS SOMEONE WHO'S
KNOWN MARK FOR THE LAST FEW
YEARS IN ORANGE COUNTY. I CAN
TELL YOU MY LIFE IS RICHER FOR
HAVING KNOWN HIM. HE WAS
INCREDIBLY POPULAR AMONG ALL
THE DO GOODERS IN ORANGE COUNTY.
HE WAS AN INSPIRATION TO MY
STAFF AN INSPIRATION TO ME AND
I WILL KERRY. HIS ARM HIS
LEGACY FORD AS BEST AS I AM
ABLE THANK YOU FOR GIVING US
THIS GIFT FOR AS LONG AS WE
HAVE THEM WE WILL ALL MISS HIM
DEEPLY. THANK YOU SENATOR
UMBERG SENATOR ATKINS.
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH. TO
THE SENATORS ARE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY PARTICULARLY HIS
SUPERVISOR- LET ME SAY WHAT AN
INCREDIBLE TRIBUTE OUT YOU DID
TODAY FOR MARK AND HIS FAMILY
AND I FEEL AS THE LEADER OF
THIS HOUSE RESPECTFULLY TO MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ALLOWED ME THIS
THIS PRIVILEGE I FELT IT WAS
IMPORTANT FOR ME TO SPEAK.
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE HIS DEAR
FAMILY IS HERE TODAY AND THAT
WE HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
CELEBRATE AN INCREDIBLE LIFE I
ACTUALLY DID HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET MARK OUR
WEATHER IN THIS BUILDING OR OUT
OF THIS BUILDING- AS THE GOOD
SENATOR- TOLD US OF HIS LIFE
AND I'M SO GLAD WE GOT TO HEAR
THE EXTENDED- REMARKS ABOUT WHO
MARK WAS. IN HIS WORK BECAUSE
IT REALLY IT REALLY DID IN CAPS
LATE THE PHOTO ALONG WITH-
SENATOR NEWMAN'S REMARKS
CAPTURED THIS INDIVIDUAL. I
WANT TO SAY HOW PRIVILEGED IT
IS WHEN YOU GET TO SERVE WITH A
PERSON WHO IS DEDICATED TO
PUBLIC SERVICE AND YOU SEE IT.
AND YOU FEEL IT. HE WAS WORKING
UNTIL THE LAST MINUTES- THAT
EVENING AND I KNOW THAT BECAUSE
WE WERE WORKING ON ISSUES AND
BUDGET AND ALL THE THINGS THAT
WE WORK ON. AND LATE AT NIGHT I
GOT A CALL FROM MY CHIEF OF
STAFF WHO HAD BEEN ON THE PHONE
WITH MARK. NOT THAT MUCH
LONGER- IT WHEN HE SAID TO ME
AND HE WAS PROFOUNDLY SHAKEN.
MY CHIEF OF STAFF WAS
PROFOUNDLY SHAKEN. BECAUSE WHEN
HE LEARNED OF MARK'S PASSING.
YOU STOP YOU KNOW SOMETIMES THE
WORLD HAS TO STOP. FOR A MOMENT
IN THE MIDST OF ALL OF THIS
WORK THAT WE DO THIS IMPORTANT
WORK THAT WE DO. BECAUSE AN%
INCREDIBLE LIGHT AND INCREDIBLE
PUBLIC SERVANT SOMEONE THAT HAD
A LIFE AHEAD OF HIM TO DO SO
MUCH MORE. WAS LOST. AND IT
REALLY ARE AS I THINK ABOUT HOW
MUCH I APPRECIATE MY CHIEF OF
STAFF AND THE FACT THAT HE
KNOWS THE STAFF THAT WORK IN
THIS BUILDING. AND HE KNOWS OF
THEIR POTENTIAL AND THEIR
PROMISE AND THEIR BRILLIANCE.
HE HAD TO STOP THAT NIGHT AND
HE LET ME KNOW- WHAT WAS ON HIS
HEART AND HIS MIND AND I THINK
WE'RE ALL FEELING THAT TODAY
AND I THINK IT'S SO IMPORTANT
FOR MARK'S FAMILY. TO KNOW THAT
THAT MARK HAD MORE THAN ONE
FAMILY. IT'S INCREDIBLE FAMILY
THIS HERE TODAY ALL OF ALL OF
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT US SENATOR
NEWMAN MENTIONED HIS WIFE HIS
PARENTS HIS SIBLINGS HIS
CHILDREN. ALL OF THESE
INCREDIBLE PEOPLE BUT YOU HAVE
A FAMILY HERE TODAY THAT WANTS
TO MAKE SURE IN THE MIDST OF AS
WE- BRING TO CONCLUSION THE
WORK THAT WE DO FOR THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA. THAT
MARK WAS AN INTEGRAL PART OF
THAT AND WE FEEL THAT TODAY AND
WE WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT AND SO
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US
TODAY THANK YOU TO HIS FAMILY
FOR ALLOWING HIS SENATE FAMILY
TO BE PART OF THE CELEBRATION
OF HIS INCREDIBLE LIFE. MAYBE
MORE THAN THIRTY- CENTER ALAN.
PARK WAS ALSO PART OF THE
FAMILY THAT HAS BEEN ALLUDED TO.
RIGHT AND. AND THAT'S A FAMILY
IN WASHINGTON DC IN THE IN THE
LATIN AMERICAN POLICY
COMMUNITY- MARK AND I SHARE
SOMETHING VERY SPECIAL WE BOTH
WORKED WITH THE NATIONAL
DEMOCRATIC INSTITUTE FOR
INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS WHICH IS
A AN INSTITUTION THAT HELPS TO
STRENGTHEN DEMOCRACY AROUND THE
WORLD AND BOTH OF US WORKED ON
ON LATIN AMERICAN PROGRAMS- WE
WOULD RUN INTO THE HALLS HERE
IN THE CAPITAL TALK VERY
FREQUENTLY ABOUT OUR
EXPERIENCES AND- I GOT A TAPE.
MY CONVERSATIONS WITH MARK
WHERE THE MOST SUBSTANTIVE AND
FINDING FRUITFUL OF FINDING ALL
THE CONVERSATIONS I'VE HAD IN
OUR CAPITOL HALLS. I WOULD
SHARE STORIES AND WE HAD SO
MANY MUTUAL FRIENDS. SO I JUST
WANT TO MENTION ON BEHALF OF A
WHOLE WORLD OF PEOPLE WHO LOVE
MARK. IN WASHINGTON DC. AND
ALSO ALL THE FOLKS WHO WORKED
WITHIN LATIN AMERICA. HE SPENT
TIME. WITH THE GOVERNMENT'S
TIGHT TEAM AT AT IN THE EYE IN
TWENTY TEN TWENTY ELEVEN. HE
DID A WHOLE PROJECT INVOLVING
CENTRAL AMERICAN LEGISLATORS
AND- BRING THEM UP HERE TO THE
UNITED STATES HE WORKED ON THE
CUBA PROGRAM AT THE WASHINGTON
OFFICE ON LATIN AMERICA. HI SO
I'VE BEEN IN TOUCH WITH. WITH A
NUMBER OF VERY CLOSE FRIENDS IN
WASHINGTON WHO ARE ABSOLUTELY.
SHOCKED AND SADDENED BY THIS
UNTIMELY LOSS AND SO ON BEHALF
OF THE INDY I COMMUNITY IN THE
DC COMMUNITY THAT HE AND I
SHARED I ALSO WANNA. TO EXPRESS
HOW HOW HOW UNSPEAKABLE TRAGEDY
THIS IS AND WHAT A LOSS THIS IS
FOR. FOR SO MANY PEOPLE ALL
SENATOR ALAN SENATOR MEN. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. BYE I
WANNA THE TOP FIFTY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FULLERTON FOR
HIS ELOQUENT WORDS ON. MARK
MARK THE MORNING TODAY IT WAS
PART OF A NUMBER OF FAMILIES
BUT HE WAS CERTAINLY PART OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY POLITICAL
FAMILY. AND IT WAS IN THAT
CONTEXT OF THE LAST FIVE YEARS
I GOT TO KNOW HIM AND- HE IS
SOMEONE WHO. WHICH JUST
RELENTLESSLY POSITIVE FULL OF
LIFE HE STOOD OUT. BECAUSE OF
THAT THAT SMILE THAT. INABILITY
TO BE DISLIKED THEIR INABILITY
TO- YOU KNOW KERRY NEGATIVITY
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT I'M
GOING TO CARRY AWAY FROM HIM I
NOW THAT. ALL OF US IN ORANGE
COUNTY WE'RE JUST DEVASTATED BY
THIS NEWS AND- I KNOW THERE'S A
CEREMONY COMING UP IN ORANGE
COUNTY THAT WILL BE. INCLUDED
CREDIBLY CROWDED. HE WAS
BELOVED BY ALL WHO KNEW HIM IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND THEN HE IS A
CHERISHED PART OF OUR ORANGE
COUNTY FAMILY AND WE WILL MISS
HIM. THANK YOU SENATOR MEN
CENTER LAYERED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MADAM PRESIDENT- WE HAVE
HEARD VERY ELOQUENTLY ABOUT THE
DIFFERENT FAMILY STEP MARK- WAS
INVOLVED WITH AND ONE OF THEM
WAS IS FOR NUMBER OF YEARS HE
WAS A CONGRESSIONAL ASSISTANT
IN WASHINGTON DC FOR MY CENTRAL
COAST CONGRESSMAN SAM FARR. AND
THE LAST TIME I TALKED TO MARK
HE WAS VERY EXCITED BECAUSE SAM
WAS HAVING HIS EIGHTIETH
BIRTHDAY PARTY IN BIG SUR ON
JULY FOURTH AND HE WENT. AND HE
HAD AN AMAZING TIME AND I HEARD
FROM MANY PEOPLE THAT WERE AT
THAT PARTY. ABOUT THEIR-
CONVERSATIONS HOW GOOD THEY
WERE HOW GREAT IT WAS TO SEE
HIM AND HOW SHOCKED THEY WERE
AND IN PARTICULAR FORMER
CONGRESSMAN FAR WANTED ME TO
PASS ALONG HIS. SINCERE
CONDOLENCES AND HIS GRIEF AT
THE LOSS BECAUSE THEY HAVE SUCH
A CLOSE RELATIONSHIP THAT CAN
DO WORK FOR SO LONG THAT HE
PARTICIPATED IN THAT AND WAS
CONSIDERED PART OF THEIR FAMILY
SO FAR I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THOSE SENTIMENTS WERE EXPRESSED
DURING THE CEREMONY. THANK YOU
SENATOR LAYERED CENTER DOT. YES
I HADN'T INTENDED TO SPEAK
TODAY BUT AFTER SEEING THIS
BEAUTIFUL PICTURE OF MARKET
HERE IN THE ELOQUENT COMMENTS
FROM OUR COLLEAGUE- SENATOR
NEWMAN- I JUST WANT TO RECAP
THE STORY OF MY ENCOUNTER ONE
ENCOUNTER WITH MARK HANSON. AND
YOU GO THROUGH THE HALLS WITH
COVERT WERE ALL MASKED WE TEND
TO JUST WALK BY PEOPLE WE DON'T
NOTICE PEOPLE WITH THIS. I WAS
GOING DOWN THE HALLWAY. AND I
WAS GOING TO BE THAT GUY. THE
USER DOES. THAT'S IT YES YES
I'M MORE CANCER. I THINK HE
FIRST BOUGHT ME DIDN'T SHAKE MY
HEAD OF COURSE BUT- IT BLEW MY
MIND. IT ABOUT THREE MINUTES
LATER WE WERE DONE BUT IT WAS
JUST A FANTASTIC CONVERSATION
HE THANKED ME FOR SOMETHING
THAT I DID THAT AND- I JUST
SAID WOW I. WENT BACK AND TOLD
MY STAFF PERSON THAT WAS IN MY
OFFICE ABOUT THIS ENCOUNTER OF
THIS WONDERFUL GUY. AND THEN
LESS THAN FIVE DAYS LATER WE
HEARD THE NEWS SO HIS FAMILY-
YOU SEVEN AMAZING SON FATHER
HUSBAND- HE WILL BE MISSED.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD CENTER
COM LONGER. JUST WANTED TO-
THANK THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
FULLERTON FOR HIS- ELOQUENT
STATEMENTS AS WELL YOU KNOW
THIS IS ACTUALLY AT MY OFFICE.
QUITE DEEPLY AS A FORMER STAFF
PERSON YOU DEVELOP REALLY CLOSE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH STAFF
MEMBERS FROM OTHER OFFICES. AND
YOU KNOW SENATOR NEWMAN AND I.
HAVE OFFICES RIGHT NEXT TO EACH
OTHER- AND THERE'S SOME QUIET
COMPETITION BECAUSE HE SNATCHED
ONE OF MY LEGISLATIVE STAFFERS
FROM MY OFFICE- BUT GAVE HER A
PROMOTION SO THAT'S OKAY- AND
WHILE I WAS A TAD SALTY. IN THE
BEGINNING- I ENJOYED THE FACT
THAT SHE HAD THIS GREAT
OPPORTUNITY MOSTLY BECAUSE SHE
WAS UNDER THE TUTELAGE OF MARK.
AND HEARING HOW WARM AND
GENEROUS AND KIND HEARTED HE
WAS AS A CHIEF THAT MADE ME
FEEL REALLY GOOD. THAT SHE WAS
GOING TO BE SUPPORTED. BY THIS
KIND OF INDIVIDUAL. WHO WOULD
HELP HER AND WOULD ALSO BRING
SUCH JOY. AND INTEGRITY AND
LOVE TO THAT OFFICE. OUR STAFFS
TALK A LOT. BECAUSE WE ARE SO
CLOSE IN PROXIMITY IN THIS
CAPITAL. AND IT HAS BEEN REALLY
TOUGH. FLORIDA'S STAFF IN THIS
BUILDING. BECAUSE THE WORDS
THAT KEEP COMING TO ME ABOUT
HIM. OUR HELP. AND GENEROUS HE
IS. HOW WARM HEARTED HE IS
ALWAYS WALK IN WITH A SMILE
ALWAYS LEADING WITH GENEROSITY
THE NICEST THE WARMEST SOUL.
AND SO THERE'S ALWAYS A REASON
WHY OUR UNIVERSE FIRE GOD TAKES
FOLKS WHEN WE THINK THEY SHOULD
STILL BE WITH US AND WE MAY NOT
ALWAYS KNOW WHAT THAT REASON IS
I HAVE TO BELIEVE. THAT THIS
ANGEL WAS NEEDED SOMEPLACE ELSE
BUT I JUST WANNA SHARE AS
SOMEONE WHO. CARES DEEPLY ABOUT
THE STAFF COME IN ALL OF OUR
OFFICES AND UNDERSTAND THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT THEY HAVE
WITH ONE ANOTHER. HOW
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT THIS LOSS
HAS BEEN. BECAUSE HE WAS AN
IMMENSELY GENEROUS SOUL AND HE
WILL BE MISSED BEYOND MEASURE.
THANK YOU SENATOR COM LONGER
CENTER PAM. THANK YOU SORRY I
MISSED READ THAT I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF THE MEMBERS WHO'VE
SPOKEN OUT SO KINDLY AND- JUST
WHEN THE STATE IS FAMILY HE WAS
ONE OF THE GOOD ONES BUT YOU
KNEW THAT. SENATOR NEWMAN
PLEASE BRING HIS NAME FORWARD
SO THE ME PROBABLY MORE OR LESS
BUT CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
MEMBERS MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED RED.
WE'RE MOVING TO MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AT NOTICES MEMBERS
THIS WOULD BE THE APPROPRIATE
TIME TO MOVE ANYTHING TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. DOES ANYONE HAVE
ANYTHING THEY WISH TO REMOVE
SENATOR HERTZBERG. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I HAVE TO.
MATTERS TO THE DESK AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR. PLEASE
MOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO THE
INACTIVE FILE MEANING WE HAVE
TO LESS BILLS TO DEAL WITH
TODAY. FOLLOW AT AND RESEARCH
BEFORE EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL WAS
FILED IN THIRTY FOUR A. B.
NINETY NINE. AND NEXT I'LL FILE
NUMBER I OR A ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY FIVE WHICH IS A B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR ALSO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THIS CALL
NOTHING CENTER HURTS PERSONALLY
KNOWN. THE AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE
FILE ITEM TO AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SIX DOWN TO THE INACTIVE FILE
THE DESK ONE OF THE SUNDERLAND
OWN MEMBERS ANYTHING ELSE. ALL
RIGHT WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
SENATE JOURNALS FOR SEPTEMBER
SEVEN THROUGH TEN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
MEMBERS WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE
TO CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE NO WE ARE NOT ONE MOMENT
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
RULES WILL BE SUSPENDED FOR THE
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENT. FOR THE
FOLLOWING MEASURE ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOUR NINETY EIGHT. NOW WE'RE
MOVING TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO SECOND READING MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RING. ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE SIXTY ONE ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX. THE
SECOND READING FOR HOURS DEEMED
RED MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. AND
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM THIRTY ONE SENATOR TO
RUSSELL. YES I'M VALERIE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ
AN ACT RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT
SENATOR RUSSELL. OKAY OKAY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. I
RISE TO PRESENT A LATINO CAUCUS
PRIORITY BILL AB TEN SEVENTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN GONZALEZ
THIS BILL SUPPORTS OUR STATE'S
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. BY BY
ENSURING THAT HOTEL WORKERS ARE
AFFORDED THE SAME
ACCOMMODATIONS CURRENTLY
PROVIDED THE JANITORIAL AND
BUILDING MAINTENANCE SERVICE
WORKERS UNDER THE DISPLACED
JANITOR OPPORTUNITY ACT. THAT
LAW WAS ESTABLISHED TWENTY
YEARS AGO TO MINIMIZE THE
IMMEDIATE DISPLACEMENT OF AN
ENTIRE WORK FORCE WHEN THERE IS
A CHANGE IN THE SERVICE
CONTRACTORS WHAT TWENTY FIVE OR
MORE EMPLOYEES. AB TEN SEVENTY
FOUR MAKES A NARROW CHANGE BY
SIMPLY ADDING SIMILARLY
SITUATED HOTEL SERVICE WORKERS
TO THIS EXISTING LAW THIS
ENSURES HOTEL WORKERS HAVE A
REASONABLE TRANSITION PERIOD.
CAN CONTINUE WORKING UNDER THE
NEW CONTRACTOR GIVEN THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT KOPEN
HOSPITALITY WORKFORCE WE MUST
MINIMIZE ANY FURTHER
DISPLACEMENT OF JOBS IN THIS
SECTOR AS THESE WORKERS ARE
GETTING BACK ON THEIR FEET.
EXISTING LAW HAS PROVEN
SUCCESSFUL IN THE JANITORIAL
INDUSTRY FOR DECADES A. B. TEN
SEVENTY FOUR SIMPLY TAKES THAT
APPROACH AND TARGET TARGETS OF
SIMILAR LOW WAGE WORKFORCE MADE
UP PREDOMINANTLY OF LATINA
WOMEN. PROVIDING THESE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS WITH A MODEST
LEVEL OF JOB SECURITY IS
FUNDAMENTALLY FAIR AND CRITICAL
TO STABILIZING JOBS IN THE
SECTOR. HAVING COME OUT OF THE
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY I SAW A
COUPLE OF DECADES AGO THE
IMPACT I WENT THROUGH THIS SIDE
BY SIDE WITH HOTEL WORKERS WHO
HAD. NOTHING TO DO WASN'T
BECAUSE OF THEM DOING ANYTHING
WRONG WHEN THERE WAS A CHANGE
IN THEIR MANAGEMENT. THAT THEY
WOULD BE DISPLACED IN LARGE
NUMBERS WHAT ACTUALLY LED TO
THIS IN LOS ANGELES PASSING AN
ORDINANCE IN LOS ANGELES WAS
ONE CASE IN PARTICULAR. ADD VIA
COVERED THE AIRPORT FOUR FOUR
FIVE HUNDRED WORKERS WERE FIRED
OVERNIGHT BECAUSE THE
CONTRACTOR MANAGEMENT HAD
CHANGED. THAT IS WHAT LED BAND
AND TRIGGERED A SERIES OF
WARDEN IS BEING PASSED IN THE
NUMBER OF CITIES OF THIS IS
AGAIN TO ALLOW THEM TO CONTINUE
TO WORK. THROUGH NO- NO
RESPONSIBILITY NOTHING THEY DID
WRONG THAT THEY WOULD CONTINUE
TO WORK- AND BE GIVEN A FAIR
OPPORTUNITY- TO SHOW THAT THEY
CAN DO THE WORK OF FOR SIXTY
DAYS SO- COLLEAGUES I
APPRECIATE YOUR VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU CENTER
DRAWS SO MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA ATKINS I FACE. BACKER
HI FOR JUST KNOW BRADFORD. I
COME BY ADAM. WE CORTESE HI
DOLLY NO GOD. NO TORONTO HI
ADNAN LASER. NOW OPENS ALL THIS
HIGH GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG HI
WITH SO HI FOR TITLES. NO JONES
NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI
LLEVA HI THE MON HI WIRE. I
MELINDA'S NO MAN. NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO A CHARTEROAK NO PAM.
PORTS AND TINA. RALPH HI RUBIO.
SKINNER. HI STERN AMBERG. WHITE
HOUSE SKI I WINNER I WILL. NO
SENATOR MOVES A CALL MEMBERS
WE'RE PUTTING ALL BILLS ON CALL
RIGHT NOW AS WE DO NOT HAVE ALL
MEMBERS ON THE FLOOR MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM THIRTY SIX SENATOR
MCGUIRE AND SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOOD AN ACT
RELATING TO COMMUNICATIONS.
CENTER REQUIRE. GOOD MORNING MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS-
PRESIDENT EIGHTY FORTY ONE ON
BEHALF OF A SIN NUMBER JIM
WOULD IF WE'RE GONNA REPLACE IF
GOING TO BRIDGE THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE WE NEED TO FIRST TO FIND
THE PROBLEM THAT WE'RE FACING-
AND THAT STARTS WITH BETTER
MAPPING. DECEMBER WOULD HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS BILL FOR
QUITE SOME TIME- IN CANDIDLY
THE MAPS THAT WE HAVE TODAY
THEY'RE FLAT WRONG WHEN IT
COMES A BROAD BAND- AND HE
INVITES ANY AND EVERY ONE OF
THE SENATE. TO BE ABLE TO COME
TAKE A LOOK AT THE CHALLENGES
THE NORTH COAST FACES AND OR
THE REST OF RURAL CALIFORNIA
WE'RE INVESTING SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IN BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND IT WOULD BE
IRRESPONSIBLE TO NOT HAVE
BETTER MAPS AS WE MAKE THIS.
GENERATIONAL INVESTMENT ON
BEHALF OF A SIMILAR VIRGIN
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPHONE. THANK YOU CENTER
REQUIRE MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
HI ATKINS I FACE HI BECKER. HI
PORCHES HI BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM I PROTESTING I. DALI I DON.
I ARRIVE SOON HI AIKMAN LASER
HI CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH. I
PURCHASED BERG HI WHERE SOME.
HER TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER
I LAYERED I LLEVA HI THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S I MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON I WOULD SHOW UP
BOTH I PAM. I PERSONS YOU KNOW.
RALPH I REVIEW FIVE SKINNER. I
STERN I'M BERG HI I LIKE HOW
SKI. FIVE WINNERS. ALL MEMBERS
WERE NOW MOVING TO FILE ITEM
FORTY SENATOR WIENER. PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE THIRTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CORIO
AN ACT RELATING TO IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT SENATOR WIENER. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT ARE COLLEAGUES I AM
TODAY PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE THIRTY SEVEN DIVISION ACTS
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CARDIO. THIS LEGISLATION WILL
PROTECT INCARCERATED REFUGEE
AND IMMIGRANT CALIFORNIANS WHO
HAVE BEEN DEEMED ELIGIBLE FOR
REHABILITATION AND RELEASE I
WILL PREVENT THEM FROM BEING
FUNNELED INTO THE IMMIGRATION
DEPORTATION. SYSTEM IN RECENT
YEARS- THE LEGISLATURE AND
CALIFORNIA VOTERS HAVE
DEMONSTRATED A COMMITMENT AND A
WILLINGNESS TO REFORM OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM TO END
MASS INCARCERATION. AND TO
PROTECT IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES.
HOWEVER FOR IMMIGRANTS EARN
RELEASE SENATOR WIENER YES I
APOLOGIZE GREATLY I'M GOING TO
ASK YOU TO PLEASE STOP WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE THIS MEASURE UP
LATER OKAY SCIENTOLOGY NICE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER
MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM THIRTY NINE SENATOR
AYERED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MARAT SUSHI AN ACT RELATING TO
GREENHOUSE GASES CENTER LAYERED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MMHM MADAM
CHAIR- THIS BILL IS THE CLIMATE
CRISIS BACKED BY SENATOR MARK
SHOES SUSHI AND OTHER AUTHORS
OF THE CLIMATE CRISIS THAT WE
ARE FACING RIGHT NOW IS JUST
REACHING EPIC PROPORTIONS. TO
AVERT THE MOST CATASTROPHIC
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE WE
MUST LIMIT ATMOSPHERIC WARMING
TO ONE POINT FIVE DEGREES
CELSIUS WHICH NECESSITATES
CALIFORNIA REACHING NET ZERO
EMISSIONS BY MID CENTURY.
FURTHER THE INTERGOVERNMENTAL
PANEL ON CLIMATE CHANGE
RECENTLY RELEASED THE FIRST
PORTION OF THE SIX TO SUSSMAN
REPORT ON HOW CLIMATE CHANGE IS
ALTERING THE PLANET'S NATURAL
SYSTEMS AND WORSENING. EXTREME
WEATHER EVENTS AROUND THE WORLD
THAT WAS WITNESSED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. WHEN I WAS
SECRETARY FOR NATURAL
RESOURCES- I DID WORK WITH THE
STATE OF NEVADA ON LAKE TAHOE
AND THE SCIENTISTS TOLD US.
THAT LIKE TAHOE WAS HEATING
FASTER THAN ANY FRESH WATER
LAKE ON THE FACE OF THE PLANET.
WHEN WE- VISIT- OF MY FAMILY
GLACIER PARK WE WERE BASICALLY
TOLD GLAD YOU GOT HERE THE
GLACIERS WILL NOT BE HERE AND
ASSUME NUMBER OF YEARS. WHEN WE
EXPERIENCED A FIRE THAT WENT
FROM CALISTOGA TO SANTA ROSA A
FEW YEARS AGO. IT WENT IN
SOMETHING LIKE SIX HOURS AND A
FIRE ON THE SAME FOOT PRINT IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR TO TWO AND
A HALF DAYS. THE FIRE IN
PARADISE- WAS SOMETHING THAT
YES THERE IS- EIGHTY OR NINETY
YEARS OF FIRE SUPPRESSION BUT
IT BROUGHT UP AGAINST THE
CHANGES IN CLIMATE. AND THE
FACT THAT THAT FAR REMOVED
SIXTY ACRES A MINUTE AND YOU
COULD NOT OUTRUN IT WAS IN PART
DUE TO THE CONDITIONS CREATED
BY CLIMATE AND RIGHT NOW WE'RE
IN A DROUGHT. AND WE'RE IN THE
SECOND YEAR OF THE DROUGHT AND
YEP WE HAVE PASSED WHERE WE
WERE IN THE FOURTH YEAR OF THE
DROUGHT FROM TWENTY ELEVEN TO
TWENTY FIFTEEN. IN MY OWN
DISTRICT LAST YEAR I WAS IN SAN
LUIS OBISPO WHEN THEY RECORDED
A TEMPERATURE OF A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY DEGREES. IT IS
HAPPENING. AND IT IS HAPPENING
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE HAVE
TO TAKE ACTION. AN ACCOUNT. HAS
A HISTORY OF SETTING GOALS AND
USING GOALS AS THE MEANS TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES I RECALL
BEING A CITY COUNCIL MEMBER.
BUT WHEN THIS LEGISLATURE
PASSED AND THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
A GOAL TO DIVERT 50% FROM MORE.
OF WASTE DIVERSION FROM
LANDFILLS IN CALIFORNIA AND I
THOUGHT AT THE TIME GREAT GOAL
IT'LL NEVER HAPPEN. AND YET-
THAT BILL GAVE THE TOOLS TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND WE MET
THE GOAL AND WE EXCEEDED IT. I
WAS ONE OF THE EARLY CO AUTHORS
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX OF A. B.
THIRTY TWO. AND WHAT I B.
THIRTY TWO DID THIS WITH OUR
NATIONAL GOVERNMENT WALKING
AWAY FROM THE KYOTO ACCORDS. WE
PUT THE KYOTO ACCORDS INTO LAW
IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE SAID THAT
BY TWENTY TWENTY WE WOULD GO
BACK TO THE MISSIONS. THAT
EXISTED IN THIS STATE IN
NINETEEN NINETY AND TWENTY
TWENTY WE MET THAT GOAL. THEN
GOVERNOR BROWN IN TWENTY ELEVEN
SIGN THE BILL. THAT SAID WE
WOULD GO 233% RENEWABLES AND
OUR ELECTRICITY PORTFOLIO BY
TWENTY TWENTY PEOPLE SAID
THAT'LL BE A HARD GOAL. WE HAVE
MET THAT GOAL. SO BASICALLY
WHAT THIS BILL IS THE NEXT STEP
IN THAT PROCESS. THERE ARE
THREE MAIN PARTS OF THIS BILL
THAT CODIFIES CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO REACH CARBON
NEUTRALITY. BY OR BEFORE TWENTY
FORTY FIVE. REACH CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY REDUCING
STATEWIDE EMISSIONS BY 90% OF
THE NINETY. NINETY NINETY LEVEL
BY OR BEFORE TWENTY FORTY FIVE
THROUGH DIRECT EMISSION
REDUCTIONS CARBON CAPTURE AND
STORAGE AND REMOVAL
TECHNOLOGIES. NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS. AND THIRD
ESTABLISH STANDARDS AND
GUARDRAILS TO ENSURE THAT THESE
TECHNOLOGIES A C. ACHIEVE REAL
MEASURABLE VERIFIABLE CARBON
REDUCTIONS. CALIFORNIA'S BEHIND
THE OTHERS OTHER STATES
WASHINGTON ADOPTED A LAW ON
TWENTY TWENTY NEW YORK. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN MESSAGE USE
INTO TWENTY. ALL WITH GOALS OF
REDUCING EMISSIONS BY TWENTY
FIFTY- THIS IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO GIVEN. THE CURRENT
CLIMATE SITUATION AND I WOULD
ASK FOR YOUR I. PHONE. FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE CENTERMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. AND I
KNOW THAT A LOT OF CONCERNS
AROUND THE IMPACTS OF THE SPILL
ON OUR ECONOMY ON OUR JOBS. BUT
I WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS AND
ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH
THOSE FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA CRUZ WE'RE IN A CLIMATE
EMERGENCY. WE ARE LIVING
THROUGH A TIME OF INCREDIBLE
AND FRIGHTENING CHANGES TO OUR
CLIMATE. TWENTY TWENTY ONE HAS
BEEN THE HOTTEST YEAR ON
RECORD. WE'VE HAD MORE INTENSE
HURRICANES AND DROUGHTS AND
EVER BEFORE OUR FORCE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ARE DRIER THAN EVER
IN RECORDED HISTORY LEADING TO
MASSIVE WILDFIRES THAT WERE
BARELY CONTROLLING. I WANT TO
POINT OUT SOMETHING THAT I
DON'T THINK HAS BEEN MENTIONED
IN THE MANY FLOOR DEBATES OVER
CLIMATE. TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS
ALMOST CERTAINLY GOING TO BE
ONE OF THE COOLEST YEARS THAT
WE EXPERIENCE OVER THE NEXT
HUNDRED YEARS. OWNER PETER
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WILL ALMOST
CERTAINLY BE THE COOLEST YEAR
ON RECORD A HUNDRED YEARS FROM
NOW. NO MATTER WHAT WE DO TODAY
EVEN IF WE GET CARBON EMISSIONS
DOWN TO ZERO. OUR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN LOOK BACK AT
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS A YEAR.
THAT WAS UNIQUELY COOL ONE WITH
UNIQUELY BENIGN WEATHER EVENTS.
THE HURRICANES THE WILD FIRES
THE HEAT WAVES TO DROUGHTS.
THAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING RIGHT
NOW WILL SEEM LIKE THE GOOD OLD
DAYS. WE TALK ABOUT THE TIPPING
POINT AND WHETHER WE MIGHT
REACH THE TIPPING POINT BUT IF
WE'RE BEING HONEST WITH
OURSELVES WE ALREADY PAST THE
TIPPING POINT. AT THE IPCC
CONCLUDED EARLIER THIS YEAR.
EVEN UNDER THE BEST CASE
SCENARIOS FOR REDUCE OUR
CLIMATE EMISSIONS RADICALLY.
WE'RE STILL GOING TO FACE
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN
TEMPERATURES OF THE NEXT
CENTURY. THAT WILL LEAD TO
CATASTROPHIC CONSEQUENCES. SO
THIS ISN'T ABOUT WHETHER WE
MIGHT REACH A THEORETICAL
TIPPING POINTS ABOUT HOW FAR
PAST THE TIPPING POINT WE'RE
GOING TO GO. AND IF WE DON'T
MAKE CHANGES NOW OR WE ONLY
MAKE MINIMAL CHANGES. WE'RE
LOOKING AT A LONG RUN INCREASE
OF OVER TEN DEGREES FAHRENHEIT
IN AVERAGE TEMPERATURE. THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE HOTTER
THAN EVER IN HUMAN EXISTENCE.
IT HASN'T BEEN THAT HOT IN
THREE MILLION YEARS. WE ARE
TERRAFORMING A PLANET RIGHT NOW
UNLESS WE CHANGE COURSE AND
QUICKLY MUCH OF OUR PLANTS
GOING UNINHABITABLE. PERHAPS IN
MY LIFETIME CERTAINLY WITHIN A
COUPLE GENERATIONS. THIS BILL
IS A MORAL IMPERATIVE. I'VE GOT
CHILDREN I KNOW MANY OF YOU
HAVE CHILDREN MY CHILDREN ARE
TEN EIGHT AND FIVE. THEY CANNOT
VOTE. CANNOT LOBBY YOU. CANNOT
DONATE YOUR CAMPAIGNS ARE FUN
AND I EAT A SUPPORT YOU. MAYBE
MY KIDS WILL HAVE KIDS OF THEIR
OWN AND THOSE KIDS DOWN THE
LINE THEY ALSO CAN'T VOTER
INFLUENCE PUBLIC POLICY. BUT
THESE CHILDREN. THEIR CHILDREN
THE CHILDREN OF THE FUTURE. WHO
HAVE NO VOICE IN OUR POLITICAL
PROCESS WE KNOW WHAT THEY NEED
AND WANT FROM US TODAY. BECAUSE
UNLESS WE CHANGE COURSE AND
AGGRESSIVELY SO WE ARE THEM TO
FUTURE OF MISERY AND HELL. OUR
FUTURE PROGENY WILL EXPERIENCE
HEAT WAVES THAT REGULARLY REACH
A HUNDRED FORTY DEGREES. THEY
WILL FACE MORE AND MORE EXTREME
HURRICANES WILDFIRES TORNADOES
AND DROUGHTS. THAT LOOK
ABSOLUTELY BIBLICAL IN
COMPARISON TO WHAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING RIGHT NOW. THEY'LL
FIGHT WARS OVER RESOURCES THAT
WE TAKE FOR GRANTED TODAY.
WATER FOOD INHABITABLE LAND.
NOW I UNDERSTAND THE PRESSURE
WE'RE ALL FACING TODAY. THERE
IS A LOT OF OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. THERE IS A LOT OF
LEGITIMATE CONCERN ABOUT THE
IMPACTS THE AGGRESSIVE CLIMATE
MANDATES MAY HAVE ON OUR
ECONOMY AND OUR JOBS. BUT I
WOULD ASK YOU TO WEIGH THIS
AGAINST THE FUTURE WELL BEING
OF OUR KIDS OUR GRANDKIDS OUR
PROGENY. THE ONES THAT HAVE NO
POLITICAL POWER AND NO VOICE.
WHO ARE URGING YOU TO TAKE
ACTION WITH THIS VOTE. WE KNOW
THE COST IS A CLIMATE CHANGE WE
KNOW WHAT WE HAVE TO DO TO
PREVENT THIS APOCALYPTIC FUTURE
FROM HAPPENING. BUT WE NEED THE
COURAGE TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
NOW MANY OF YOU HEARD. ME SAY
THIS QUOTE FROM THE ANCIENT
GREEKS. A CIVILIZATION IS GREAT
WHEN ITS ELDERS PLANT TREES
WHOSE SHADE THEY KNOW THEY WILL
NEVER. SIT UNDER. TODAY I'M
ASKING YOU TO PLANT THOSE TREES
BECAUSE WE ARE FACING. THE
WORST POSSIBLE FUTURE UNLESS WE
ACT AGGRESSIVELY WE HAVE TO ERR
ON THE SIDE WITH. THE
PROGRESSIVE POLICY RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NASTIER I
VOTE. SENATOR LEYVA. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS I'M PROUD TO STAND IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE MEMBERS CLIMATE CHANGE IS
REAL AND IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE
DEAL WITH THESE WORSENING
IMPACTS OF THIS CRISIS
IMMEDIATELY AND DECISIVELY.
THOUGH SOME OF MAY BELIEVE OR
ARGUE THAT WHAT IS HAPPENING
NOW IS NOT AS POTENTIALLY
DEVASTATING THAT'S WHAT
SCIENTISTS AND EXPERTS SAY I
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE DEPENDS ON
WHAT WE KNEW ABOUT. EVEN JUST
THE MOST RECENT DEVASTATING
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
CREATE A CLEAR COMPARISON FROM
JUST ONE YEAR AGO. FIRES FLOODS
HURRICANES AND OTHER WEATHER
PHENOMENA ARE NOW TRULY
HISTORIC AND ONLY GETTING
WORSE. FROM THE COUNTER FIRE
JUST UP THE ROAD FROM US TO THE
DIXIE FIRE WHICH HAS BECOME
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST SINGLE
WILDFIRE IN STATE HISTORY. THE
HURRICANE IDA THE TERRIBLE
FLOODING UP THE EASTERN
SEABOARD IT IS CLEAR THAT WE
MUST ACT NOW. AND ON THE AIR
QUALITY FRONT ACCORDING TO THE
AIR QUALITY LIFE INDEX BY
UNIVERSITY OF CHICAGO
RESEARCHERS LIFE EXPECTANCY
LOSS MAKES PARTICULATE
POLLUTION MORE DEVASTATING AND
COMMUNICORP BEND COMPUTER
CALLED DISEASES. LIKE
TUBERCULOSIS HIV AND AIDS
BEHAVIORAL KILLERS LIKE
CIGARETTES CIGARETTE SMOKING
AND EVEN WAR BUT THAT SINK IN
PARTICULATE MATTER IS WORSE
THAN ALL OF THESE THINGS THAT
WE HAVE KNOWN FOR YEARS CAUSE
OF DEATH. MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
HAS TAKEN MANY IMPORTANT AND
HISTORIC STEPS IN RECENT YEARS
TO ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE AN AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE ANY VITAL
NEXT STEP. IN THAT PROCESS WILL
FURTHER PROTECT CALIFORNIA FROM
THE DEVASTATING IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE. I JUST WANT TO
SAY TO MY FRIENDS IN LABOR I
WANT TO MAKE A COMMITMENT TO
YOU. THAT WE WILL BE WORKING
GOING FORWARD TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE GREEN JOBS ARE GOOD JOBS
THAT THEY ARE UNION JOBS AND I
KNOW THAT IT'S A WORRY I
UNDERSTAND THAT. TO HAVE A JOB
THAT IS A GOOD PAYING JOB THAT
IS SCARY TO THINK THAT IT MIGHT
NOT BE THERE. BUT WE HAVE TO
ACT BUT WE HAVE TO CHANGE AND I
COMMIT TO ALL OF YOU THAT I
WILL WORK HARD AS LONG AS I'M
IN THE SENATE AND OUT OF THE
SENATE TO MAKE SURE AS WE
TRANSITION TO CLEAN JOBS. THOSE
ARE GOOD UNION LIVING WAGE JOBS.
MEMBERS I THINK ABOUT IN TEN
YEARS FROM NOW. MY
GRANDCHILDREN WILL BE ELEVEN
AND TWELVE LITTLE NIGGLES
BIRTHDAY IS TODAY HE'S ONE YEAR
OLD. WHEN THEY LOOK AT ME AND
THEY SAY NANA WHEN YOU WERE A
SENATOR DID YOU DO EVERYTHING
TO SAVE THE PLANET. I WANT TO
BE A LOOK AT THEM AS A YES NANA
DID EVERYTHING SHE COULD TO
SAVE THE PLANET. I RESPECTFULLY
OFFER NOT ABOUT. SENATOR ALAN.
MEMBERS ALL RIGHT I HAVE A
SMALL CHILD. OUR COLLEAGUE IS-
LITERALLY AT HIS WIFE'S BED
TODAY. AS SHE GIVES BIRTH TO A-
BEAUTIFUL LITTLE CHILD. I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PLAY WITH
THE- KNICKS BEAUTIFUL LITTLE
GIRL THESE- THIS IS OUR SENATE
FAMILY THESE ARE THESE LITTLE
ONES WHO ARE. COMING UP. AND
THE KIND OF WORLD THAT WE'RE
GIVING TO THEM. IS ONE THAT IS
VERY MUCH IN JEOPARDY IT'S IN
DANGER. HI WE ARE STARTING TO
SEE TRENDS ON OUR PLANET THAT.
SHOCKED US ALL. THE SPEED WITH
WHICH- PUTTING A STAR TO TAKE
PLACE IN PLACES WE NEVER HAD
BEFORE FIRES HAVE YOU SEEN HERE
IN OUR OWN STATE. THE AMOUNT OF
PROPERTY THAT'S NOW. AT RISK ON
COASTLINES. REMEMBER THIS IS A
REASONABLE BILL GIVEN THE
ENORMITY OF THE CHALLENGE.
THERE'S A BILL WITH PROBABLY
TWO WEEK A TIME LINE. IT'S A
BILL THAT. GIVES A LOT OF
DISCRETION. TO THE AIR BOARD TO
DO WHAT HE NEEDS TO DO TO. MAKE
SURE THE CALIFORNIA'S AT THE
HEAD OF THE LINE IN TERMS OF
INNOVATION. THERE WILL BE LOTS
OF OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THE TRANSITION THAT TAKES
PLACE UNDER. THE WORK. WILL IT
WILL BE JUST. THERE'S NO REASON
WHY CALIFORNIA CAN'T CONTINUE
TO BE A MAJOR INNOVATOR AND JOB
CREATOR AS WE COME ALONG AND
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WAYS TO HELP
SOLVE THIS CRISIS. AND BY THE
WAY THIS BILL PROVIDES JOB
OPPORTUNITIES IN OUR OIL SECTOR
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY IT'S
ACTUALLY BEEN AN ISSUE FOR A
CONTROVERSY ON THE PROGRESSIVE
SIDE BUT THERE'S LANGUAGE IN
HERE THAT ALLOWS FOR. CARBON
CAPTURE WHICH I KNOW IT'S BEEN
INCREDIBLY CONTROVERSIAL BUT
IT'S SOMETHING IT'S VERY
MEANINGFUL TO MANY MANY PEOPLE
AROUND OUR STATE AND OF COURSE
IT'S A TECHNIQUE THAT COULD END
UP BECOMING A REALLY IMPORTANT
TOOL IN OUR TOOL KIT AS WE TRY
TO COMBAT CLIMATE CHANGE. IN
ORDER TO REACH CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE
WE NEED TO WORK ON EMISSIONS
REDUCTION WE NEED TO WORK ON.
CCS INNOVATION. NATURAL CARBON
SINKS. THIS BILL IS GOING TO.
SET US ON COURSE. FOR THE FOR
THE INVESTMENT THE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILD OUT THAT
WILL. LET GIVE US A FIGHTING
CHANCE. TO STAND SOME OF THESE
INCREDIBLY DISTURBING TRENDS. I
JUST INVITE FOLKS TO READ SOME
OF THE SCIENCE READ THE
PREDICTIONS ABOUT WHAT LIFE
WILL LOOK LIKE ON OUR PLANET
203-040-5070 YEARS FROM NOW AND
THEN THINK ABOUT THESE LITTLE
BABIES. YOUR GRANDCHILDREN OUR
CHILDREN WHAT KIND OF LIFE WERE
HANDED TO THEM WHAT SORT OF
LEGACY AND WHAT SORT OF
CONVERSATION WE ALL WANT TO
HAVE WITH THEM AS WE END OUR
OWN LIVES. ABOUT THE WORK WE
DID TO MAKE SURE THE LIFE WOULD
BE BETTERFOR THEM THAT'S WHY
WE NEED BILLS LIKE THIS IS A
BOLD BILL. BUT THE PROBLEM IS
SO ENORMOUS. THAT WE'VE GOT TO
TAKE A STEP LIKE THIS AND SO I
STRONGLY STRONGLY URGE YOUR
COLLEAGUES FOR OUR FUTURE
PLEASE. SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE AS A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR OF THE
LEGISLATION AND I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUES FOR SO
ARTICULATELY- DESCRIBING THE
STAKES HERE YOU KNOW SO I THINK
SOMETIMES WHEN IT COMES TO
CLIMATE CHANGE IT'S SO EASY FOR
US FOR OUR SOCIETY TO OUR
PLANET IT HAS TO BECOME LIKE A
DEER CAUGHT IN HEADLIGHTS. YOU
SEE THIS TRUST DISASTER
ABSOLUTE DISASTER COMING OUR
WAY AND WE'RE SEEING WHAT THAT
DISASTER HEALTH DISASTER
MANIFESTS IN OUR DAILY LIVES
WITH THE ORANGE SKIES ND THE
POSSIBILITY OF A LITERALLY
RUNNING OUT OF WATER AND THE
SUPER. STORMS AND I CAN GO ON
AND ON AND ON. WE SEE IT COMING.
BUT IT'S JUST SO BIG THAT WE
FREEZE. AND WE EITHER DO
NOTHING OR WE NIBBLE AROUND THE
EDGES. AND IF WE- GIVE A EXCUSE
MY LANGUAGE ABOUT THE FUTURE OF
THIS PLANET. THEN IT'S TIME TO
GO BIG AND GO BOLD WHEN IT
COMES TO CLIMATE CHANGE. NOT
TOMORROW OR A YEAR OR TEN YEARS
FROM NOW BUT NOW THAT I KNOW
THE POLITICS ARE HARD. BECAUSE
MEANINGFULLY ADDRESSING CLIMATE
CHANGE MEANS THAT WE HAVE TO DO
THINGS DIFFERENTLY IN OUR WORLD
AND OUR DAILY LIVES IN TERMS OF
OUR ECONOMY. IT MEANS THINGS
HAVE TO BE DONE DIFFERENTLY AND
THAT IS HARD THOSE TRANSITIONS
ARE HARD AND I DON'T WANT TO
MINIMIZE THAT PAIN THAT THOSE
TRANSITIONS CAN CAUSE. BUT
WHAT'S THE ALTERNATIVE. JUST TO
ALLOW THE SLOW MOVING TRAIN
WRECK TO CONTINUE TO BECOME A
VERY FAST MOVING TRAIN WRECK
AND THEN WE DRIVE A CAR TRULY
INTO THE DITCH. I DON'T WANT A
FUTURE FOR OUR PLANET. THAT IS
DRAMATICALLY WORSE THAN WE'RE
ALREADY SEEING RIGHT NOW I
DON'T WANT TO I DON'T THINK
ANYONE WANTS TO AND IT'S TIME
TO TAKE BOLD ACTION. I DO WANT
TO SERVICE ADDRESS- IN TERMS OF
JOBS IN THE ECONOMY AND I HAVE
ENORMOUS RESPECT. FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING IN THE
FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY UNDER
DOING THAT HARD WORK- AND I'VE
WORKED VERY HARD TO GET THOSE
GOOD PAYING JOBS- AND I HAVE
ENORMOUS RESPECT. FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. BUT WE ALSO NEED
TO LOOK AT THE HARM TO OUR
ECONOMY AND JOBS THAT
UNCONTROLLED CLIMATE CHANGE. IS
DOING TO THE ATTIC IN THE
STREET. WHICH IS BEING
DECIMATED BY CLIMATE CHANGE.
TWO ARE HEADED TO HOUSING. THE
PEOPLE WHO BUILD HOUSING WHEN
MORE AND MORE PARTS OF THE
STATE ARE GONNA BE UNTENABLE TO
EVEN BUILD ANY HOUSING. BECAUSE
OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE RISKS
OF WILDFIRES AND SEA LEVEL
RISE. TO OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
WHICH IS GOING TO BE OVERRUN.
BY THE HEALTH IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. WHICH IS
ALREADY BEING DAMAGE AND WILL
BE A HUGE RISK AND OF COURSE
ANY INDUSTRY. THAT RELIES ON
WATER. AND THERE ARE A LOT OF
THEM. WE ALSO KNOW THE CLIMATE
CHANGE DISPROPORTIONATELY HARMS
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHETHER
PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING IN IN LOW
LYING AREAS AND ARE SUBJECT TO
SEA LEVEL RISE PEOPLE ON
COMMUNITIES THAT RUN OUT OF
WATER. IT CETERA TO COLLEAGUES
AND DID THIS IN A WAY
UNDERSTANDS POLITICALLY THIS IS
A HARD BILL- BUT IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IT'S NOT AND
I ASKED FOR AN IPO. SENATOR
BAKER. MEMBERS THREE FIVE
SAYING AROUND HERE THIS IS A
SIMPLE BILL. AND WHY DO I SAY
THAT BECAUSE THE SIMPLY ASK THE
QUESTION ARE WE SERIOUS ABOUT
GETTING TO CARBON NEUTRALITY.
BECAUSE IF WE ARE THEN WE CAN
QUIBBLE ABOUT THE TIME LINE
WASHINGTON STATE HAS SAID 95%
REDUCTION BY TWENTY FIFTY. NEW
YORK STATE 85% BY TWENTY
FIFTEEN MASSACHUSETTS 85% BY
TWENTY FIFTY THIS BILL IS 90%
DIRECT EMISSIONS BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE. BUT IT ALSO ALLOWS
AN OFFRAMP FROM AIR RESOURCES
BOARD. AND I'D BE HAPPY THAT
WAS MOVED UP IN THAT IT ALLOWS
AN OFFERING FOR THE IRISES
EVEREST RESOURCE SUPPORT SAY IS
THAT THE RIGHT NUMBERS AT 90%
IS IT 85% IT ALLOWS THAT THE
OFF RAMP. BUT ALSO GIVES
DIRECTION TO THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD DESCRIBING PLANS A TWENTY
TWENTY TWO SCOPING PLAN TO
THOSE EIGHT AWAIT NO IT'S OUR
JOB TO DIRECT KERR. DID YOU
WHAT WE WANT. SO FOR SERIOUS
ABOUT IT THE CARBON NEUTRALITY.
THEN LET'S GET THE TIMELINE IN.
IN AT THIS POINT WE'RE FALLING
BEHIND OTHER STATES. NOT
LEADING ADVERTISERS ABOUT THAT
WE HAVE TO GET READY FOR LOTS
MORE FIRES AND DEVASTATION
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT'S GONNA
HAPPEN. A LOT OF ELOQUENT
SPEECHES ON CLIMATE CHANGE I
TRY TO DRESS TO A PIECES OF
THIS ONE THE CHIEF ABILITY AND
SECOND ON JOBS. NEVER ONE CAN
WE GET THERE. ABSOLUTELY WE SEE
THE TECHNOLOGY ADVANCED SO
RAPIDLY IN SOLAR AND WIND AND
GEOTHERMAL. I JUST TALKING TO
ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES REMEMBER
WHEN EXXON WAS THAT AT THE
HIGHEST MARKET CAP OF ANY. ANY
COMPANY IN THIS COUNTRY. NOW
TESLA AT THE START OF MY
DISTRICT HAS THREE AND A HALF
TIMES. THE MARKET CAP. OF EXXON
MOBIL. SO IT HAS COME DOWN 90%
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS 99% OF
THE LAST TWENTY OR SO YEARS
WIND ENERGY THE COSTS KEEP
FALLING SO WE CAN ACHIEVE THIS
BUT WE MUST DO THIS IN A
THOUGHTFUL WAY. THINGS EVERYONE
ALONG AND WE CAN'T. LET'S USE
THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
GREENHOUSE GAS OPTIONS FROM A
CABBAGE TRADE OPTIONS. TO BRING
EVERYONE ALONG WE ABSOLUTELY.
CAN DO THAT. AND WE MUST DO
THAT. ON JOBS THIS BILL DOES
PRESERVE SOME JOBS AS MIKE MY
COLLEAGUE THAT MENTIONED. BUT
WE DO NEED GOOD JOBS AS MIGHT
AS A COLLEAGUE FROM CHINO
MENTION WE DO NEED GOOD JOBS IN
CLEAN ENERGY. AS WELL THEN WE'D
FORTUNATELY WE HAVE THE THREE
NIGHTS POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE PASSED
YESTERDAY. FOR INTER E. V.
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE THOSE
WILL BE UNION JOBS. THE WIND
BILL THAT WE PASSED YESTERDAY
THAT'S ETIMATED TO CREATE
OFFSHORE WIND TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND GOOD PAYING UNION
JOBS. GEOTHERMAL EVERYTHING NON
CORRELATED WITH SOLAR IT'S
GOING TO CREATE ENERGY STORAGE
DOES WHAT LONG TERM SOURCES
WILL ALL CREATE. GOOD UNION
JOBS I WOULD ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
THAT THE BUILDING TRADES IN
PARTICULAR ALWAYS BEEN A
PARTNER. IN CALIFORNIA'S
EFFORTS MOST OF OUR GREENHOUSE
GAS GAMES HAVE ACTUALLY COME
FROM THE REAL CRITICAL
PORTFOLIO STANDARD. NOT
ACTUALLY BEEN CAPTURED OR
ANYTHING ELSE THAT COME FROM
THE R. P. S. 55% 10% TWENTY
PERCENT. THAT WOULD NOT HAVE
HAPPENED WITHOUT LABOR SP ONE
HUNDRED WOULD NOT HAPPEN
WITHOUT LABOR BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WE'RE CREATING GOOD PAYING JOBS
IN THOSE AREAS IN GEOTHERMAL IN
OFFSHORE WIND IN LONG DURATION.
STORAGE I WILL CONTINUE TO DO
SO MY CAR PROCESS WORK WITH
ABOUT- OR MAKING FUN OF THIS
PERCENT OF 2% AND SO I'M SURE
THE FACT THAT ONE POINT 6% OF
OUR WORKERS IN THE STATE
WORKING OIL AND GAS. IT MAY NOT
BE IMPORTANT TO THEM BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ME AND WE HAVE TO.
THINK. ABOUT THAT TRANSITION
AND A NEW REPORT. ADDRESSED BY
NINE UNION INCLUDE TRUE WERE
SOUTH OF CALIFORNIA OIL
WORKERS. ESTIMATES ARE STATE
COULD CREATE FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY. FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND CLEAN ENERGY JOBS PER
YEAR. THROUGH A PROGRAM TO CUT
CLIMATE POLLUTION IN HALF OVER
THE NEXT DECADE. IT SAYS IT
COULD CREATE EVEN MORE JOBS SIX
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX THOUSAND PER
YEAR. TWO INVESTMENT IN RELATED
AREAS SUCH AS WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE LEAKY GAS
PIPELINES PUBLIC PARKS AND
ROADWAYS. TO SOME BUT NOT ALL
OF WHICH WOULD ALSO REDUCE
EMISSIONS. BUT LEADER OF ONE OF
THOSE UNITS WAS ASKED WHAT WAS
GOING ON HE SAID QUOTE. AN
ENERGY TRANSITION IS COMING
WHETHER WE LIKE IT OR NOT. AND
IT'S CRUCIAL THAT WE BUILD A
SECURE FUTURE FOR WORKERS AD
THEIR FAMILIES. AS WELL WORKER
YOU'RE STANDING ON THE TRACK.
AND YOU CAN SEE THE TRAIN
COMING. WE CAN ARGUE ABOUT WHY
THE TRAIN IS COMING. WE CAN
TALK ABOUT EXACTLY WHEN IT'S
GOING TO GET HERE. BUT IT'S
COMING HE SAID. THE CHOICE FOR
US IS DO WE STILL HAVE A TRUCK
AND FACE WHATEVER HAPPENS. WHEN
WE GET ON THE PLATFORM AND TRY
TO CATCH THE TRAIN. GOING OUT
OF THAT STATION. MY FRIENDS
LET'S CATCH A TRAIN TO THE
FUTURE AND I WOULD REMIND YOU
SOMETHING VICE PRESIDENT KHAMA
HARRIS SAID LAST YEAR. HE SAID
OUR CHILDREN OUR GRANDCHILDREN
LOOK INTO OUR EYES. LET'S SEE
WHERE WERE YOU WHEN THE STAKES
ARE SO HIGH. PEOPLE ASK US WHAT
WAS IT LIKE. ANDWE WILL TELL
THEM SHE SAID WE'LL TELL NOT
JUST HOW WE FELT. WE'LL TELL
THEM WHAT WE DID. MEMBERS ARE
SPECTRAL ASTRO VOTE ON THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE. SENATOR DODD. YES
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS- I
NORMALLY- I'VE MADE IT A
PRACTICE NEVER TO US STAND UP
AND SPEAK AGAINST A DEMOCRATIC
BILL. NEVER AND I'VE NEVER
SPOKEN AGAINST ANYTHING CLIMB
IN FACT I'VE GOT THE HIGHEST
RATINGS FROM ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS FOR MY VOTING RECORD IN
THE LAST SEVEN YEARS BUT
THERE'S A FALSE NARRATIVE GOING
ON IN THIS BUILDING RIGHT NOW
THAT IF YOU DON'T VOTE FOR THIS
BILL YOU DON'T BELIEVE IN
CLIMATE CHANGE AND I'VE GOT
NEWS FOR YOU I VOTED FOR EVERY
CLIMATE CHANGE BILL ON THIS
FLOOR I ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR%
WHEN I SERVED IN THE ASSEMBLY
AND THEY'RE IMPORTANT. BUT THE
IDEA. IF WE DON'T PASS THIS DAY
TODAY. THAT OUR CHILDREN AND-GRANDCHILDREN ARE GOING TO BE
AT RISK TOMORROW. NEXT YEAR.
AGAIN IS A FALSE NARRATIVE YOU
KNOW BECAUSE I STOOD UP ON THE
FLOOR VERY PROBABLY HOW MANY
GRANDCHILDREN I'VE HAD I HAVE
TWELVE AND I LOVE HIM VERY
MUCH. AND I WANT THE VERY BEST
FUTURE FOR THEM. BUT I'M
TELLING YOU RIGHT NOW I BELIEVE
IN MY HEART. BUT MORE WORK
NEEDS TO BE DONE ON THIS BILL.
MORE SITES IS GOING TO BE
DEVELOPED. THROUGH THE SCOPING
PLAN WITH DATA AND SCIENCE. IT
EXPERIENCE WILL ALWAYS LEAD TO
BETTER DECISIONS AND I THINK
THIS THING IS BEING RUSHED
TODAY TO GET OUT OF THE
CALIFORNIA CAN HAVE THE BEST
POLICY POSSIBLE. WITH IT YOU
KNOW IT IN IF IT PASSES ARE NOT
ACTIVELY GOING OUT AND TRYING
TO KILL THIS BILL I'M NOT I'M
JUST NOT GOING TO SUPPORT TODAY
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK IT'S THE
RIGHT THING I THINK THAT SHOULD
BE A TWO YEAR BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOVO.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODSON EARLY
MON. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
AS A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR YOU'VE
ALL HEARD THE DATA THAT WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT ABOUT THE I.
P. P. C. STUDIES AT AND WE ALSO
KNOW THAT THE TIME TO ACT IT
WAS DECADES AGO- THAT ARE FOR
WE ARE LIVING THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE NOW- BUT WE WERE
DECADES AGO IN THE FUTURE
YOU'VE HEARD ALL OUR COLLEAGUES
TALK ABOUT HOW. CHALLENGING
IT'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE
AND WHEN I THINK ABOUT HE
DISTRICT I REPRESENT AND THE
VALUES THAT ARE IMPORTANT I
THINK ABOUT THIS BILL AND WHAT
IT MEANS TO THE TO THE PEOPLE
THAT I REPRESENT END YOU KNOW
JUST SHORT OF A YEAR BEING A
HUB. SWORN INTO THE LEGISLATURE
WE EXPERIENCE THE THOMAS FIRE
DECEMBER FOURTH OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND THAT LED TO A
DEBRIS FLOW. WE LOST LIVES
BECAUSE OF THE WILDFIRE AND THE
DEBRIS FLOW NOT TO MENTION THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT. CALIFORNIA'S
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WILDFIRES LESS
THAN HALF THE SIZE OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY- AND NOW TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FIRES COST US. A
HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT POINT
FIVE BILLION IN DAMAGES. IT
DOESN'T MATTER HOW MUCH WE PUT
IN THE IMPACT IS STILL GREAT TO
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES. CLIMATE
IMPACTS CONTINUE TO CAUSE
DEVASTATING HUMAN LOSS CAPITAL
LOSS NOT TO MENTION THE
DISPLACEMENT AND MENTAL HEALTH
OUR DISTRICT MY DISTRICT HAS
LIVED THAT. WE ALSO KNOW THAT
WE ARE LIVING IN A TIME WHERE
THE WEATHER CONDITIONS ARE
HOTTER THERE IS MORE DROUGHT MY
DISTRICT HAS NEVER GOTTEN OUT
OF THE DROUGHT THE PART OF THE
DISTRICT OF THE CALIFORNIA BUT
I LIVE IN IS EITHER THE
BEGINNING OF A CONNECTION OR
THE END OF A CONNECTION TO A
WHOLE LOT OF SYSTEMS. AND SO
WE'VE ALWAYS STRUGGLED. WITH
THE WATER CONNECTIONS THERE AND
WE'VE LIVED THE DROUGHT- IN
MANY WAYS AND NOW WE'RE MORE
THAN TWO DECADES INTO A MAKE A
DROUGHT ON PAR WITH THE DRIEST
TIMES OF THE LAST MILLENNIUM.
ALL OF THESE ISSUES ARE ISSUES
THAT REPRESENT. GREAT CONCERN
TO THE DISTRICT BUT THEY ALSO
HAVE AN IMPACT ON EVERYONE IN
THE DISTRICT WHETHER IT'S MY
ELEVEN MONTH OLD CHILD OR
WHETHER IT'S A UNION WORKER IN
THE DISTRICT WHEN WE HAD SOME
OF THESE IMPACTS IN OUR STATE
IN OUR DISTRICT WE HAD TO CLOSE
HIGHWAY ONE OH ONE FOR THIRTEEN
DAYS. EVERY ENTITY IN EVERY
INDUSTRY I REPRESENTED WAS
IMPACTED. SO THE AD I'M THE
EIGHTH AND THIRTY I REPRESENT
THE EIGHTH AND THIRTEENTH
LARGEST AG PRODUCING COUNTIES
IN THE STATE. ABSOLUTELY
IMPACTED THERE WAS NOT A WAY TO
GET BACK AND FORTH. ON THAT
ONE- ONE. WE ALSO BENEFIT FROM
TOURISM. ALL OF OUR TOURISM
INDUSTRY WAS COMPLETELY
IMPACTED. AND SO I SHARE THIS
WITH YOU BECAUSE I ALSO THINK
THAT AMONG THE NARRATIVES THAT
ARE OUT THERE IS THAT THOSE
THAT ARE MOVING THIS FORWARD
DON'T CARE ABOUT WORKERS. I
CARE ABOUT WORKERS I HAVE A
HISTORY OF SHOWING THAT PEOPLE
CAN LOOK AT MY LEGISLATIVE
RECORD. AND THIS IMPACTS
WORKERS AS WELL AS EVERYBODY
ELSE IN THE DISTRICT. DO I WANT
TO DO RIGHT FOR EVERYONE
ABSOLUTELY YOU KNOW IN IN THE
LATE IN THE TIME THAT I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES
AND CLIMATE ISSUES HERE IN THE
STATE I'VE BEEN CALLED A WHOLE
LOT OF NAMES OF WHOLE LOTTA
NAMES FOR CARING ABOUT ISSUES
THAT ARE IMPACTING EVERYONE I
REPRESENT. AND I WANT FOLKS TO
KNOW THAT MY SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL IS BECAUSE I BELIEVE IT IN
ADDITION. TO THE FINDING THAT
WE'VE ALLOCATED TO TRY TO
MITIGATE THE IMPACT WE NEED TO
MOVE LEGISLATION AND POLICY
FORWARD. THAT HELPS US. ALSO
TRIED TO SLOW DOWN SOME OF
THESE IMPACTS BECAUSE YOU'RE
SEEING THAT WE CAN'T JUST PUT
MONEY INTO IT AND THAT ALONE
WILL SOLVE. THE PROBLEMS THAT
WE HAVE IN FRONT OF US. I'VE
HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH
COLLEAGUES FROM THE OPPOSITE
SIDE AND WE BOTH AGREE. THAT
YOU KNOW WE HAVE THE SHARED
GOALS I BELIEVE THAT EVERYBODY
WANTS. TO LIVE IN A COMMUNITY.
WHERE PEOPLE CAN GO TO WORK FOR
PEOPLE HAVING WATER WHERE
PEOPLE CAN BENEFIT FROM THE
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE THERE BUT
WE ALSO HAVE TO. TAKE A LOOK
AND REALLY EXAMINE DEBT YOU
KNOW DIFFICULT. DECISIONS ABOUT
WHAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE TO HAVE
A PLAN FOR PEOPLE TO WORK ON.
AND SO I STAND IN SUPPORT I
KNOW THIS IS A DIFFICULT BILL I
KNOW THAT MANY OF YOU HAVE
ALREADY MADE THE DECISION THAT
YOU WILL NOT RETURN CANNOT
SUPPORT THIS BILL. BUT LIKE I
SAID EARLIER THIS YEAR WHEN A
BILL DID NOT MOVE FORWARD THAT
TO MY COLLEAGUE AND I AM. AND A
FEW OTHERS WORKED ON- MICHAEL
UNITE FROM SAN FRANCISCO. WHEN
IS THE TIME GOING TO BE FOR US
TO SIT AT THE TABLE AND HAVE
THESE HARD CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
HOW WE DO MORE. HERE IN THIS
STATE FOR EVERYONE WE REPRESENT
I KNOW THESE ARE DIFFICULT
CONVERSATIONS AND I HOPE TO BE
PART OF THEM BUT I ALSO HOPE
THAT WE ALL COMMIT TO TRYING TO
FIND A WAY. NOT JUST TO MOVE
FORWARD IDEAS BUT TO REALLY TRY
TO SLOW DOWN AND THE IMPACTS
THAT EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US IS
LIVING I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
LEE MOUNT CENTER DRAWS SO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. WHEN
THE LEGISLATURE ADOPTED
CALIFORNIA'S RECYCLING PROGRAMS
DECADES AGO. THEY LEFT OUT
ANYTHING RELATED TO WAGE
POLICIES. IT WAS LEFT TO
ORDINARY PEOPLE TO TRY TO
ORGANIZE. THE QUOTE UNQUOTE
GREEN JOBS THAT IMMIGRANT
WORKERS DID. THEY SORTED
THROUGH RECYCLED MATERIALS USE
CONDOMS AND HYPODERMIC NEEDLES
WITHOUT SAFETY GLOVES AND FOR
WAGES THAT ARE SOCIETAL
DISGRACE. I WAS THERE. THAT
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN NECESSARY IF
THE LEGISLATURE HAD TIED
ECONOMIC JUSTICE TO
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPROVEMENTS. IT
WASN'T THAT LONG AGO THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE GAVE THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD THE POWER. TO
PRIORITIZE CAP AND TRADE
REVENUES FOR QUOTING CODE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. IT
HASN'T HAPPENED. AND WHILE
UPPER MIDDLE CLASS CALIFORNIANS
GOT FINANCIAL INCENTIVES TO
CONSUME LESS GASOLINE LOWER
INCOME PEOPLE ARE GETTING WHAT
THEIR BOARD CALLS PRICING
POLISH POLICIES THAT PUNISH
THEM FOR WHAT. WE'RE USING WHAT
THEY NEED. MY PROBLEM WITH THIS
BILL ISN'T WHAT IT SAYS. BUT
WHAT IT DOESN'T SAY. NOT A WORD
ABOUT JOBS OR WAGES NOT A WORD
ABOUT ECONOMIC JUSTICE NOT A
WORD ABOUT THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVING WHATEVER THE AIR
RESOURCE BOARD'S COME UP WITH.
WHEN I RAISE THESE CONCERNS I
AM TOLD THAT THOSE THINGS COULD
BE ADDRESSED LATER. WELL I
DIDN'T COME AND I'M SURE MANY
OR ALL OF YOU DIDN'T COME TO
THE SENATE. TO WAIT. I WAS IN
MY TWENTIES WHEN I BEGAN
FIGHTING FOR GARMENT WORKERS. I
CAME TO THE SENATE TO HELP WIN
THAT FIGHT NOT WAIT. OVER A
DECADE AGO BOMBER KERR BECAME
LAW. I CAME TO THE SENATE. AS
YOU HAVE TO HELP WIN HEALTH
CARE FOR OLDER IMMIGRANTS IN
CALIFORNIA. NOT TO WAIT. GOING
TO JAIL TWENTY THREE TIMES TO
WIN DECENT WAGES AND HEALTH
CARE FOR HOTEL WORKERS. I
LEARNED THE HARD WAY THAT THERE
IS NO EASY WAY. THIS BILL IS
UNFINISHED. UNLESS WE SEIZE
EVERY OPPORTUNITY THE WORKING
POOR WILL ALWAYS BE THE LAST IN
LINE. WE CAN INCLUDE WAGE
POLICIES FIGHTING CLIMATE
CHANGE DOESN'T HAVE TO MEAN
REGRESSIVE ECONOMIC POLICIES
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE DOESN'T
NEED TO COME AT THE EXPENSE OF
ECONOMIC JUSTICE. THANK YOU
SENATOR TORONTO CENTER GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
WEIGHING IN ON ON VARIOUS SIDES
OF THIS ISSUE YOU KNOW- I'M A
SENATOR IS OFTEN MENTIONED IN
MANY OF COMMITTEE HEARINGS
ETCETERA THAT REPRESENTS- SOME
OF THE HIGHEST POLLUTED REGIONS
OF LOS ANGELES- COMING FROM THE
PORT OF LOS AT PORT OF LONG
BEACH EXCUSE ME- THROUGH THE
SEVEN TEN COMMUNITIES WITH
MOBILE AND STATIONARY SOURCES
OF POLLUTION EXCITE IS IN MY
BACKYARD I DON'T HAVE THE
LUXURY. ANYMORE UNFORTUNATELY
TO SIT BACK AND CONTINUE TO NOT
PASS LEGISLATION THAT WILL
ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE. AND I'M
ALSO THE DAUGHTER OF A TEAMSTER
DAUGHTER OF A VERY PROUD- TRUCK
DRIVER WHO FOUGHT FOR THIRTY
YEARS WOKE UP EVERY MORNING. TO
PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE FOR MY
PARENTS SO I UNDERSTAND THAT. I
BELIEVE ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY
AND WORK FORCE CAN CO EXIST
THEY CAN. AND I'M COMMITTED TO
THAT I THINK MANY OF US HERE ON
THIS FLOOR ARE COMMITTED TO
THAT. BUT WE CANNOT IGNORE THE
IMPACTS I HAVE A FIRST GRADER.
WHAT IS HIS LIFE GOING TO LOOK
LIKE. TWO DECADES FROM NOW.
WHEN THE PLANET IS WARMING.
MORE THAN ONE POINT FIVE
DEGREES CELSIUS. WHEN THE U. N.
IS CALLING OUT AND SAYING CODE
RED AND WE'RE SITTING BACK
DOING NOTHING. THE CLIMATE
ACTION ABSOLUTELY CANNOT COME
AT THE EXPENSE OF OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ONE
IN WHICH I REPRESENT BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES WERE ALREADY
DEALING WITH THESE IMPACTS. IN
FACT YOU LOOK UP ANY HEADLINE
ON THE NEW YORK TIMES AND-
THESE ARE THE HEADLINES. MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED FIFTY PEOPLE
MILLION PEOPLE UNDER HE ALERTS
AS MUCH OF. THE U. S. IS
SCORCHED AGAIN THIS WEEK.
TROPICAL STORM FRED FORMS JUST
SOUTH OF PORTO RICO I WOULD
WANT TO DIE RIGHT HERE IN AID
OF AMERICAN COMMUNITY FIGHTS TO
PROTECT ITS LAND FROM THE DIXIE
FIRE. IN THE VALLEY WHERE ONE
TOWN BURNED FIRE CREWS AND
VOLUNTEERS ARE STILL BATTLING
THE FLAMES. CANADIAN WILDFIRES
COULD INTENSIFY FROM A LOOMING
HEATWAVE. SO I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES ALL OF THEM WHO
ADDRESSED CONCERNS AGAIN ON ON
MULTIPLE SIDES OF THIS ISSUE I
THINK THERE IS A LOT OF WORK TO
DO AND I BELIEVE THAT IF THIS
POLICY PASSES WE WILL CONTINUE
TO BE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT
WE DO BUILD A CALIFORNIA THAT
TRULY IS REPRESENTATIVE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE WILL BE BOLD ON
THESE ISSUES WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOAT.
THANK YOU SENATOR GONZALEZ SAID
HER TADO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- I RISE. TODAY
BECAUSE I WANT TO REDUCE CARBON
EMISSIONS JUST AS MUCH AS THE
AUTHOR OF THIS LEGISLATION. I
WANT TO HELP FIGHT STOP CLIMATE
CHANGE AS WELL. THIS BILL
HOWEVER IS THE WRONG APPROACH
AND I IT'S MY OPINION THAT IT'S
UNREALISTIC. TO FIGHT CLIMATE
CHANGE WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
HUMAN SECURITY ADAPTATION AND-
MORE PARTLY INNOVATION AS WELL.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
REDUCTIONS FOR QUITE SOME TIME
IN THE STATE. BUT WHAT HAS IT
DONE FOR DISTRICTS LIKE MINE.
IT'S CREATED MORE POVERTY. AND
MORE SUFFERING. AND MORE DEATHS.
REDUCTION IS NOT HELPING MY
DISTRICT IT'S MAKING LIFE WORSE
FOR THE INDIVIDUALS THERE. WE
HAVE BEEN SO FOCUSED ON
PRODUCTION THAT WE ARE FAILING
TO ADAPT AND TO INNOVATE. WE
NEED TO EMPOWER ONE ANOTHER
AND- WE ALSO NEED TO EMPOWER
INDUSTRY TO BE INNOVATORS AND
LEADERS OF INNOVATION THAT WILL
HELP US. STOP CLIMATE CHANGE
OUR FUTURE TO ADAPT TO CLIMATE
CHANGE. OUR FAILURE TO ADAPT TO
CLIMATE CHANGE IS WHAT'S
KILLING PEOPLE. OUR APPROACH IS
NOT WORKING. I DON'T BELIEVE
THIS BILL WILL SAVE LIVES IT
WILL NOT STOP CLIMATE CHANGE
OUR APPROACH MUST CHANGE TO
SAVE THIS PLANET. BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY TO SAVE MANKIND.
AND FOR THESE REASONS I ASK FOR
A NO VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR HER
TITLE CENTER BOARD JUST.
COLLEAGUES I'M A LITTLE
CONFUSED THE- LAST NUMBER OF
LEGISLATIVE SESSIONS AS LONG AS
I'VE BEEN A SENATOR WE HAVE
TALKED ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE IN
ALL THAT WE'RE DOING LEADING
THE CHARGE AS CALIFORNIANS. THE
BUDGET INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE
MAKING IN. OUR GREEN TECHNOLOGY
AND MODIFYING OUR FOSSIL FUEL
INDUSTRY ENGINE FIVE NEW AREAS
OF ENTERPRISE. WE TAUGHT
OURSELVES FOR WHAT WE'RE DOING.
BUT TODAY I HEAR THAT WE'RE AT
THE PRECIPICE HAVING DONE
NOTHING. SO WHAT WHAT IS IT.
HAVE WE BEEN LACKADAISICAL HEAD
AND OUT TO LUNCH ON THIS ISSUE
FOR AS LONG AS I'VE BEEN A
MEMBER OF THIS BODY I DON'T
THINK SO BECAUSE EVERY BILL
SENSE OF IMMEDIACY. THAT UNLESS
WE PASS IT WE ARE. DERELICT IN
OUR DUTIES IN THE STEWARDS OF
NOT ONLY OUR STATE BUT ON A
BILL WITH OUR PLANET. TWO DAYS
AGO I THINK WE HAD A BILL. TO
CREATE A UC PARTNERSHIP WITH
CHINA. FOR A THINK TANK
RESEARCH FACILITY A SO THAT WE
CAN TALK ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING
TO ADAPT TO THE NEW REALITY IN
WHAT WE WANT TO LOOK LIKE. AND
WE ALL SUPPORTED THAT BECAUSE I
THINK IT DOESN'T HURT TO
ACCUMULATE INFORMATION AND
KNOWLEDGE DESPITE MY MISGIVINGS
ON THE BILL ITSELF. BUT I
REMAIN CONFUSED BY HARKING BACK
TO THE COMMENTS FROM THE
SENATOR FROM NAPA. THANK YOU
YOU CAN'T UNDERSTAND HOW OUR
CLIMATE IS CHANGING. BUT MY
BOOK BY VOTING AGAINST THIS ALL
OF A SUDDEN YOU'RE A CLIMATE
CHANGE DENIER. THAT'S NOT
THAT'S NOT BEING PRACTICAL.
WHEN YOU PUSH SOMETHING AS
AMBITIOUS AS THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IT'S ALMOST BECOME
SYMBOLIC WHAT EXACTLY ARE WE
PUSHING FOR BECAUSE WHAT I'D
LOVE TO SEE. OR THE METRICS
THAT GO ALONG WITH THE NUMBERS
OF THE NEW EMPLOYMENT SCHEME IN
THE GREEN NEW DEAL. BECAUSE WE
ALWAYS TAUGHT ALL THE NEW JOBS
THAT WOULD GO ALONG WITH. A NEW
PIECE OF LEGISLATION RARELY DO
I HEAR THAT NUMBER QUANTIFIED
pWILL BE LOST BY PREMATURELY IN
SYMBOLICALLY TRANSFERRING INTO
A NEW FORM OF ENTERPRISE OR
TECHNOLOGY. IF WE'RE BEING
HONEST WE HAVE TO DO THAT. I
THINK INDUSTRY WHETHER IT'S IN
THE OIL FIELD OR IN AGRICULTURE
OR IN CEMENT. AS WE DISCUSSED
YESTERDAY. CALIFORNIA IS THE
GOLD STANDARD SO FOR TO HEAR
FOLKS SAY THAT WE'RE BEHIND THE
EIGHT BALL AND HAVE DONE
NOTHING. YET TELL OURSELVES AS
THE GOLD STANDARD NOT ONLY IN
IN IN CALIFORNIA AS
CALIFORNIANS BUT WITHIN. THE U.
S. IN OVERSEAS WHICH ONE IS IT
ARE WE STEWARDS AGAIN ARE WE
BEING AMBITIOUS OR ARE WE BEING
LACKADAISICAL I THINK. A BILL
LIKE THIS. NEEDS TO BE VETTED
IN A MORE SERIOUS WAY. IN
PUTTING OUT AN AMBITIOUS GOALS
SO THAT WE CAN TELL IT IT ON
SOME SORT OF CAMPAIGN FLYER BUT
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO BY
YOUR TWENTY FORTY FIVE. THAT'S
THE SAME RATIONALE OF THE PARIS
ACCORDS. BUT I ACTUALLY BELIEVE
IN MANY OF THOSE CONSTRUCTS OF
THE PARIS ACCORDS. BUT WE DO DO
YOU TAKE CORRECTIVE ACTION IN
SO MANY WAYS BUT WE ALSO HAVE
TO DO IT IN A WAY THAT IS
SUSTAINABLE AND BEING HONEST
WITH THE PEOPLE WE REPRESENT.
WE HAVE A HISTORY AS
LEGISLATORS OF PRO CLAIMING
THESE BOLD AMBITIOUS GOALS. AND
NEXT THING YOU KNOW WECAN'T
ACHIEVE THEM WE CREATE ANOTHER
SET OF GOALS TO MASK WHAT WE
WERE UNABLE TO DO IN THE
PREVIOUS FIVE YEARS SO I THINK
IF WE'RE BEING HONEST. PUT
FORWARD. IN REAL TERMS. A PLAN
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS THAT
ACCOMMODATES IT TAKES INTO
CONSIDERATION JOB LOSS VERSUS
JOB CREATION ENVIRONMENTAL
CHANGES THAT WE WILL BE A PART
OF NOT JUST THE 1% OF THE
CLIMATE- PARTICIPATION THAT WE
HAVE AS CALIFORNIANS BUT WHAT
DOES IT MEAN IN THE GREATER
SCHEME OF THINGS WITHIN THE U.
S. IN THE MAJOR PLAYERS IN THE
EMERGING MARKETS LIKE CHINA AND
INDIA. YOU CAN'T PLAY CHESS ONE
PIECE. YOU GOT TO SEE HOW IT
ALL FITS TOGETHER AND FRANKLY
THESE OVER AMBITIOUS OVERLY
SYMBOLIC GESTURES SOUNDS GOOD
BUT I THINK THEY LACK SUBSTANCE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BORDERS
CENTER DOLLY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I.
BEEN LISTENING TO A LOT OF
DEBATE IS QUITE FASCINATING- TO
LISTEN. TO HISTORY ABOUT WHERE
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN IN WEATHER
WE'VE BEEN LEADING INTO WHAT WE
SHOULD DO IS GO FORWARD BUT I
HEARD A LOT OF STORIES ABOUT
MEMBERS AND- THEIR FAMILIES AND
WHY THEY CAME HERE IN. I THINK
MAYBE I SHOULD TELL MY STORY A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHY I CAME TO
THIS LEGISLATURE. I CAME AS A
REPUBLICAN. WHO LIVES IN A VERY
SMALL TOWN. LESS THAN THREE
HUNDRED PEOPLE. ALSO COME FROM
A FAMILY OF HOME THAT
HOMESTEADED HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND HAS WORKED THE SAME PIECE
OF LAND. FOR EIGHTY YEARS I'M
THE THIRD GENERATION MY SONS
AND MY DAUGHTER WILL BE ARE THE
FOURTH GENERATION. I CAME TO.
LOOK FOR TRUE ENVIRONMENTALISTS
WHEN I SAY THAT. I'M NOT.
SAYING YOU'RE NOT IN
ENVIRONMENTS BUT SOMEBODY WHO
WILL SAY WE NEED TO CUT A TREE
BECAUSE IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO
DO. NOT BECAUSE- AN
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP. TELLS YOU
THAT IT'S THE WRONG THING TO DO
SO I. HAVE HAD FORESTRY TOURS
I'VE INVITED MANY OF YOU TO THE
DISTRICT TO EDUCATE BECAUSE I
BELIEVE EDUCATION. OF WHAT IS
REAL AND NOT WHAT IS NOT
POLITICAL WILL MAKE THE
DIFFERENCE. AND YES I MOVED
LOTS OF FORESTRY BILLS THROUGH
THIS LEGISLATURE AND BEEN
SOMEWHAT SUCCESSFUL. BUT I
VOTED AGAINST TARGETS WHICH
THIS BILL IS A TARGET THERE'S
REALLY NOT A LOT OF SUBSTANCE
AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET
THERE. AND FOR ME I DON'T HAVE
THE TRUST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
IS GOING TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
NOW I PUSH BACK ON.
TECHNOLOGIES BUT I DON'T
BELIEVE WE'LL GET US WHERE WE
WANT TO GO. I WILL SHARE WITH
YOU TO DATE AFTER A. B. THIRTY
TWO WE HAVE SPENT EIGHT BILLION.
DOLLARS CAP AND TRADE DOLLARS.
ON A TRAIN. AND HAVE NOT LAID
ONE FOOT OF TRACK. ONE PUT.
THAT'S WHY I DON'T TRUST THIS
PROCESS NOW IN THAT PROCESS
LABOUR LINED UP RIGHT NOW LABOR
IS NOT ON BOARD BUT IF LABOR
WAS ON BOARD. THIS BILL WOULD
BE OUT OF HERE. WE ALL KNOW THE
TRUTH BECAUSE OF POLITICAL IT'S
ABOUT JOBS DOESN'T MATTER WHAT
THEY DO FOR THE ENVIRONMENT
IT'S ABOUT JOBS. SORRY I'M
GETTING LOUD. AS I WATCH.
COMPANIES LEAVE CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO
WORK HERE. AND THEY GO TO
STATES WHERE THEY'RE NOT
REGULATED AS HEAVY OR THEY GO
TO OTHER COUNTRIES. AND THAT'S
YOUR JOBS THAT ARE LEAVING THE
STATE. THE EXODUS OF JOBS OUT
OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF OUR
REGULATIONS AND THE REGULATIONS
ARE CHANGING THE ENVIRONMENT.
AS I TALKED ABOUT THE BILL TO
REGULATE. LAWN MOWERS AND WEED
EATERS AS MY FOREST IS BURNING
DOWN THAT'S THE PROBLEM WE'RE
GOING TO GIVE THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD MORE POWER
WITH THIS BILL. THEY GOT WAY
TOO MUCH AS IT IS WE NEED TO
HAVE SOME OVERSIGHT ON WHAT
THEY'RE REALLY ACHIEVING. WE
HAD A. ANALYSIS OF WHAT THEIR
CARBON WAS PER DOLLAR AND IT
WAS HORRIBLE. SO WHAT DID WE DO.
THEY JUST CHANGE ADMINISTRATORS
AND SAID WE'RE GOING TO FIX IT
WITH THE NEXT ADMINISTRATOR.
THE SAME THING WE'VE DONE ON
THE BULLET TRAIN EVERY TIME IT
DOESN'T MEAN IT'S PERFORMANCE
WE CHANGE THE DIRECTOR AND THE
NEXT GUY'S GOING TO FIX THE
PROBLEM AND THEY DON'T FIX THE
PROBLEM BECAUSE IT'S ABOUT
POLICY. WHAT I'M GONN ASK YOU
A QUESTION WHAT WAS THE WETTEST
YEAR ON RECORD IN THIS. STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I BET YOU DON'T
KNOW. IN A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
TWO YEARS OF KEEPING RECORDS.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. DECEMBER
AND TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EVERYWHERE THE WETTEST YEARS ON
RECORD IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE'RE
IN A DROUGHT RIGHT NOW. OUR
RESERVOIRS WERE A HUNDRED AND
5% OF PEOPLE. EIGHTEEN MONTHS
AGO. WHERE DID THE WATER GO.
THIS ADMINISTRATION RELEASED
THE WATER. BECAUSE THERE'S
ENOUGH WATER IN OUR RESERVOIRS
TO TAKE CALIFORNIA FOR FIVE
YEARS. SO THERE'S A LOT OF
POLICY THAT NEEDS TO BE FIXED
IN THIS PLACE AND THERE'S A LOT
OF PEOPLE THAT NEED TO BE. HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. RELEASING WATERS.
AND NOT TAKING CARE OF THE
ENVIRONMENT AND NOT LAYING THE
TRACK. AND THIS BILL IS GOING
TO DO NOTHING MORE ADD TO THAT.
MEMBERS FOR THE FUTURE OF MY
FAMILY AND MY RANCH I ASK YOU
TO VOTE NO ON THIS AND MANY
OTHER BILLS UNLESS DO SOME
POLICY AROUND HERE IT'S
ACTUALLY GOING TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE FOR THE ENVIRONMENT.
IT ACTUALLY KEEPS BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA. AND NOT SHIFTING
OUR JOBS TO. CHINA WHERE THEY
POLLUTE IT'S THE SAME ERROR.
ALL COMPANIES COMPETE AGAINST
ALL THESE OTHER COMPANIES I
COMPETE AGAINST COMPANIES IN
OREGON WASHINGTON AND NEVADA
AND I'M GETTING. KILLED BECAUSE
MY TOOLS A DOLLAR A GALLON MORE.
BY REGULATIONS ARE SO MUCH MORE
MY WAGES ARE SO MUCH MORE AT
SOME POINT I CAN'T COMPETE. AND
I THINK I'M A PRETTY GOOD
FORMER. BUT AT SOME POINT IN
THE LEGISLATURE'S CAUSING MY
PROBLEMS MORE THAN ME. I URGE A
NO VOTE ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR HOLLINGS CENTER GROVE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I'M
OBVIOUSLY I RISE IN OPPOSITION
OF AB THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE
YOU'VE HEARD ME TALK ON THIS
FLOOR ABOUT THE CAREERS I'M NOT
JUST GOING TO SAY JOBS BUT
CAREERS THAT THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY PROVIDE TO MY DISTRICT
BECAUSE THEIR LONG TERM CAREERS
YOU KNOW TEN TWENTY THIRTY
YEARS WHERE PEOPLE MAKE A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF MONEY.
THEY HAVE GREAT BENEFITS- WE DO
HAVE BOTH UNION AND NONUNION
JOBS AND DEAL INDUSTRY IS
CONSISTENT IN MAKING SURE THAT
WAGES AND BENEFITS IS- IS A-
MAKING SURE THAT OUR EMPLOYEES
ARE TAKING CARE OF- THIS BILL.
LIKE SO MANY OTHER BILLS THAT
GO THROUGH- ATTACK OUR OIL AND
GAS INDUSTRY AND- I AGREE WITH
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BIEBER WITH
THE COMMENTS THAT HE SAID ABOUT
FARMING BUT I ALSO AGREE WITH
MY COLLEAGUE IN THE BRICK
BEAVER THAT WE REALLY NEED TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS ON ABOUT HOW
TO FIX THE ISSUE OF A- THAT WE
KNOW WE HAVE. BUT WE ALSO NEED
TO MAKE SURE WE DO THAT SMARTLY
YOU KNOW WE REDUCED OIL
PRODUCTION OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION HERE IN THE STATE
AND- WE IMPORT ALMOST 70% OF
OUR PRODUCT FROM FOREIGN
COUNTRIES. BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
REDUCED THE CONSUMPTION THE
CALIFORNIANS EXPECT. I LISTEN
TO A LOT OF COLLEAGUES TALK
ABOUT THEIR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN YOU KNOW MY
HUSBAND AND I WE GOT FIVE KIDS
AND WE'RE ON OUR TENTH
GRANDCHILD I HAVEN'T CAUGHT UP
WITH MY SENATOR. A FRIEND
COLLEAGUE FROM NAPA YET BUT- I
GUARANTEE YOU MY CHILDREN ARE
WORKING ON IT. M. BUT I CAN
TELL YOU THAT YOU KNOW I HAVE
GRANDKIDS TO ANNA. MY GRANDKIDS
I THINK ONE OF LUPUS WHICH YOU
HAVE THE ELECTRICITY COME ON.
WHEN THEY GET OLDER. THEY WANT
TO BE ABLE TO COOK ON A STOVE
INSIDE THE HOUSE AND NOT HAVE
TO BUILD A FIRE. I THINK THE
WAY THAT. THIS BODY IS
APPROACHING CLIMATE CHANGE IS
REALLY DETRIMENTAL. IT'S
THROUGH OVER REGULATION. I CAN
TELL YOU THAT- WITH EVERYTHING
THAT'S GOING ON IN ALL THE- THE
BANNING OF LAWN MOWERS AND JUST
EVERYTHING PLUS THIS. SOLUTION
TO MAKE THAT WORK. AND FIX
THAT. SO THAT THAT'S ONE THING
THAT WE CAN CHECK OFF OUR LIST
AND I THINK THAT WE COULD GET A
LOT OF I AM FROM. FROM
EVERYBODY. AT ALL PARTIES
INVOLVED. I CAN TELL YOU THAT-
I COULD GO ON AND ON ABOUT
EVERYTHING THAT EVERYBODY SAID
BUT I'M JUST GETTING IN THIS
WITH A VERY SIMPLE THING
BECAUSE I KNOW WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THIS. YOU CAN SET THE
GOAL YOU CAN MAKE THEIR
SPEECHES YOU CAN USE THIS FOR
SPEECHES AND CAMPAIGNS IN YOUR
DISTRICT. BUT I CAN TELL YOU
THAT IT'S UNATTAINABLE. AND I
CAN TELL YOU THAT BECAUSE I
HAVE A LINE MIKE THOUGHTS WITH
THE GOVERNOR OF THIS STATE TOO
IS. REALLY AN ENVIRONMENTALIST.
BUT LAST. MONTH HE HAD TO
AUTHORIZE EMERGENCY USE FOR
FIVE NEW GAS LINE GENERATORS TO
BE BROUGHT ON LINE TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS. SO WHEN
THEY FLIP THE SWITCH THE LIGHT
CAME ON. SO NOBODY TALKS ABOUT
THAT IT'S NOT IN THE MEDIA. D.
W. R. ACTUALLY THE- THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
RESOURCES ANNOUNCED ON AUGUST
SIXTEENTH VERY QUIETLY THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO INSTALL FIVE
NEW GAS POWERED GENERATORS. DUE
TO ENERGY SUPPLY CONCERNS
BECAUSE THEY ARE CALIFORNIANS
THAT WE REPRESENT EXPECT. TO BE
ABLE TO TURN ON THE AIR
CONDITIONER WHEN IT'S A HUNDRED
TEN DEGREES. AND THEY WANT
THEIR AIR CONDITIONER TO COME
ON THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE LIGHTS IF THEY NEED
BREATHING TREATMENTS AT NIGHT
THEY WANT THE POWER TO WORK. SO
THAT THEY CAN USE THOSE
BREEDING TREATMENTS. SO I THINK
MOVING IN A DIRECTION OF.
MOVING IN AND USING GREEN
TECHNOLOGY LIKE ALL OF THE
ABOVE ALL OF THE ABOVE BOILING
GAS GREEN TECHNOLOGY. IN KERN
COUNTY THE DISTRICT I REPRESENT
THAT I SHARE WITH MY COLLEAGUES
WE DO THAT WE PRODUCE 70% OF
THE STATE'S OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY IN IT. IT OIL AND GAS
SUPPLY AND WE ALSO PRODUCE 53%
OF THE STATE'S RENEWABLE
ENERGY. SO IT CAN BE DONE
PEOPLE CAN DO THIS TOGETHER WE
CAN SOLVE SOME PROBLEMS THAT WE
HAVE THAT WE ALL AGREE THAT WE
HAVE. BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS IT
ALL OF THIS. IN THIS BILL
DOESN'T WORK YOU CAN SET THESE
GOALS BUT YOU WILL ALWAYS NEED
OIL AND GAS AND GAS POWERED
GENERATORS. JUST LIKE THE COMIC
YESTERDAY THEY CAME HOW IF YOU
DON'T IF YOU IF YOU CAN'T PLUG
IN A BATTERY OPERATED GENERATOR
TO RUN YOUR- YOUR KEEP YOUR
REFRIGERATOR COLD. BUT YOU KNOW
HOW YOU CHARGE THAT RIGHT IF IT
DOESN'T HAVE GAS. INTO
ELIMINATE THOSE TYPES OF J. THE
RAIDERS WHICH I NOTED. BUT THAT
WAS A BILL THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
YESTERDAY ANYWAYS- SO I WENT
DOWN A RABBIT HOLE SORRY DIDN'T
MEAN TO. I JUST WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT. THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES JUST
AUTHORIZED- THE GOVERNOR
ACTUALLY GAVIN NEWSOM JUST
AUTHORIZED. AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES TO PUT FIVE
GAS POWERED. PLANTS IN PLACE
IMMEDIATELY. IMMEDIATELY UNDER
EMERGENCY AUTHORIZATION BECAUSE
WE NEED POWER NOW. AND WE HAVE
TO HAVE THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY TO BE ABLE TO PRODUCE
IT. SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
NO VOTE. THE CENTER GROVE
CENTER HERTZBERG. VERY FEW MEN
A PRESENTATION- I LEFT
GOVERNMENT OVER TWENTY YEARS
AGO. AND SPENT MORE THAN TWELVE
YEARS TRAVELING THE WORLD
WORKING IN. THE AREA OF CLEAN
TECH IN THE ENVIRONMENT AND TO.
ALWAYS WAS AT ODDS WITH SO MANY
FRIENDS I WOULD ALWAYS SAY HOW
MANY POUNDS OF CARBON DID YOU
PRODUCE. IN THE ENVIRONMENT
BECAUSE THE FIRST TEN YEARS
AFTER. AB THIRTY TWO WHICH
PRODUCED A LOT OF THE ASIAN. A
LOT OF RULES AND REGULATIONS
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK. GLOBALLY IS
WHAT THE IMPACT WAS EVEN
COMPARED AGAINST CHINA OR
GERMANY OR SO MANY OTHER
JURISDICTIONS OF THE MALDIVES.
WHERE WERE WE IN TERMS OF THAT
POLICY WHAT DO WE ACTUALLY DO
TO HELP THE ENVIRONMENT BEYOND
JUST THE RHETORIC OF THAT. AND
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT.
IF YOU REALLY DON'T WANT TO
JUST READ. A COUPLE LINES FROM
IT. IT SAYS THE SEPARATELY.
THAT THE STATE BOARD. HELLO
JENNIFER HI- IN ROOM FIVE YOUR
GREENHOUSE GASES BEGIN JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. AND
PAGE FIVE IN THE PARAGRAPH NINE
INCHES BY DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE THE BOARD
SHALL EVALUATE FEASIBILITY IN
TRADE OFF. WHAT ARE WE DOING
NOW WE HAVE A CLIMATE EMERGENCY.
THE LOWER CLIMATE CHANGE I SAID
YESTERDAY ITS CLIMATE CHANGED.
WHAT WE DID YESTERDAY FOR
FAMILIES ON EXTREME HEAT A
FRIEND OF MINE GOOD FRIEND OF
MINE JUST TOLD ME A STORY. WHO
GREW UP IN MY DISTRICT IN
COMMUNITIES I REPRESENT. THAT
SHE USED TO PUT A SOCK IN THE
FREEZER. SHE LIVES IN A
TRAILER. AND SO THAT YOU CAN
PUT IN A HEADER STOMACH ISSUE
SO. SO HOT. THAT WAS THE THING
SHE HAD TO DO TO BE ABLE TO
SURVIVE WE HAVE THESE
EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGES AND
JUST YESTERDAY THE SENATE. WITH
THE LEADERSHIP. ALL THROUGHOUT
THE COMMITTEES THE BUDGET.
BASICALLY HAVE DONE THAT
EXTREME HEAT ON FIRES ON OUR ON
THE ISSUE OF URBAN FORESTRY
THINGS THAT WILL IMPACT
PEOPLE'S LIVES NOW. THE LAST
THING I WANT TO SHARE. IS THAT
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS DELEGATE
TO KERR. OKAY WHAT HAPPENED
BACK WAY BACK WHEN WE GET A B.
THIRTY TWO. WAS PEOPLE COULDN'T
AGREE SO LET'S GIVE IT TO AN
AGENCY. AND SO ALL WE'RE DOING
IS TAKING AUTHORITY FROM THE
BRILLIANCE THERE IN THIS ROOM
AND THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
PASSION ON THIS ISSUE AND CARE
DEEPLY. AND WE'RE PASSING TO
THE AGENCY AND LET ME TELL YOU
LASTLY ONE EXAMPLE. THAT MYSELF
THE SENATOR FROM MENLO PARK IN
THE SENATOR FROM. FREMONT WENT
AND MET WITH CARBON. AND WE
ASKED THEM TO RESPOND TO AN
ISSUE THAT WE CARED ABOUT THE
SENATOR'S. INVOLVING CAP AND
TRADE AND YOU KNOW WHAT. WE
HAVEN'T HAD A RESPONSE. SO HERE
WE ARE IF SENATORS WHO WE ARE
AS LEGISLATORS AND WE'RE SAYING
WE WANT TO SOLVE THIS URGENT
PROBLEM. WE'RE SENDING IT OUT
YEARS AND INTO THE FUTURE AND
WE'RE GIVING IT TO AN AGENCY.
THAT JUST IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS
WOULD NOT EVEN RESPOND TO
CINDERS REQUEST TO KURT DEEPLY
ABOUT THESE ISSUES. I AM
COMMITTED TO THE CAUSE I AM
GOING TO PUT EVERYBODY GOT IT I
HAVE INTO CONTINUING TO WORK ON
THIS IS THIS. GREAT SENATE HAS
DONE WITH RESPECT TO ITS
RESOURCES PROGRAM THE BIGGEST
IN THE HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT WHAT WE
HAVE BEFORE US HERE TODAY
SOLVES. THOSE PROBLEMS BEYOND
THE RHETORIC. THANK YOU SENT
HER. CENTER BATES. RELEVANT I
WASN'T GOING TO SPEAK ON THE
BILL BUT THERE'S SOMETHING THAT
CAUGHT MY EYE IN THE HOUSE
FLOOR ALERT AND- LET ME PREFACE
THAT WITH- I GIVE A ABOUT THE
CLIMATE CHANGE I GIVE A ABOUT
THE PLANET AND I GIVE A ABOUT
THE PRESENCE IN THE IMMEDIATE
FUTURE IN TERMS OF JOBS SO THIS
PARTICULAR ITEM IN THE FLOOR
ALERT CAUGHT MY EYE IT SAYS
AMENDMENTS WERE PROMISED IN
COMMITTEE. TO BE CONCERNS OF
WORKING FAMILIES THAT WERE
NEVER ADDED TO THE BILL WHAT
SEEMS TO BE THE PROBLEM HERE
WITH THE BILL IS THERE'S NO
BALANCE THERE'S NO DELIBERATE
UP PROGRESS IN IN ADDRESSING
ALL OF THE GREENHOUSE GAS WE
HAVEN'T MET THE TARGETS AND
THAT'S IN A LOT OF THE
MATERIALS WE'VE BEEN PRESENTED
WE ARE. SORELY CONCERNED ABOUT
MEETING EVEN THOUGH OF THE
NINETEEN THE TWO THOUSAND OF
THE 40% THAT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
AND BY TWENTY ODD THIRTY SO.
THERE'S TIME HAS BEEN MENTIONED
BY A NUMBER OF OTHER PRESENTERS
THAT ALL THIS AS A TWO YEAR
DEAL MAYBE THESE AMENDMENTS
THAT WOULD HELP BRING THE
BALANCE FOR THE PRESENT AND THE
NEED FOR JOBS AS WE GO FORWARD
A BASICALLY FOR OUR CHILDREN OR
GRANDCHILDREN OR GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN SO I WOULD BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT IT TODAY EVEN
THOUGH I AM NOT A DENIER ON
CLIMATE CHANGE AND SPECIALLY
LIVING ON THE COAST. I SEE SEE
RIDER SO I JUST RECOMMEND THAT
WE TAKE MORETIME WE GET MORE
RESPONSIBILITY ON MY ARM THE
CARD REGULATIONS THAT ARE JUST
YOU KNOW DECIDED THERE VOTED
THERE AND- PROMULGATED ON OUR
INDUSTRY IS THAT SOME OF THAT
COME BACK TO US FOR A REVIEW
FULL BECAUSE OF THOSE ISSUES I
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY. BUT I DON'T WANT ANYONE
TO BELIEVE THAT I DON'T THINK
IT'S AN IMPORTANT THING FOR US
TO BE INVOLVED IN- IN OUR
LEGISLATURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR BATES CENTER
MELINDA'S. THANK YOU SO MUH.
THE SENATORS. TO THE CAR FROM
THE AIR. CALIFORNIA EMITTED
JUST IN THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED AND SIX MILLION
METRIC TONS OF CARBON. JUST
THREE FIRES ALONE. THAT'S IT SO
THAT'S ALMOST AS MUCH AS THE
ENTIRE CARBON EMISSIONS ACROSS
ALL INDUSTRIES. FOR THE VERY
SAME YEAR. BUT WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE WITH POLICIES LIKE
THIS TO PUSH MORE INDUSTRIES
OUT OF OUR STATE TO PUSH MORE
JOBS OUT OF OUR STATE. HE'S
LIKE THIS DO. THE COMMENTS THAT
WERE MADE EARLIER ABOUT THOSE
WHO ARE A BIT SELF PROCLAIMED
ENVIRONMENTALIST HAVING DONE
NOTHING TO REALLY PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT I COMPLETELY AGREE
WITH YOU JUST BECAUSE YOU STAND
UP ON THE FLOOR AND TALK ABOUT
HOW MUCH OF AN ENVIRONMENTALIST
YOU ARE AND SHED A TEAR IN
DECIDE THAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE THE MONOPOLY
ON- PROTECTING THE PLANET THAT
DOESN'T FLY BECAUSE WHAT YOU'RE
DOING ISN'T PROTECTING THE
PLANT WHAT IT IS DOING. IS
RUNNING PEOPLE OUT OF THE STATE
THIS IS A GOOD POLICY THOUGH
THERE'S ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
DIFFERENT POLICIES WITHIN THIS
ONE BILL AND I'M NOT SURE WHY
THAT IS BUT IT NEEDS TO BE
CERTAINLY MORE FOCUSED AND IT
IN. IT IT CERTAINLY NEEDS TO BE
TONED DOWN DRASTICALLY ORIGINAL
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
MELINDA'S ANY FURTHER COMMENTS
CONSPIRED TO BAIT SEEING AND
HEARING NINE CENTER LAYERED YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT AND LET ME
THANK. ALL OUR COLLEAGUES FOR
WHAT I THINK WAS A VERY VERY
GOOD DEBATE IT IS CLEAR. FROM
THE DEBATE THE TWO COMPLEXITY
OF ADDRESSING ISSUES OF
CLIMATE- IS INTENSE AND THAT
GOING FORWARD WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS THE DIFFERENT ISSUES
THAT CAME UP. BUT WHAT IS IN
FRONT OF US NOW IS THIS AND
GIVEN A ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WAS JUST SAID THIS IS NOT A
BINARY CHOICE BETWEEN
ADDRESSING FIRE AND DOING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
SEPARATELY WE TOOK AMAZING
ACTION ON CLIMATE EARLIER THIS
WEEK WITH REGARD TO FIRE WITH
REGARD TO THE DROUGHT WITH
REGARD TO THE- ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCY POLICIES WE ACTED.
AND WE ALSO. ARE ACTING ON
EMISSIONS AND IT'S INTERESTING
BECAUSE JUST BEFORE WE CAME
BACK FROM THE RECESS I VISITED-
EIGHT EIGHT A PLANT IN MY
DISTRICT IT'S ONE OF THE
LARGEST BATTERY STORAGE PLANTS
AND WAS A FORM OF FOSSIL FUEL
PLANT. AND THERE ARE I WAS
GIVEN A TOUR BY WORK FOR OVER
FORTY YEARS SERVICE OF FOSSIL
FUEL WORKER FOR THIRTY YEARS
AND NOW COULD EXPLAIN TO ME
EVERYTHING ABOUT BATTERY
STORAGE. AND SO ARE A CHANCE
HERE IS TO SET A GOAL. ANSWER
SOME OF THESE QUESTIONS THAT
WERE RAISED IN THE DEBATE AS WE
IMPLEMENT THE GOAL AND CATCH UP
WITH WASHINGTON NEW YORK AND
MASSACHUSETTS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NOT AT FAULT. THANK YOU
SIR SENATOR LAYERED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA. ATKINS FIVE
EIGHTHS NO BACKER HI FORTUS NO
BRADFORD. BY ADAM. CORTESE
DALLY NO DOG NO TORONTO. AIKMAN
GLAZER. GONZALES HI GROSS NO
HERTZBERG. WHAT IS SO. HER TADO.
NO JONES NO CAN MONITOR.
LAYERED I LLEVA I THE MOON I
REQUIRE. I MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN. NIELSEN NO A CHARTER
BOTH KNOW PAM. FORTUNE TINO.
ROTH RUBIO. SKINNER I STERN
AMBERG. WHITE HOUSE SKI. I
WINNER I WILL KNOW PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA
BRADFORD. BY ZERO NO CORTESE.
TORONTO AIKMAN GLAZER.
HERTZBERG WESSEL. CAN LONGER.
NEWMAN PAM. FORTUNE TINO I.
ROTH RUBIO. STERN AMBERG.
REMOVE THE CALL. WE HAVE THE
NUMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
ARCHULETA BRADFORD QUARTET
THREE. TORONTO EGGMAN GLAZER.
HERTZBERG WEST SO. CAN LONGER.
NEWMAN CAN. ROTH RUBIO STERN
AMBERG.
THE NUMBER OF THE CALL
MEMBERS. MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
LIFT THE CALL ON FILE ITEM.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA I. FATES NO COME BY
YELLOW. EGGMAN IN. PAN. FORTINO
I RUBIO I STERN NUMBER HI. FIVE
TWENTY THREE NEWS TWELVETHE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FORTY
ONE SENATOR BRADFORD MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX EIGHTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE AN ACT
RELATING TO GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND CENTRE BRADFORD
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY ATTEMPTS TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT WE JUST HEARD RAISED- THE
LAST BILL PRESENTATION ABOUT
JOBS ABOUT. ACCOUNTABILITY
ABOUT MEASURABLE GOALS AND I'LL
CALL COMES THE SIMPLY
IMPLEMENTS KEY POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS IN A RECENT
REPORT BY THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD.
THESE THIS MEASURE REQUIRES
REPAIR RESOURCE FOR TO WORK
WITH LABOR AGENCIES TO UPDATE
FUNDING GUIDELINES FOR PROGRAMS
FUNDED BY THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND THIS WILL ENSURE
THAT THAT APPLICANTS USE FEAR
AND RESPECT RESPONSIBLE
STANDARDS TO PROMOTE HIGH
QUALITY JOBS INCLUSIVE
PROCUREMENT AND THE PREVAILING
WAGE OF CONSTRUCTION ON- FOR
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS.
CALIFORNIA LIKES TO INSERT
ITSELF AS WE HEARD IN THE
PREVIOUS DISCUSSION HAS BEEN A
GOAL GOAL GLOBAL LEADER WHEN IT
COMES TO COMBATING. CLIMATE
CHANGE BUT- THAT WORK CUTS BOTH
WAYS HOWEVER THERE IS A GROWING
EVIDENCE THAT OUR CLIENT
CLIMATE CHANGE INVESTMENTS ARE
NOT GOING TO THE COMMUNITIES
THAT NEED THEM THE MOST. THEY
ARE BEING IGNORED AND- THIS IS
SOME OF THE GREAT CONCERNS ON
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY. A REPORT
FROM UCLA CENTER FOR
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES FOUND
THAT THE STRUCTURE OF OUR
PLANNED INVESTMENTS IS SKEWED
TO BENEFIT MORE OF THE
FOLLOWING COMMUNITIES IN OUR
STATE AND OUR WORKING CLASS AND
ARE POOR. AN AUDIT BY CAR WHICH
I RECORD SET LAST YEAR AND
REPORTED BACK THIS YEAR THAT
MANY OF THE GREENHOUSE GAS.
REDUCTION PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED
BY THE DEPARTMENT FAILED TO
ACHIEVE ANY MEANINGFUL
EQUITABLE OR MEASURABLE
OUTCOMES GOALS THIS SHOULD BE
CONCERNING TO ALL OF US THESE
VALUES TO COME TO AT THE
EXPENSE OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. DESPITE BEING THE
POSTER CHILD FOR MANY OF THESE
PROGRAMS. THIS BILL WILL CLOSE
THE GAP BETWEEN OUR INTENTIONS
AND OUR OUTCOMES FOR GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND SPENDING.
ALSO WON A NOTE TO THE MEMBERS
THAT THE AUTHOR WILL SUBMIT A
LETTER TO THE SIMPLY JOURNAL
STATING SHE WILL CLARIFY NEXT
YEAR THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT.
AFFECT BUDGET ACTIONS ON
CLIMATE RESILIENCE AS THE MOOD
MEMBER BURKE WILL WORK WITH US
SENATOR FROM NAPA TO MAKE SURE
THIS ISSUE IS ADDRESSED TO
RESPECT LAST FRIDAY BOOK.
REVIEW CENTER BRADFORD MEMBERS
DISCUSSION. AND OR DEBATE
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE FLOOR JOCKEY IN THE AUTHOR.
AND THE OTHER SENATORS SENATOR-
FROM EQ FOR WORKING ON THE
ISSUE OF. OF THE LETTER THAT
SHE DID SUBMIT TO THE JOURNAL
ON. THIS WILL END THE CTUALLY
THE TRAILER BILL. IS WHAT
CAUSED THIS LETTER TO REACTION
TO HAVE TO COME SO I. I JUST
WANNA TAKE THOSE MEMBERS AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO NEXT YEAR
MAKING SURE- THAT WE WORK THIS
OUT SO THAT WE CAN KEEP THOSE
FOR THREE PROJECTS- GOING OUT
IN THE IN THE STATE. SO THANKS
AGAIN PERSIAN. AND THANK YOU
SENATOR DOLLY MEMBERS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR ALLEN'S JUST WANTED. TO
ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS
MADE FROM MY FRIEND FROM
DEEPER- THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
HER LETTER TO THE JOURNAL TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THIS
ISSUE ADDRESSED INVOLVING- THE
EFFICACIOUS FIGHTING THE FIRES-
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
ON THE ROAD COUNTIES BUT WITH
THAT I. ASKED FOR A VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR ALAN FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NINE CENTER
BRADFORD YOU MAY CLOSE IN ON
PRISONERS REQUEST FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I BASE. BACKER FORTUS.
BRADFORD I COME BY IT- I
PROTESTING. I DALLY. DOT HI
TORONTO HI ADNAN GLAZER.
GONZALEZ GROVE. GROVE NO
HERTZBERG. WHERE SO. HI HER
TADO. JONES NO CAN LONGER.
LAYERED HI LLEVA I THE MON I
REQUIRE. I MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A TRIO OF
BOTH NOPE PAN HI FORTUNE TINO.
FIVE ROTH. I RUBIO. I SKINNER I
STERN NUMBER HI I LIKE HOW SKI.
I WINNER I WILL NOW. PLEASE
CALL THE UPSET MEMBERS. BASED
UPON US. BACKER I GORGEOUS NO.
DALLY. I COMMEND GLAZER.
GONZALES HERZBERG I HER TADO I.
CAN LONGER I STERN. FIVE THREE
SEVEN NO SEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM FORTY TWO SENATOR
NUMBER. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BENNETT AN ACT RELATING TO
COURTS SENATOR UMBERG. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS- AB SEVEN SIXTEEN WOULD
REQUIRE COURTS PROVIDE THE
REMOTE ACCESS HEARINGS. BY
AUDIO STREAM OF THIS BILL WOULD
STRIKE A BALANCE BETWEEN
MEANINGFUL ACCESS IN COURT
FLEXIBILITY WITHOUT LIMITING A
JUDGE'S ABILITY TO HOLD CLOSE
PROCEEDINGS ARE GINGIVAL. THANK
YOU CENTER AMBERG MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I ADKINS I
BASE I BACKER I PORCHES I
BRADFORD HI BYRON I PROTESTING
I DALLY I DON. HI TORONTO HI
ADNAN LASER ARKANSAS IS GROWTH
HI HERTZBERG HI WEST SO I-
TANTO I JONES I CAN LONGER.
LAYERED HI FLAVOR I THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. I MEAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON. I ASSURE BOTH
I. TEN I. FORTUNE TINO. I
BROUGHT. I REVIEW I'VE SKINNER.
I STERN AMBERG HI BY CAL SKI.
WINNER I WILL I. PLEASE CALL
THE OF THE MEMBERS. EGGMAN
GONZALEZ CAN LONGER I STERN
WHITE HOUSE STATE. FIVE THIRTY
SIX NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
ONE MOMENT MEMBERS. MEMBERS ARE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FORTY
THREE SENATOR CALERO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS AN
ACTUAL RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT
SAFETY AND DECLARE ENTER THE
URGENCY BARRACKS MEETING.
CENTER PROVIDER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT AB
SEVENTY THREE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS AND
I AM A PROUD CO AUTHOR THE
FORMER CURVE WILDFIRE SMOKE
PROTECTION ACT WILL PROTECT
FARMWORKERS AND OTHER
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS DURING AN
UNHEALTHY AIR QALITY EVENTS
CAUSED BY WILDFIRE SMOKE WHILE
ALSO ADDRESSING THE CHALLENGES
THAT WILDFIRE SMOKE EVENTS
CREATE. FOR THE EMPLOYERS. WE
KNOW ALL TOO WELL THE IMPACT OF
WILDFIRES AND YOU WILL ALL
REMEMBER THE HAUNTING PHOTOS
AND FARM WORKERS. WORKING IN
THE FIELDS WITH PLUMES OF A
FIRE IN THE DISTANCE LAST YEAR
DURING THAT TIME THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD FILE FOUND
SPIKES AND TOXINS SUCH AS LEAD
ZINC AND MANGANESE DURING
WILDFIRE EVENTS ESPECIALLY WHEN
STRUCTURES BURNED. AT SEVENTY
THREE WILL ENSURE THAT FARM
WORKERS AND THEIR EMPLOYERS ARE
EQUIPPED WITH THE NECESSARY
TOOLS PP TO REDUCE HARM CAUSED
BY HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH WILDFIRE. L.
CODIFIED FORM OCCURS AS A
CENTRAL WORKERS SO THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT STOCKPILES FOR WHILE
FOR EMERGENCIES AND FINALLY IT
REQUIRES CAL OSHA TO UPDATE
WILDFIRE SMOKE TRAINING
REGULATIONS AND PROVIDE
MATERIAL AND LANGUAGES. NATIVE
TO FARM WORKERS THIS BILL IN A
JURY'S BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HAS
NOT RECEIVED ANY OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR
CAFIERO MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING IN. SENATOR
RAZA THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT-
I RISE AS CHAIR OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
AS ONE OF OUR PRIORITY BILLS
BECAUSE IT WILL PROTECT FARMERS
AND OTHER AGRICULTURAL WORKERS
DURING UNHEALTHY AIR QUALITY
EVENTS CAUSED BY THE WILDFIRES
SMOKE BUT DID BY DECLARING THEM
ESSENTIAL WORKERS EVERY YEAR
PICTURES GO VIRAL OF FARM
WORKERS TO CONTINUE WORKING OUR
IN OUR AGRICULTURAL FIELDS EVEN
IN THE MIDST OF TERRIBLE AIR
QUALITY CAUSED BY THE FIRES
THESE PICTURES OFTEN LOOK
APOCALYPTIC. ON THE DESK
POSITION BETWEEN THE WORKERS
WITH THE FIRES IN THE
BACKGROUND OUR CONSTANT
REMINDER OF THE RISKS THAT FARM
WORKERS PUT THEMSELVES IN TO
NOT ONLY PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES BUT ALSO TO KEEP
CALIFORNIANS FED. FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU CENTER
DRAWS- MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SENECA WHERE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I THINK MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM LOS ANGELES FOR HER
SUPPORT TODAY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AND I VOTE
THANK YOU CENTER CABALLERO
MEMBERS THIS MEASURE IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING. I'M SO SORRY WE HAVE NOT
ESTABLISHED YET SO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS I
FACE I BACKER. I PORCHES. HI
BRADFORD HI BY ADAM I
PROTESTING I DALLY. I DON HI
TORONTO HI ADNAN LASER. I
CONSOLIDATE GROWTH. BY HERTZ
BERG I WAS SO. HYFR TANTO HI
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED. I
LLEVA I THE MOON HI WIRE I
MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. I GO TO A BOOK HI PAM
I FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH I
REVIEW I SKINNER. I STERN
AMBERG HI WHAT KASKY I WINNER I
WILL I. PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. EGGMAN GONZALEZ STERN%
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. I NEED TO VOTE.
THIRTY SEVEN I ON THE URGENT
THIRTY SEVEN I ON THE- URGENCY.
NO. ZERO THIRTY SEVEN HIGHS ON
THE BILL THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO
THE S. THE- THE UNFINISHED
BUSINESS AND TAKE UP FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY TWO SENATOR LEYVA
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR LEYVA AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT. CENTER
LABOR THE FLOOR'S YOURS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
SENATE BILL SEVENTY SEVEN IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY WERE
CONFORMING AMENDMENTS REQUESTED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE
DIRECT CONTACT TRACTORS RECEIVE
AT LEAST THIRTY DAYS PRIOR
NOTICE. TO THE COMMENCEMENT OF
ANY ACTION MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SENATOR HERTZBERG
QUICKLY MADAM PRESIDENT I THINK
IT'S A GREAT PHILOSOPHER AND I
VOTE. SENATOR TROUBLED. THAT
I'M PRESIDENT I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN BECAUSE I DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THE ROOT OF THE
PROBLEM IF THERE ARE BAD ACTORS
AMONG SUBCONTRACTORS THEN WE
SHOULD BE FOCUSING OUR RESPONSE
AND BOLSTERING OUR ENFORCEMENT
OR EXISTING LAWS BY PROVIDING
BETTER FUNDING AND RESOURCES TO
OUR ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES I ALSO
HAVE CONCERNS BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THAT THIS BILL WILL FURTHER
EXASPERATED AN ALREADY DIRE
HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR STATE. I
URGE THIS LEGISLATURE TO FIND
MORE COMMON SENSE SOLUTIONS FOR
HOLDING PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR ACTIONS THE WELL INTENDED
THIS BILL WOULD HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A NO VOTE. THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. FURTHER DSCUSSION OR
DEBATE SINGMAN CENTER LABOR YOU
MAY CONCLUDE HAN CONCURRENCE
ASKING MEMBERS FROM A VOTE ON
THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY THANK YOU. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I
FACE. NO BACKER HI FORGES NO
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI I.
FOR TENNESSEE. HI DALLY NO DOG
I DRAW SO HI AIKMAN GLAZER.
GONZALEZ GROSS NO HERTZBERG HI
WEST SO I HER TADO I JONES NO
CAN LONGER I LAYERED. I LLEVA.
I THE MOON I REQUIRE. HI%
MELINDA'S NO MAN. I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF BOTH NO
PAM I FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS I
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG
ALL RIGHT I LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL LOOK. PLEASE CALL
THE UPSET MEMBERS. ADMIN GLAZER.
GONZALEZ STERN WELL NO. FIVE
TWENTY SEVEN NEWS NINE THE
MEASURE OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
ARE CONCURRED IN MEMBERS WE ARE
NOW GOING TO TAKE A LUNCH BREAK
WE'RE GOING TO COME BACK HERE
IN CHAMBERS AT ONE THIRTY SHARP
PLEASE WE STILL HAVE A LOT OF
WORK TO DO PLEASE TAKE YOUR
DEBT- LUNCH TO YOUR OFFICE SO
THAT WE CAN MAINTAIN SOCIAL
DISTANCING SEE YOU IN OUR
MEMBER'S.
AGAIN ON DECEMBER
THIRD READING. WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH FILE ITEM FORTY SIX
SENATOR JONES. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
THIRTEEN BY SENT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SMITH AN ACT RELATING TO
COLLATERAL RECOVERY CENTER
JONES THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE THIRTEEN-
UPDATING KERR FI IS THE
COLLATERAL RECOVERY ACT IN THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
TO REFLECT CURRENT PRACTICES
RECENT AMENDMENT TO NARROW THE
BILL WERE TAKEN AT THE REQUEST
OF DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS. AND THE BUREAU OF
SECURITY AND INVESTIGATIVE
SERVICES THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS RECEIVED NO
NO VOTES- SOME REMEMBER SMITH
AND I ASK FOR YOUR I. VOTE
THANK YOU CENTER JONES MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. ARCHULETA I ADKINS HI
PLEASE HI BACKER. HI FORTUS.
BRADFORD. BY ADAM I PROTESTING
I DALLY I THOUGHT. I TORONTO I
EGGMAN GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE.
GROVE HI HURTS BERG I WAS SO.
HER TADO I JONES I CAN LONGER.
LAYERED I LLEVA I THE MOMENT I
WIRE. HI MELINDA'S I BEEN I
NEWMAN. NIELSEN. NEWMAN I
NIELSEN- SHOW BOTH I CAN HI
PERSONS YOU KNOW. HI RALPH HI
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN NUMBER
I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER. I WILL
LOOK. I SENATOR MUSICAL MEMBERS
WERE MOVING TOO FAST TO FILE
ITEM FORTY FOUR CENTER CUT BY
AERO MEN SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN OH THREE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DALLY AN ACT
RELATING TO AGRICULTURAL LANDS
CENTER COPIER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB ELEVEN OH THREE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYWOMAN MEGAN
DOLLY. THIS BILL CREATES
STANDARDIZED TRAINING AND A
FRAMEWORK FOR A LIVESTOCK PASS
PROGRAM TO ALLOW RANCHERS
ACCESS TO THE PROPERTY IN AN
EMERGENCY TO SAVE THEIR
LIVESTOCK AND ASSIST EMERGENCY
PERSONNEL BY IDENTIFYING ACCESS
ROADS AND WATER SOURCES THIS
BILL WILL PROVIDE COUNTIES WITH
A VALUABLE TOOL. BY REQUIRING
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL TO
ESTABLISH A STATEWIDE FRAMEWORK
AND TRAINING PROGRAM FOR A
LIVESTOCK PASS PROGRAM COVERING
THE FIRE BEHAVIOR AND EMERGENCY
RESPONSE ENSURING LIVESTOCK
OWNERS HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE AND
TOOLS TO SAFELY RESCUE THEIR
ANIMALS DURING AND IMMEDIATELY
AFTER A NATURAL DISASTER. A
LIVESTOCK PASS HOLDER WOULD BE
ALLOWED TO AN EMERGENCY
RESPONSE AREA ONLY WITH THE
CONSENT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
QUITE FRANKLY IF IT'S SAFE THE
AUTHOR WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING LABOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF WINE GRAPE
GROWERS AND CAL FIRE ON THIS
BILL WHICH ENJOYS NO OPPOSITION
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THE
CENTRE COUPLE EURO MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE. MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WITH ALAN. HI ARCHULETA I
ADKINS I HATE. HI BACKER. I
PORCHES. BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM I PROTESTING I DALLY I DON
HI TORONTO. HI ADNAN LASER. I
BEEN SOLID GROWTH. I HURTS BERG
I WAS SO. HI FURTADO I JONES I
CAN LONGER LAYERED HI LLEVA I
THE MOMENT. I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S I MEANT I NEWMAN I
NELSON. A TRUCKLOAD HI PAM I
FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS I REVIEW
FIVE SKINNER I STERN AMBERG I
LIKE HOW SKI HI WE- I WILL I
DIDN'T REMOVE THE CALL MEMBERS
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
FORTY FIVE THE SENATOR TEEN-
BEEN SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO TO TWENTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALMOST AN ACT
RELATING TO CARE FACILITIES
CENTER FORTINO. THANK YOU A MAN
PRESIDENT MEMBERS A. B. TWO TO
SIX WOULD CLARIFY LICENSING
ISSUES AND ENSURE MUCH NEEDED
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR CHILDREN'S
CRISIS RESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS
CURRENTLY AN ESTIMATED THREE
OUT OF EVERY FOUR CHILDREN IN
THE UNITED STATES YOU NEED
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES DID NOT
RECEIVE THEM. SUICIDE IS NOW
THE SECOND LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH AMONG ADOLESCENTS IN
ADDITION FORTY SEVEN OUT OF
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES HAVE NO
CHILD PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITAL
INPATIENT BEDS FOR CHILDREN
UNDER TWELVE. THE NEED FOR
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH
RESIDENTIAL SERVICES COULD NOT
BE MORE URGENT AB TWO TO SIX
WOULD CLARIFY THAT PROGRAMS
THAT PLAN TO PROVIDE TWENTY
FOUR HOUR CHILDREN'S CRISIS
RESIDENTIAL SERVICES- TO
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES UNDER
AGE OF TWENTY ONE SHALL BE
DESIGNATED AS PSYCHIATRIC
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT PROGRAMS.
THIS BILL WILL ADD A
DESPERATELY NEEDED SERVICE TO
THE CONTINUUM OF MENTAL CARE
CRISIS SERVICES UNDER MEDICARE
OUT EARLY IN. ATIKA SCREENING
DIAGNOSIS AND TREATMENT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A- THANK YOU CENTER FORTINO
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SENATOR TOWBOAT.
AFTERNOON PRESIDENT AND THEN
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS AS CHAIR
OF THE INLAND EMPIRE CAUCUS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO TWENTY SIX THIS BILL
CLARIFIES THAT THE RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAMS MUST BE APPROVED AS
PSYCHIATRIC SAID RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT FACILITIES. TO
MAXIMIZE FEDERAL FUNDING AND
ENSURE AVAILABILITY OF THESE
CRITICAL SERVICES FOR YOU. THIS
BIPARTISAN SOLUTION WILL
DIRECTLY BENEFIT RESIDENTS IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE. FOR THIS
REASON EIGHTY TWO TWENTY SIX IS
A PRIORITY BILL FOR THE CAUCUS
I ASKED FOR AND I. THE USER
OCHO BOGUT MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONEMEMBERS THIS
QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE I WAS
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON THE
FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN SENATOR
HER TADO AM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
SEVENTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ALMOST AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES CENTER
HER TADO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I HAVE HERE A B.
EIGHT SEVEN THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROMMEL'S WHICH
PROHIBITS AGREEMENTS BETWEEN
CDSS ANY TRAVEL ORGANIZATION
THAT INCLUDE PROVISIONS
REQUIRING THE TRIBE TO PAY AN
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. SHARE FOR
LEGALLY REPRESENTED A CHILD IN
CARE AND CUSTODY CASES. IN
DOING SO THE BILL PROTECTS
TRIBAL RIGHTS ENCOURAGES STATE
TRIBAL COLLABORATION TO PROMOTE
CHILD AND FAMILY WELL BEING.
AND FACILITATES ACCESS TO
AVAILABLE FEDERAL FUNDS THIS
BILL HAS OPPOSITION HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
BOTH. THINK YOU SENT HER TADO
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING I THREE SO
NINE ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FIVE AND FORTY NINE
SENATOR MEN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SEVENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOW AN ACT RELATING TO
AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR. CENTER IN
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY ONE
IMPROVES THE CURRENT CITATION
AND FINE REGULATORY PROGRAM
UNDER THE BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR BY CREATING AN
INDEPENDENT CITATION CONFERENCE
PANEL TO REVIEW CITATIONS THIS
BILL HAS NO FORMAL OPPOSITION
AND PAST SEVENTY SEVEN TO ONE
ADDIE ASSEMBLY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
MEN NUMBERS DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE I
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES WE ARE NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FIFTY
SENATOR PAN MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
FIFTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SANTIAGO AN ACT RELATING TO
TELEHEALTH CENTER MA'AM THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS-
PLEASE PRESENT EIGHTY FOUR
FIFTY SEVEN BY SOME MEMBER
SANTIAGO WHICH CREATES A
PROTECTION OF PATIENT CHOICE IN
TELEHEALTH PROVIDER ACT THESE
ARE PATIENTS RECEIVE ADEQUATE
AND EFFICIENT TELEHEALTH
SERVICES. AS WE EXPAND ACCESS
TO TELEHEALTH SUPPORT ESTABLISH
ADEQUATE SAFEGUARDS FOR
PATIENTS SURE TO GET QUALITY
CARE. THIS BILL WOULD GIVE
PATIENTS THE OPTION TO USE THE
PROVIDER OF THEIR CHOICE IN
PERSON OR VIA TELEHEALTH AND
THEN IT'S TAKEN IN THE SENATE
REMOVED OPPOSITION FROM. MANY
OF THE HEALTH PLANS- AND THE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCEEXPECT THE
ASK FOR AND I DON'T THINK YOU
CENTER PANEL MEMBERS. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. C. AND
HEARING THE MATTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I ACTIONS I FACE HI
BACKER. HI PORCHES HI BRADFORD
I COME BY ADAM I PROTESTING I
DALLY. I DONT HI TORONTO HI
ADNAN GLAZER ICONS OLIVE GROVE
HI HURTS BURKE I WISH SO HI PER
TANTO HI JONES. I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED ON HIGH LABOR I LIVE
ALONE HI WIRE HI HI MELINDA'S I
MEN. HI NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A
TOTAL OF BOTH. I STAND BY I
FOURTEEN TO NO. HI RALPH I
REVIEW HI SKINNER. I STERN
NUMBER I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER.
I WILL HI. THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES WHO DEFIED
AND I'M FIFTY ONE SENATOR BATES
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PETRI NORRIS AN
ACT RELATING TO ALCOHOLISM AND
DRUG ABUSE OR DRUG ABUSE
SENTIMENTS THANK YOU AND HAVE A
DANCE MY PRIVILEGE TO PRESENT
AT ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT ON BEHALF
OF THE FAMILY OF WOMEN PETRI
NORA SPIREITES TO PRESENT
ALREADY SAID THAT THE GOAL OF
THIS BILL IS TO IMPROVE PATIENT
PROTECTIONS AND INCREASED
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE FOR
PATIENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
SEEKING SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT. MAYBE ELEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT AIMS TO INCREASE
STANDARDS BY ESTABLISHING
MINIMUM INSURANCE COVERAGE
LEVELS FOR LICENSED DRUG ABUSE
RECOVERY AND TREATMENT
FACILITIES AND RECOVERY
RESIDENCE THAT CONTACT CONTRACT
WITH THE GOVERNMENT THE BILL
HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BUILT THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
HEARING THEN I. THIRTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING BACK
TO UNFINISHED BUSINESS WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE ITEM.
SIX AND THAT IS SENATOR
BRADFORD MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SIX NINETY
FOUR BY SENATOR BRADFORD AND
ACTUALLY DID YOU FIRE
PREVENTION THE RECORD THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AS V. SIX NINE
FOUR IT'S A MEASURE THAT
CREATES OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CONSERVATION CORPS MEMBERS AS
WELL AS FORMALLY INCARCERATED
FIREFIGHTERS TO WORK ON
WILDFIRE MITIGATION AND WE ALL
KNOW IT'S PROBABLY NEED IT.
THIS BILL REQUIRES INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES REPORT ON THEIR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT EFFORTS
PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE SPECIFIC
COMMUNITIES OF SKILLED WORKERS-
BY EVERY METRIC CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES OUR SHORTAGE OF
PEOPLE WORKING IN THE WILDFIRE
MITIGATION SPACE THIS BILL WILL
HELP FILL THAT SHORTAGE BY
CONNECTING THOSE WITH. THOSE
NECESSARY SKILLS AT REDUCING
THE RISK OF WILDFIRES AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION. OR
DEBATE SENATOR BORCHERS. I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THE CENTER PARTY
THIS IS BILL I THINK THIS IS-
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BEEN
DONE. EARLIER IF WE COULD HAVE.
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE WE'RE
DOING NOW IS FANTASTIC WE'VE
SEEN FROM THE EXPERIENCE WITH
WILDFIRES. CREATING A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE OR VACATION CORE
CREATING OPPORTUNITY FOR
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS. OFFER TRAINING TO
PROVIDE COMMUNITY SERVICE THIS
IS ACTUALLY THE RIGHT STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION I APPLAUD
HIM FOR HIS AUTHORSHIP. THANK
YOU SENATOR PORCHES MEMBERS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY. SIX SENATOR NELSON
BETTER PRESENTATION THE SENATE
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF THIS
LEGISLATION- ONE OF THE-
INSTALLATIONS THAT WE ARE
CONFRONTED WITH NOW INMATE
LABOR IS NOT MUCH AVAILABLE.
SOME BUT NOT MUCH BUT I HAVE
LONG ADVOCATED FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
PARTICIPATION TO BE INCREASED
THIS IS SIGNIFICANTLY GOING TO
HELP THAT. THESE CONSERVATION
CORPORATE MEMBERS HAVE BEEN SO
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER THE YEARS AS
THEY PARTICIPATED ON THE FRONT
LINES OF FIRING LINE. AND THEY
LEARN SO MUCH. AND THEY'RE SUCH
A MOTIVATED BUNCH OF YOUNG
PEOPLE BEFORE AND THEY ALL GET
ON SUCCESSFUL LIFE PATHWAYS
THROUGH THIS SO IT'S A GREAT
COMBINATION. I HAVEN'T BEEN
NOURISHING AND ENCOURAGINGAND
MENTORING OUR YOUTH AND HELPING
US CONTAIN OUR FIRE PROBLEMS
AND THEY DON'T JUST FIGHT
FIRES. THEY HELP CLEAN THE
FORESTS AND WILDLANDS ALSO AND
THEY WORK ON OTHER EMERGENCY
DISASTERS SUCH AS FLOODS. THANK
YOU SENATOR NELSON MEMBERS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE AMENDMENTS SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MEMBERS IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. YOU GOTTA GET ON THIS
ROLL CALL THE MESS UP. FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED END MEMBERS RENOWNED
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN SENATOR GLAZER. NOT AT
HIS DESK. FOLLOWING HIM EIGHT
SENATOR RUBIO. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL THREE
TEN BY SENATOR RUBIO AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC HEALTH.
SENATOR RUBIO. I THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE I RISE
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL THREE
TEN WHICH IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ADDED LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS THE
BOARD OF THE PHARMACIES
CONCERNS ALLOWING ADDITIONAL
OVERSIGHT AND MAKING OTHER
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE I HAVE
THREE SEVEN NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN PART I ITEM NUMBER
NINE SENATOR ALAN. NUMBER. NINE
BENHAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL SIX TWENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR ALAN AN ACT RELATING TO
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT CENTER
ALAN. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SO THIS IS THE CREATIVE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT ACT WOULD
DIRECT THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL TO ESTABLISH AND
EARN AND LEARN PROGRAM IN
CONSULTATION WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. AND COMMUNITY
NONPROFITS TEMPLATE CREATIVE
WORKERS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES-
THE BILL WOULD ESTABLISH A
TRAINING PROGRAM FOCUSED ON
DEVELOPING MARKETABLE SKILLS IN
THE ARTS PRIORITISING LOW
INCOME UNEMPLOYED. AND
DISADVANTAGED PERSONS BEGINNING
THEIR CAREERS IN THE CREATIVE
ARTS THE BILL RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. IN THE
SENATE ME SOMEBODY'S GOT. A
BROAD SUPPORT FROM CREATIVE
INDUSTRY WORKERS EMPLOYERS AND
UNIONS ACROSS THE STATE
INDUSTRY FOLKS AS WELL. AND I
RESPECT FASHIONABLE. THE CENTRE
ALAN MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING THAT
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. EXCUSE ME SENATOR RUBIO
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- I ALSO- AS A
PRACTICAL OUT THERE THIS
MEASURE I WANNA ALSO
RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN I VOTE
THIS BILL IS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO THE CALIFORNIA CREDIT WORK
FORCE ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WE WILL WHICH WILL PROMOTE OUR
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES EARN
TO LEARN. JOB TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE CREATIVE
WORKERS ACCORDING TO STUDIES
SHOW 96% OF CREATIVE WORKERS
HAVE LOST REVENUE EMPLOYMENT
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC THIS
BILL NOT ONLY PUTS VALUE IN THE
ARTS PROMOTES DIVERSITY AND
CREATES JOBS SO WITH THAT I
ALSO ASK FOR ARRIVAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO CENTER
ALLN DID YOU WISH TO CLOSE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
LEADERSHIP OF MY COLLEAGUE WHO
JUST SPOKE INCLUDING ON THE
OTHER THE OTHER MAJOR ARTS
BILL. ZERO FIVE THEY GOT
THROUGH AND WHEN I THINK HER
AND THAT'S WHEN I HAVE A- THE
CENTRE AL. OF SICK PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I BASE. BACKER HI FOR
JUST. BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM I
PROTESTING HI DOLLY I DON. I
TORONTO I EDMUND GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE GROWTH. HI HURTS
BERG HI WITH SO. HI HER TADO I
JONES NO CAN LONGER. I LAYERED
HI LLEVA I THE MON I REQUIRE. I
MELINDA'S. IN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH I PAM
I FORTINO. I. ROSS HI RUBIO. I
SKINNER I STERN AMBERG HI I
LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER. I WILL.
HI PLEASE CALL THE OF THE
MEMBERS. BASED I. PORCHES I
EDMUND GONZALES BELINDA'S.
STERN. THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO THE
SIMPLY MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING THE FILE ITEM TEN
SENATOR SKINNER. EXCUSE ME FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE WAS THIRTY
FIVE ONE. RIGHT NOW MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM TEN SENATOR
SKINNER MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SIXTY FIVE BY
SENATOR SKINNER. THERE'S GONNA.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS. SB SIXTY FIVE BACK TO
CONCURRENCE IS CALIFORNIA'S MOM
DID THIS ACT MAMBAS RECOGNIZES
THAT MATERNAL AND INFANT
MORTALITY IN THE US IS TOO HIGH
AND IT IS TOO HIGH ESPECIALLY
FOR BLACK BABIES AND MOTHERS.
THE AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY
REFLECT SEVERAL ACTIONS TAKEN
IN THE BUDGET THEY MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO THE
CALIFORNIA PREGNANCY ASSOCIATED
REVIEW BOARD AND CREATE A
WORKING GROUP TO AID IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW
MEDICO DO LESS BENEFIT THAT WAS
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS ON CONCURRENCE THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE. MAN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I HATE. I
BACKER. I FOR JUST BRADFORD I
COME BY ADAM I PROTESTING I
DALLY NO DOG. I TORONTO HI
EGGMAN GLAZER AIKENS OLIVE
GROVE NO HERTZBERG I WAS SO I
HER TADO I JONES. NO CAN LONGER.
I LAYERED HI LLEVA I THE MOON
HI WIRE. HI MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON NO A TROUBLED.
I PAM MY FORTUNE TINO. I ROTH I
REVIEW. I SKINNER. I STERN
NUMBER FIVE CASSIE I WINNER I
WILL HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. FOR JUST NO. EGGMAN IN
SOLACE MELINDA'S STERN. FIVE
THIRTY ONE NEWS FIVE DECEMBER
MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN MEMBER
REMOVING THE FILE ITEM ELEVEN
SENATOR TORONTO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL TWO
SEVENTY BY SENATOR ALSO AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
CENTRE TORONTO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AS B. TWO
SEVENTIES BACK ON CONCURRENCE
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY
EXTENDED THE CURE PERIOD FOR
EMPLOYERS TO PROVIDE ACCURATE
BARGAINING UNIT UNIT DATA TO
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS WAS
EXTENDED FROM TEN DAYS TO
TWENTY DAYS. GIVING EMPLOYERS
MORE FLEXIBILITY TO COMPLY WITH
THE LAW I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU CENTER
JURADO MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
THEN MEMBER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
I ATKINS I HATE NO BACKER. I
FORTUS NO BRADFORD I HAVE A
ADAM I PROTESTING I DALLY NO
DOG. I TORONTO I EGGMAN LASER
NOW OPENS ALL THIS GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO HI HER TADO
HI JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. I LLEVA HI HI THE MOON
HI MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON KNOW WHAT YOUR
VOTE NO PAM I FORTUNE TINO I
ROTH HI RUBIO. I SKINNER I
STERN AMBERG HI LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER. I WILL. NO PLEASE CALL
THE OF THE MEMBERS. EGGMAN
GONZALEZ GROVE. NO STERN. FIVE
TWENTY SEVEN NEWS TEN DECEMBER
MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN FAVOR
OF REMOVING THE FILE I'M TWELVE
SENATOR HUESO. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL THREE
ELEVEN BY SENATOR HUESO AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES. IN A WAY SO. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT CENTERS I
PRESENTS SP THREE ELEVEN THE
COMPASSIONATE ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CANNABIS SECTOR RYAN'S LAW THE
STORE WOULD REQUIRE HOSPITALS
IN CERTAIN TYPES OF HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO ALLOW TERMINALLY
ILL PATIENTS ACCESS MEDICAL
CANNABIS FOR TREATMENT OF PAIN
RELEASES BECAUSE BEEN AMENDED
AS PART OF AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN
MY OFFICE. AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WHICH PUT THE WITH INPUT FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THE
AMENDMENT SIMPLY REQUIRE
HOSPITALS TO REASONABLY
RESTRICT THE MANNER IN WHICH A
PATIENT'S STORES AND USES
MEDICAL CANNABIS INCLUDING
REQUIRING THE MEDICAL CANNABIS
TO BE STORED IN A LOCKED
CONTAINER TO ENSURE THE SAFETY
OF OTHER PATIENTS GUESTS. AND
EMPLOYEES OF THE HEALTH
FACILITY COMPLIANCE WITH THE
STATE LAWS AND SAFE OPERATIONS
OF THE HEALTH CARE FACILITY.
THIS LANGUAGE WAS PREVIOUSLY IN
THE BILL BUT THE AMENDMENTS
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT IT IS WERE
REQUIRED NOT JUST ALLOWED-
REQUIRE IT ALSO REQUIRES HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES PERMITTING
PATIENT USE OF MEDICAL
CANNABIS. TO COMPLY WITH DRUG
AND MEDICATION REQUIREMENTS
APPLICABLE TO SCHEDULE TWO
THREE AND FOUR DRUGS AND BE
SUBJECT TO ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS.
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH THESE RULES ARE SPECIFIC
TO THE USE STORAGE AND TRACKING
OF MEDICAL CANNABIS ONLY. THIS
MEANS THAT THE FACILITY WOULD
CREATE POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
FOR CHECK IN IN. THE CANNABIS
AND THE STORAGE OF THE CANNABIS
WELL IN THE FACILITY NOTHING IN
THIS BILL REQUIRES FACILITY TO
DISPENSE. THE CAT CANNABIS FROM
THE PHARMACY. CMS HAS TOLD CITY
PH THAT THEY WILL NOT ENFORCE
ANY ACTIONS AGAINST A FACILITY.
UNLESS ANOTHER AGENCY WITH
JURISDICTION TAKES ENFORCEMENT
ACTION. FOR PERMITTING MEDICAL
CANNABIS AND THEY EXPECT YOU TO
BE H. TWO MONITORS STORAGE AND
TRACKING AS WE WOULD ANY OTHER.
MEDICATION SP THREE NOT THE
LEVIN WILL PROVIDE RELIEF
COMPASSION DIGNITY. TO
TERMINALLY ILL CALIFORNIANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES AS FOR NOW
THOUGH. THANK YOU CENTER WHERE
SOME MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SENATOR PAM. I T. RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE ELEVEN
AND AT FIRST WHILE I RECOGNIZE
THE HARD WORK OF. THE AUTHOR-
AND WORKING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BAR PUBLIC HEALTH I JUST WANNA
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THE
AMENDMENTS DO NOT REQUIRED THE
HOSPITAL TO ACTUALLY TAKE
POSSESSION OF THE MARIJUANA- WE
WANNA BE SURE THAT- THIS IS THE
THIS BILL OF. IT WILL ENABLE
PATIENTS TO- TO TAKE MARIJUANA
AS INTENDED BY THIS BILL AND
AGAIN APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK
OF THE AUTHOR WORKING WITH C.
DPH AND WITH- THE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO BE SURE THAT
THE BILL TO USE ITS AIMS I ALSO
ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR PAM CENTER JONES.
ELEVEN I RISE TODAY TO ASK THE
BODY TO- OFTEN I VOTE ON THIS
ITEM THANK YOU. THE CENTER
JONES SENT AWAY SO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. POSSIBLY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOVEL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BYE RECENT
THINKCENTRE WAY SO MEMBERS THIS
QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
THERE'S AN OBJECTION MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA. I CANS HI
EIGHT. HI BECKER HI FOR JUST. I
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM I
PROTESTING I DALLY NO DODD.
FIVE TORONTO. HI A COMMON LASER
I CONSOLIDATE ROVE I HURTS BERG
HI WESTERN HI HER TADO HI JONES
I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I LABOR
HI THE MOMENT I REQUIRE. I
BELINDA I MEANT. I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A TELEPHONE. I CAN I
FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH I RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG I
LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER. HI WELL
I. FIVE THIRTY SIX NEWS ONE THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE I'M THIRTEEN
SENATOR EIGHT MEN. SENATOR
RUBIO IS GOING TO BE TAKING
THAT UP FOR HER MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL THREE
TWENTY BY SENATOR RUBY BY
SENATOR ADMIN AN ACT RELATING
TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE MR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
SENATE COLLEAGUES TODAY I'M
PRESENTING SP THREE TWENTY ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR ADMIN WHICH
SEEKS TO BETTER PROTECT
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
FROM GUN VIOLENCE. SB THREE
TWENTY CODIFIED AN EXISTING
RULE OF COURT THAT CREATES A
JUDICIAL OVERSIGHT PROCESS
RELINQUISH AT THE EARLIEST
MOMENT POSSIBLE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER
PROCEEDINGS. AND CREATES A LINE
OF COMMUNICATION BETWEEN LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT PROSECUTORS AND
THE COURT THAT WILL HELP TO
PREVENT CIVIL INSTANCES. OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE FROM
ESCALATING TO CRIMINAL ASSAULT
OR MURDER AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THE ASSEMBLY CLARIFY HOW THE
PROVISION OF SB THREE TWENTY
WILL WORK WITHIN THE EXISTING
FIREARM. RELINQUISHMENT
FRAMEWORK SB THREE TWENTY HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE. THE CENTER
RUBIO MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
ANONYMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
NO ZERO THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. WE'RE MOVING
OUT OF FILE I'M FOURTEEN
SENATOR CABALLERO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE TWENTY THREE BY
SENATOR KERR BIO AN ACT
RELATING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CENTER CAMARO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT AS B. THREE TWENTY
THREE FOR CONCURRENCE THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THIS THE
ASSEMBLY ADD AN ADDITIONAL
NOTIFICATION WILL GO OUT TO
CUSTOMERS INFORMING THEM ABOUT
THE NEW HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAY.
TIMELINE PRIOR TO THE ADOPTION
OF A NEW RATE CHANGE IN SEWER
AND WATER UTILITY BILLS BUT
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
THANK YOU SENATOR CAFIERO
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING THAT
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I FACE NO BACKER I
PORCHES. BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM I PROTESTING FIVE DALLY I
DON I TORONTO HI EGGMAN GLAZER
AIKENS OLIVE GROVE. HERTZBERG I
WAS SO HI HER TADO I JONES. I
CAN ORDER. I LAYERED I LABOR I
THE MOON I ACQUIRE I MELINDA'S
NO MAN. I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. I
GO TO A VOTE. I CAN I FOURTEEN
TINO I ROCKED I REVIEW. I
SKINNER I STERN AMBERG WELL I
WAKE COUNTY HI WINNER I WILL.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. PORCHES EGGMAN
GONZALEZ GROWTH. STERN I WAS
THIRTY THREE NOSE TO DECEMBER
MOMENTS ARE CONFERRED IN FILE
ITEM FIFTEEN SENATOR HER TADO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL FOR TWENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR HER TADO AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE CENTRE HER TADO THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AS BEFORE
TWO EIGHT IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AND ASSEMBLY
MOMENTS ADDRESS DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO RESOLVE
FACTORY COMPLEXES BILL HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE. WE
CONSIDER HER TADO MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
RUBIO THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATE COLLEAGUES I ALSO WRITE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
TWENTY EIGHT AS A FORMER
TEACHER I HAVE SEEN UP CLOSE TO
THIS THE DEVASTATING IMPACTS
THAT ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES CAN HAVE ON A CHILD
SOMATIC EXPERIENCES AT A YOUNG
AGE HAVE LIGHT LIFE LONG
LASTING IMPACTS NOT JUST WITHIN
THEIR HEALTH BUT ALSO THEIR
ABILITY TO SUCCEED AND LEARN IN
THE CLASSROOM ANDIN ADULTHOOD.
CERTAINLY WE KNOW THAT THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE NINETEEN
WILL ONLY MAKE THIS WORSE THAT
IS WHY THIS WAS SO IMPORTANT
AND SO NEED IT WITHOUT I ALSO
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE AS A PROP
COOPER THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO MEMBERS. FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SO AND
HEARING. SENT HER TO WHICH LIKE
CLOSE. I RESPECT RESTAURANT
ABOUT VERY GOOD. MEMBERS THERE
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
AND HEARING THEM I WAS THIRTY
SEVEN WINDOWS ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
PART I ITEM SIXTEEN SENATOR
ALAN MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY
THREE BY SENATOR ALAN AN ACT
RELATING TO RESENTENCING
CONSIDER SENATOR ALAN MEMBERS
THIS IS A BILL- THAT YOU HEARD
WE HEARD BEFORE IT HAS TO DO
WITH- WITH WITH THE TWO-
SENTENCE ENHANCEMENT. BILLS
THAT WERE PASSED BY THIS HOUSE
BEFORE CENTER WINNERS CENTER
MITCHELL'S. THOSE TWO BILLS OF
COURSE- WERE WERE ARE GONE A
GOING FORWARD BASIS IN THIS
RETROACTIVELY APPLIES THEM
BECAUSE IN THE END OF THE DAY
WE WANNA MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
ARE TREATED EQUALLY. REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER THEY'RE SENTENCED IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO VERSUS TWENTY
SIXTEEN. ONE THING TO MENTION
IS THAT THE- THE AMENDMENTS
SEMELE- ESTABLISH A PROCESS FOR
THE COURT TO HOLD A HEARING IF
IT CHOOSES SO IT GIVES. YOU A
VISUAL DISCRETION BEFORE ANY OF
THESE SENTENCES MIGHT BE ROLLED
BACK THE REASON BEING. THAT
SOMETIMES. PROSECUTORS WILL
ENTER INTO. A DEAL THEY'LL ADD
IN SOME ADVANCEMENTS. AS PART
OF THE PLEA DEAL OR AS PART OF
THE SETTLEMENT. AND AND DID SO
BY BY UNILATERALLY ROLLING BACK
THESE PARTICULAR ENHANCEMENTS
MAYBE THE PROSECUTOR WOULD USE
A DIFFERENT ONE INSTEAD. SO WE
WANTED TO GIVE THE JUDGES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK
HOLISTICALLY AT THE PACKAGE AND
THEN MAKE A DECISION SO AS A
RESULT NOW THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL'S NEUTRAL ON THE BILL.
BECAUSE OF THE JUDICIAL
DISCRETION THE BILL GIVES. AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU CENTER ALAN MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
FACE NO BECKER. I FORGES NO
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM. I
PROTESTING. I DALLY NO DOG. HI
TORONTO HI ADNAN GLAZER.
GONZALEZ GROVE NO HURTS BERG I
WEAR SO. HI HER TADO NO JONES
NO CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I
LABOR HI I THE MON I REQUIRE. I
MELINDA'S NO MEN. NEWMAN
NIELSEN NO TROUBLE NO PAN I
FORTINO. I ROTH I REVERE FIVE
SKINNER I STERN AMBERG HI HI
MIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL
KNOW PLEASE CALL THE UPSET
MEMBERS. EGGMAN LASER I
CONSOLIDATE MAN. NEWMAN I STERN.
FIVE THREE SIX IN THOSE TEN
DECEMBER MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE I'M SEVENTEEN SENATOR
PAM MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE TEN BY SENATOR
PAN AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE IN THE PAN THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS SP
FIVE TENS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
THIS BILL IS SURE IS THAT YOUR
CONSTITUENTS CAN GET THE COBRA
TESTS AND VACCINATIONS WITHOUT
COPAYS YES ONLY MOMENTS TO FIND
SPIKE NAP DIAGNOSTIC AND
SCREENING TESTING AND REMOVES
URGENCY CLASS ARE STRICTLY
ASPEN I VOTE ON CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU SENATOR PANEL MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
WILL. TAKING PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS- BASED UPON THE
ANNOUNCEMENT AND THE NEW
GUIDELINES FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT YESTERDAY. THIS
SEEMS TO ME TO BE AWFULLY
PREMATURE I THINK WE'RE PUTTING
THE CART BEFORE THE HORSE. AND
BY TAKING THIS ACTION TODAY
WELL WE'RE GONNA BE DOING IS
ESTABLISHING MANDATES. AND
POTENTIALLY WALKING IN COST
BURDENS FOR SCREENING. FOR THE
HEALTH PLANS AS WELL AS THOSE
THAT ARE INSURED WHEN WE MAY
NOT HAVE TO BASED UPON-
COMMENTS MADE YESTERDAY BY-
PRESIDENT BIDEN. AS WELL AS BY
THE FED SO I THINK THIS IS
PREMATURE AND I ADVOCATE FOR A
NO VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
BROKE MEMBERS ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
AMENDMENTS. SEEING AND HEARING
NINE CENTER PAN WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE YES- FIRST OF ALL TO
MAKE NOTE THAT- THIS BILL
ACTUALLY- CONFORMS TO SOME
GUIDELINES FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WHICH ARE ACTUALLY
STILL IN EFFECT- THE OTHER
POINT I ALSO WANT TO MAKE IS
THAT. IT IS AGAIN VERY STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF- PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S- PROPOSAL- EXECUTIVE
ORDERS THAT HE MADE RECENTLY-
THIS BILL WILL ALSO ENSURE
THAT- WORKERS WHO. CHOOSE NOT
TO BE VACCINATED AND PREFERRED
TO DO THE WEEKLY TESTING THAT
THEY'RE NOT LEFT WITH THE
BURDEN. OF SIDE THE CO PAY FOR
THAT FOR THOSE PARTICULAR
TESTS- SOMETHING I KNOW MANY-
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS AND
LABORS- WOULD BE CONCERNED
ABOUT- AGAIN FUNDAMENTALLY
QUESTION IS THAT DO YOU DO. WE
WANT YOUR CONSTITUENTS. TO
AVOID GETTING TESTS BECAUSE
THERE BE BURDENED WITH THE CO
PAY. AND THEN WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE STATUS OF THEIR IT
WHETHER TO KILL THE POSITIVE OR
NOT AND THEN POTENTIALLY
SPREADING DISEASE FURTHER. THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT MEASURE
BOTH FOR PUBLIC HEALTH AND ALSO
FOR ASSURING THAT- PEOPLE GET
TESTED IF THEY'VE BEEN EXPOSED
OR IF THEY HAVE SYMPTOMS ARE
STRICTLY ASKED WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAM MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. ARCHULETA I ATKINS I FACE
NO BACKER. PORCHES BRADFORD I
KERR BIO I PROTESTING HI DOLLY
NO DOT ALL RIGHT TORONTO HI
AIKMAN GLAZER I ALL IS GROSS
NOPE HURTS BERG I WENT SO. I-
TANTO. JONES NO CAMCORDER I
LAYERED I LLEVA I THE MOON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN HI
NEWMAN. HI NIELSEN NO A
TELEPHONE NO PAM HI FORTUNE
TINO. I. ROSS I REVIEW I
SKINNER I STERN AMBERG ALL
RIGHT HI MIKE HOW SKI. I WINNER
I WILL KNOW PLEASE CALL THE
UPSET MEMBERS. ALAN I. BACKER I
FORGES EGGMAN GONZALEZ- TADO.
STERN. FIVE TWENTY SEVEN NEWS
EIGHT DECEMBER MOMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING THE FILE
ITEM EIGHTEEN SENATOR MAN BAND
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FIVE TWELVE BY SENATOR MAN
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION CENTERMAN
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT S. R.
SP FIVE TWELVE IS AMENDED IN
THE ASSEMBLY ADOPTABLE JOINING
LANGUAGE AND RELIEVE A CONFLICT
WITH A P. FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU CENTERMAN MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT NICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THESE
SUPPLEMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING THE FILE ITEM NINETEEN
SENATOR STERN SOMEONE
PRESENTING FOR SENATOR STERN.
VERY GOOD. SENATOR MCGUIRE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY THREE
BY SENATOR STERN AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTRICITY SENATOR
MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FR
THE PRESIDENT TO- HONOR TO BE
ABLE TO PRESENT ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR STERN SP FIVE THREE
THREE IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE A
LOT OF CORPORATIONS TO IDENTIFY
CIRCUITS ARE. FREQUENTLY AT
INDIA ENERGIZES SIMPLY MINUTES
SIMPLY NARROW PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL AND ADDRESS CONFLICTS
WITHIN THE BUDGET BILLS WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE
ON BEHALF OF SINISTER. THANK
YOU SENATOR REQUIRE MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE. MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING THEM FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
NO ZERO DECEMBER MOMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FAT ITEM TWENTY
SENATOR RIGHT CASKEY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FIVE SEVENTY BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI AND ACT
RELATING TO VEHICLES THE REBELS
KEY. ARMORED PERSONNEL MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS
MADE IT EXPLICITLY CLEAR THAT
THIS BILL APPLIES TO AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES EXCLUSIVELY OPERATED
BY ECONOMISTS VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY. AN IRISH AND I
THOUGHT. THANK YOU SENATOR Y.
CASKEY MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT NICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THIS SOME
LIMITS ARE CONCURRED IN PART I
ITEM TWENTY ONE THE SENATOR
GLAZER. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SIX EIGHTY
SIX BY SENATOR GLAZER AN ACT
RELATING TO THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR SENATOR RAZOR THANK YOU
MADAM PESIDENT MEMBERS. SIX
EIGHT SIX IS BACK FROM THE
ASSEMBLY FOR CONCURRENCE THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS CHANGE THE
MONETARY THRESHOLD. AT THE TIME
PERIOD DURING WHICH A PERSON
WHO'S PROVIDED A CAPITAL
CONTRIBUTION TO AN LLC. IS
REQUIRED TO BE DISCLOSED IN THE
L. L. C. STATEMENT OF. OF
NUMBERS. SECONDLY REQUIRED THE
SECRETARY OF STATE TO POST
ONLINE ALL STATEMENTS OF
MEMBERS RECEIVED. AND CLARIFY
THE PROCESS FOR A SUBMISSION OF
A QUALIFYING LLC STATEMENT OF
MEMBERS AND FINALLY REMOVED THE
CODIFICATION OF CERTAIN F. PPC
REGULATIONS RELATING TO LLCS.
ALL THE BILLS AND THE ASSEMBLY
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE MOVE THEIR OPPOSITION
THE BILL RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZER
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
HI ADKINS I FACE. BECKER I
PORCHES. BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM I PROTESTING HI DOLLY NO
DOG. FIVE TORONTO I A COMMON
GLAZER AIKENS OLIVE GROVE NO
HERTZBERG. WESSEL HI PATADA HI
JONES. CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LAVER I THE MOON. HI WIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON NO A SHOW OF BOTH. PAM I
FORTUNE TINO. I BROUGHT I
REVIEW FIVE SKINNER. I STERN
AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI. HI
WINNER I WILL. PLEASE CALL THE
UPSET MEMBERS. FAITH. PORCHES
NO. EDMUND GONZALES HERZBERG I.
JONES NO I TRIED BOTH. STERN
WELL. FIVE TWENTY EIGHT NEWS
SIX DECEMBER MOMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY THREE SENATOR ROTH
MEN OF SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHT HUNDRED BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA AN ACT
RELATING TO REAL ESTATE CETERA.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THIS
IS THE SUNSET BILL FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE IN
YOUR- REAL ESTATE APPRAISERS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE. THE BILL
MAKES VARIOUS CHANGES TO REAL
ESTATE LAW INTENDED TO IMPROVE
OVERSIGHT OF REAL ESTATE
PROFESSIONALS STEMMING FROM OUR
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY JOINT
SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT
EFFORTS. THE BILL ENSURES
LEGISLATIVE REVIEW OF THESE
PROGRAMS AGAIN IN TWO THOUSAND
AND TWENTY SIX THE SUNSET DATE
AMONG OTHER PROVISIONS ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS RESOLVE CONFLICTS
WITH OTHER MEASURES MOVING THIS
YEAR AN UPDATE REFERENCE TO THE
DEPARTMENT. OF REAL ESTATE
COLLEAGUES IT IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT
REFLECT NECESSARY DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT THE EXTREMELY HIGH FEES
THAT REAL ESTATE APPRAISERS
PAID TO THE BUREAU OF REAL
ESTATE APPRAISERS. MOVING
FORWARD I SHARE A COMMITMENT
WITH MY COUNTERPART ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW THE CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE TO
FURTHER REVIEW THESE LICENSING
FEES AS SOON AS WE ARE ABLE TO
DO SO. WITH A PARTICULAR FOCUS
ON THE APPLICATION REVIEW FEES
BUT THIS BUREAU CHARGES FUNDING
GOVERNMENT IS CERTAINLY
IMPORTANT BUT WITH A DWINDLING
POPULATION OF LICENSEES AND
RISING ADMINISTRATIVE PRO RATA
CHARGES. THE BUREAU PAYS AS
PART OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS STRUCTURE WE
NEED TO ENSURE FAIRNESS AND
REALISTIC CHARGES TO LICENSEES
AND WE INTEND TO DO SO
RESPECTFULLY AS FOR LIVE- THANK
YOU SENATOR ROBERT MEMBERS. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE I WAS THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FAT ITEM TWENTY
FOUR SENATOR DODD MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL EIGHT TWENTY BY THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION AN ACT RELATING TO
HORSE RACING CENTER DOT. I
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS AMENDMENTS WERE
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING MAJOR
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SENATOR DODD MEMBERS ANY
COMMENTS QUESTIONS CONCERNS
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING NONE
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL SEEING
AND HEARING THEN HIGHS THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS. ARE CONCURRED IN
GOING TAKE A SLIGHT PAUSE
MEMBERS.
RIVERS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE WE ARE GOING BACK
TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE I'M
TWENTY FIVE SENATOR MEN MEN
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION FIFTY TWO BY SENATOR
MAN RELATIVE TO THE HISTORY OF
BASEBALL IN ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITIES
SENTIMENTAL PRESIDENT THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES. ARRIVED TODAY TO
PRESENT SENATE RESOLUTION FIFTY
TWO WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF
BASEBALL SEASON WE'VE GOT A HOT
PENNANT RACE IN CALIFORNIA US
SENATE RESOLUTION FIFTY TWO
CELEBRATES THE HISTORY OF AND
CONTRIBUTIONS MADE BY ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITIES.
TO OUR NATIONAL PASTIME
BASEBALL. THIS WAR HAS DEEP
ROOTS IN API COMMUNITIES AND
CULTURE- BASEBALL WAS FIRST
INTRODUCED TO JAPAN AND KOREA
IN A LATE NIGHT EIGHTEEN
HUNDREDS- BY MISSIONARIES FROM
AMERICA AND IT'S SINCE GAINED
POPULARITY NOT ONLY IN THOSE
COUNTRIES BUT IN THE API
COMMUNITIES HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES. A. P. I. BASEBALL HAS
STRONG ROOTS IN CALIFORNIA AS
THE EARLIEST KNOWN MAINLAND
JAPANESE AMERICAN BASEBALL TEAM
IS A SAN FRANCISCO FUJI
ATHLETIC CLUB. FORMED IN
NINETEEN OH THREE. SEVERAL
OTHER CALIFORNIA CITIES
DEVELOPED SEMI PRO JAPANESE
AMERICAN TEAMS THROUGHOUT THE
EARLY TWENTIETH CENTURY
INCLUDING LOS ANGELES SAN DIEGO
AND FRESNO. AS SOME OF THE
GREATEST PLAYERS COACHES AND
EXECUTIVES THAT HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO THE GAME OR API
DESCENT AND THAT TREND OF
COURSE IS GROWING. LONGTIME
DODGERS ACE JUDGE ANDREW. CAME
TO MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL FROM
THE GREEN BASEBALL LEAGUE KBO
AND WAS THE FIRST PICTURE OF
KOREAN DESCENT TO EVER START A
WORLD SERIES GAME WHEN HE TOOK
THE MOUND IN GAME TWO OF THE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WORLD
SERIES. HE WENT ON TO DOMINATE
THE LEAGUE NEXT YEAR STARTING
THE ALL STAR GAME FINISHING
SECOND VOTING FOR THE NL CY
YOUNG AWARD. WHILE POSTING
BASEBALL'S BEST EARNED UN
AVERAGE. ONLY GIVE A SHOUT OUT
TO CAME IN WHO MADE HISTORY
LAST YEAR NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY AS THE FIRST WOMAN AND
FIRST ASIAN AMERICAN GENERAL
MANAGER IN MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL. DAVE ROBERTS WHO SAID
INCREDIBLE SAYS SUCCESS AS BOTH
A PLAYER AND MANAGER BECAME THE
FIRST MANAGER OF ASIAN HERITAGE
TO LEAD A TEAM LOS ANGELES
DODGERS I THINK WE HAVE A FEW
FANS HERE IN THE HOUSE. WHEN HE
TOOK IN THE WORLD SERIES IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. OF COURSE
WE KNOW EACH OTHER SUZUKI TEN
TIME ALL STAR AND GOLD GLOVE
WINNER. CONSIDERED ONE OF THE
GREAT PLAYERS OF ALL TIME.
WE'VE MADE INCREDIBLE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE GAME OF
COURSE TODAY WE HAVE SHOHEI
OHTANI SHOW TIME. OF MY
HOMETOWN LOS ANGELES ANGELS OF
ANAHEIM. WHO IS DOMINATING THE
SPORT. THE FIRST TWO WAY
STARTER IN THE HISTORY OF
BASEBALL TO BE SELECTED IN THE-
MLB ALL STAR GAME AS A TWO WAY
STARTER. WIDELY REGARDED AS THE
MOST ACCOMPLISHED TO A PLAYER
SINCE BABE RUTH- HE'S EXCITING
LEADING LEAGUE HOME RUNS RIGHT
NOW ONE OF BASEBALL'S BEST
PITCHERS. SO COLLEAGUES PLEASE
JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT API
COMMUNITY. HAS MADE TO THE
SPORT OF BASEBALL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU SENATOR MAN
SENATOR PAM. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- CENTERS I TO RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. R. FIFTY
TWO AND IS CHAIR OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS WANT TO THANK. MY GOOD
FRIEND. ADULT WHO AUTHORED THIS
RESOLUTION AS HE POINTED OUT
THERE'S A LONG HISTORY OF-
ASIAN AMERICANS IN RELATION TO
OUR ALL AMERICAN SPORTS. I
THINK IT'S A REMINDER THAT
ASIAN AMERICANS ARE AMERICANS
AND- LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
FIRST ASIAN AMERICAN SUNDAY TO
GET INTO THE- BASEBALL HALL OF
FAME IT'S BEEN OVERDUE. BUT I
SHOULD ALSO MENTION THAT
GROWING UP- WE'RE VERY WORRIED
VERY FEW OCCASIONS- PERSONALLY
TO EVER SEE SOMEONE WHO LOOKS
LIKE- MYSELF FOR MY COMMUNITY.
IN THE SPORT- THAT- TO BE ABLE
TO SEE ASIAN AMERICANS- PLAYED
BASEBALL HERE IN THIS COUNTRY.
THE CERTAINLY BEEN VERY
INSPIRING AND SO AGAIN STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS R. FIFTY
TWO THANKS. THE KEY CENTER
PANEL MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SENATOR
MAN I WILL MAKE YOU STAND UP
AGAIN UNLESS YOU'D LIKE TO. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. SORRY
BEFORE THAT SENATOR HER TADO
ALAN AS SOMEONE WHO HAD THE
GREAT HONOR AND PLEASURE TO
TAKE MY SON TO COOPERSTOWN THIS
SUMMER- I WANT TO STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION I ALSO
WANT TO CONGRATULATE THE AUTHOR
FOR HIS FANTASTIC PERFORMANCE
ON THE BASEBALL FIELD- EARLIER
THIS. THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN
MEMBER FOR MEMBERS FOR THE
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SING THEN
NOW YOU MAY CLOSE IN A MINUTE.
I RESPECT THE PROMISE OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA MONICA I
SHOULD SAY I DID LEAVE THE
FIELD TO FOR TWO BEFORE EXITING
WITH THIS INJURY- AND SO API
BASEBALL AND SOFTBALL ARE
STRONG IN THESE CHAMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SENATOR MEN MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL SEEING AND
HEARING THEN I WAS THIRTY SEVEN
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING TO FILE I'M TWENTY SIX-
S. C. R. NUMBER SIXTY SENATOR
NIELSEN MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SIXTY BY SENATOR
NIELSEN RELATIVE TO ART THERAPY
WEEK OF CIVIC ENGAGEMENT CENTER
NIELSEN DATA PRESENT LADIES
DOWN IN THE SENATE THIS WILL
RECOGNIZE OCTOBER. TENTH
THROUGH SIXTEEN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IF CALIFORNIA ART THERAPY
WEEK OF CIVIC ENGAGEMENT. ARE
THERE A P. HAS A LONG HISTORY
BEING THERAPEUTIC AND ALL KINDS
OF WAYS FORMAL AND INFORMAL.
BUT PARTICULARLY I WOULD INDEED
NOT ALL AGE. THE IMPACT OF ART
THERAPY ON CRIMINAL OFFENDERS
IN THE INSTITUTION FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE PARTICIPATED IN ART
HAS BEEN A VERY THERAPEUTIC WAY
TO REDIRECT THEIR ENERGIES AND
POSITIVE AND IN CONSTRUCTIVE
WAYS. THEY ALSO HAVE GOOD
APPLICATION THE FOUR PEOPLE WHO
WERE INVOLVED IN SERIOUS HEALTH
ISSUES WHERE THEY ENGAGE
THEMSELVES IN ART EXPRESSION
SELF THEY'RE IN IT IT'S JUST A
WONDERFUL WAY AND THIS IS
SPONSORED BY THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ART THERAPY
ASSOCIATION. AND AGAIN I WOULD
EMPHASIZE HOW IMPORTANT THIS
REALLY IS IN OUR DAILY HEALING
AND OUR DAILY ENRICHMENT OF
LIFE I WOULD ASK AND I BOTH.
THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
SEEING AND HEARING THEM I
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE I'M TWENTY
SEVEN. S. R. NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT
SENATOR PAM MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE RESOLUTION
FIFTY EIGHT BY SENATOR PAM
RELATIVE TO CONCRETE PIPE WEEK
CENTER PAM THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATORS TODAY I RISE
TO PRESENT S. R. FIFTY EIGHT
RECOGNIZING THE WEEK OF APRIL
OF AUGUST FIFTEENTH TWO AUGUST
TWENTY FIRST. AS CONCRETE PIPE
WEEK S. R. FIFTY RECOGNIZES THE
VITAL IMPORTANCE OF REINFORCED
CONCRETE PIPE AND PRECAST
PRODUCTS TO SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES IN THE HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA OFTEN OUT OF SIGHT
BUT SHOULD NOT BE OUT OF MIND
THESE RESIDENT PRODUCTS ARE
CRITICAL IN OUR STATE'S EFFORTS
TO WITHSTAND CLIMATE CHANGE
WILDFIRES. AND TO HELP MOVE-
OUR WATER AROUND OVER THE YEARS
NUMEROUS RESIDENCES VIC LEADERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA GAIN
KNOWLEDGE MEETING A PROGRESSIVE
INTEREST IN UNDERSTANDING
PORTENT OF REINFORCED CONCRETE
PIPE INDUSTRY EVERY COMMUTER
OUT CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I VOTE ON S. R.
FIFTY EIGHT FIFTY CENTER PANEL
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING THEN I THIRTY SEVEN IT
KNOWS THE MAJOR PASSES. WOULD
BE TO FIGHT HIM TO EIGHT SAID
IN BACKER MADAM SECRETARY READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION FIFTY NINE BY
SENATOR BACKER AND RELATIVE TO
RUBY BRIDGES DAY CENTER BETTER.
THANK YOU FOR CALLING TO RISE
2% S. R. FIFTY NINE TWO STEPS
NOVEMBER FOURTEENTH AS RUBY
BRIDGES WALK TO SCHOOL DAY.
THIS IS ALSO VERY INSPIRING
STORY ABOUT STUDENTS FROM MY
OWN DISTRICT. BUT FIRST ABOUT
RUBY. AT THE TENDER AGE OF SIX
RUBY BRIDGES BECAME A CIVIL
RIGHTS ICON AND PIONEER. SHE
BECAME ONE OF THE FIRST BLACK
CHILDREN TO INTEGRATE NEW
ORLEANS ALL WHITE PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM. TYPICAL AMERICAN SOUTH
AT THE TIME. RUNNING FOR A
FIRST IN CLASS WHENEVER
FOURTEENTH NINETEEN SIXTY.
WE'LL BE IN A MOTHER ESCORTED
BY U. S. MARSHALS TO PROVIDE
SAFE PASSAGE OR ALL WHITE
SCHOOL. ON THAT DAY WILL BE
INITIALLY BELIEVED TO BE A
RAMBUNCTIOUS CROWD WAITING TO
CELEBRATE WITH HER. WAS A
REALITY AN ANGRY WHITE MOB. THE
CROWD TAUNTED RUBY. HURLED
RACIAL EPITHETS BECAUSE THE
BRAVE LITTLE GIRL REPRESENTED
IDEAL THAT THE MOB FOUND
THREATENING. WE'LL BE IN HER
COURAGE REPRESENTED A SUBTLE-SHIFT TOWARDS GREATER RACIAL
EQUALITY UNDER THE LAW. IMAGES
OF RUBY'S FIRST DAY RUN BY
POLICE ENCOURAGE OUR NATION TO
RETHINK SCHOOL SEGREGATION AND
RECOGNIZE THE VALUE IN
ACHIEVING RACIAL EQUITY. NORMAN
ROCKWELL IMMORTALIZED HER
SHINING MOMENT IN HISTORY WITH
IT THE PAINTING. IN NINETEEN
SIXTY FOUR TOP OF THE PROBLEM
WE ALL LIVE WITH. THE CONCERT
MINDER TO ALL OUR CHILDREN THAT
WE CAN BE COURAGEOUS AND LIKE
RUBY WE CAN DEFY AND DEFEAT
INJUSTICE WITH DIGNITY AND
GRACE. THROUGH HER STORY
INSPIRED THE FIFTH GRADE CLASS
AT MARTIN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN
SOUTH SAN FRANCISCO IN MY
DISTRICT. TO ENGAGE WITH THE
LOCAL REPRESENTATIVES TO QUIT A
DAY TO CELEBRATE RUBY. AN
IMPORTANT CONTRIBUTION CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT. THESE ARE THE
LOCAL LEVEL THE FIRST PERSUADE
THE SCHOOL BOARD THEN THE
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION
CEMETERY OF THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TO ADOPT NOVEMBER
FOURTEENTH THIS REPURCHASE.
WALK TO SCHOOL DAY. I KNOW
THEY'RE WATCHING TODAY AS THE
STUDENTS. BUT THEY ASK US TO DO
THE SAME THE STUDENTS HAD
EXTRAORDINARY OPPORTUNITY TO
MEET. MS BRIDGES WHOSE BIRTHDAY
BY THE WAY WAS TWO DAYS AGO.
AND THEY ASK OUR STATE TO
FOLLOW SUIT. COLLINGS WOOD
BRIDGES IS A ROLE MODEL. FOR
YOUTH PARTICULARLY YOUNG GIRLS.
THE DAVID MENSAH POTENTIAL TO
BECOME LEADERS. RUBY IS A
REMINDER FOR US IN GOVERNMENT
TO ENSURE THAT EVERY CHILD
RECEIVES A QUALITY EDUCATION A
SOLID EARLY CHILDHOOD
FOUNDATION FOR SAFE PASSAGE TO
ADULTHOOD. MEMBERS JOIN ME MY
CO AUTHORS RECOGNIZE YOU RUPERT
MOVIE WHICH IS REMARKABLE
REMARKABLE LEGACY BY
PROCLAIMING NOVEMBER FOURTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. DECEMBER
FOURTEENTH THEREAFTER AS RUBY
BRIDGES WALK TO SCHOOL DAY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I START
TO ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR BAKER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE THE CENTRE BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
CHOOSE JUST ONE A RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE-
AS CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS I APPRECIATE- MY
COLLEAGE FROM THE BAY
RECOGNIZING THE TREMENDOUS
CONTRIBUTIONS SET. A SIX ZERO
MAY TWO- OUR WHOLE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT TO THE INTEGRATION OF
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND THE
COURAGE THAT SHE HAD AND WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT PROFILES IN
COURAGE I WE SHOULD KNOW THE
NAME OF RUBY BRIDGES OFTEN WE
THINK ABOUT THE COURAGEOUS-
ROSA PARKS WHO REFUSED TO GIVE
UP HER SEAT ON THE BUS BUT
BEFORE ALL OF THAT THERE WAS. A
YOUNG SIX YEAR OLD WHO WAS
BRAVE ENOUGH TO. ENTER A
HOSTILE ENVIRONMENT JUST FOR
EDUCATION. AND THE ROAD MOST
REMARKABLE THING ABOUT THIS HE
NEVER MISSED A DAY OF SCHOOL.
DESPITE THE TAUNTING AND
HARASSMENT SHE SHOWED UP EVERY
DAY FOR SCHOOL SO. AGAIN WE
REFLECT ON ALL THE TREMENDOUS
ADVANCES THAT THIS. COUNTRY HAS
MADE WHEN WE THINK ABOUT BEING
ABLE TO LIVE IN THE VARIOUS
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT WE ARE NOW
ABLE TO LIVE IN. LET'S THINK
ABOUT THE LITTLE SIX YEAR OLD
AND THAT'S ALL I TRY TO EMBRACE
A LITTLE BIT OF RUBY BRIDGES.
AND A HARD EACH AND EVERY DAY
SO I STRONGLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SAID A BRADFORD
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
THING IN HER MENTOR BROKER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE-
COMMENTS FOR MY COLLEAGUE FROM
GARDENIA AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NOT VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
BAKER MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
SORRY WE HAVE SOMEONE OFF THE
FLOOR SO ALL EYES THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO AND THE MAJOR STILL PASSES
OUR MEMBERS WE ARE NOW MOVING
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
SENATE FORTINO FOR PRIVACY
RIGHTS THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM
UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE FOUR- I
JUST WANNA MAKE A COMMENT THAT
YESTERDAY. THIS HOUSE PASSED ON
CONSENT SR FIFTY ACTION YES ARE.
FIFTY FIVE I BELIEVE IT IS HOLD
ON- OVER. S. R. FIFTY FIVE
SKEWS ME S. R. FIFTY FIVE WHICH
PROCLAIMED OCTOBER AS ITALIAN
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH AND ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF SENATOR
CORTESE AND SENATOR MELINDA AS
THE THREE ITALIAN AMERICANS IN
THE SENATE CURRENTLY I JUST
WANT TO THANK HIS BODY FOR
PASSING UNANIMOUSLY SR FIFTY
FIVE AND ALSO MENTION THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS A LONG PROUD
ITALIAN AMERICAN HERITAGE AND
CONTRIBUTIONS BOTH IN BANKING
AGRICULTURAL THE WINE INDUSTRY
IN THIS OWN SENATE CHAMBER.
SENATOR DAVID ROBERTI SERVED AS
THE SENATE PRO TEM A PRODUCT
GIANT AMERICAN AND SO ON BEHALF
OF THE THREE OF US- IT'S DOES
SENATOR CORTESE PROVIDED SOME
CANNOLI FOR EVERYONE TODAY WE
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORTING ITALIAN AMERICAN
HERITAGE AND PROCLAIMING
OCTOBER AS ITALIAN AMERICAN
HERITAGE MONTH. BECAUSE AN
IMPORTANT TINO ALSO UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR SENATOR
NIELSEN. THAT A PRESIDENT LAYS
DOWN THE CENTER OF THE
PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK YOU ALL TO JOIN ME
IN A KNOWLEDGE IN ONE OF OUR
OWN. SENATOR JOHN DUNLAP MY
PREDECESSOR IS TURNING NINETY
NINE YEARS OLD. THIS MAN HAS
HAD A FULL LIFE HE HAILS FROM A
HISTORIC NAPA VALLEY FAMILY
LONG ACTIVE IN POLITICS. HE
SERVED IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY
AND THEN IN THE STATE SENATE.
AND PROBABLY ONE OF
LANDMARK WORKS WAS THE
AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS
ACT LANDMARK LEGISLATION THAT
PASSED IN THE LATE SEVENTIES
YEAH I WOULD LIKE TO WISH
SENATOR JOHN DUNLAP HAPPY
FRUITFUL. NINETY NINTH BIRTHDAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON RIVERS
I'M GONNA ASK SENATOR DODD FOR
WHAT PURPOSE TO RISE YES IS THE
US SENATOR FROM NAPA I'D LIKE
TO JOIN THE CENTER FOR TO HIM
AND IN WISHING. A FORMER
SENATOR JOHN DUNLAP- HAPPY
BIRTHDAY HI I WAS JUST MOST
RECENTLY THAT- IT WAS ABLE TO
INTRODUCE HIM ON A- ZOOM CALL
PRESENTATION FOR THE NAPA
VALLEY HISTORICAL SOCIETY WAS
REALLY A GREAT DAY LEARNED A
LOT ABOUT- THE OLD DAYS IN THE
SENATE AND- HIS HISTORY AND
WHAT HE WAS ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH.
FIRST DISTRICT WISH HIM HAPPY
BIRTHDAY WONDERFUL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR DODD. MEMBERS
IF I CAN ASK EVERYONE TO TAKE
THEIR SEATS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO A CHURN IN MEMORIESAND
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
SENATOR WAY SO. WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY SENATOR HUESO. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT SENATORS TODAY
WERE TALKING ABOUT- THE MEMBER
OF THE SENATE FAMILY AND TODAY-
I'D LIKE TO ASK. THE US SENATE
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF THE
FATHER OF. ONE OF. THE MEMBERS
OF OUR SENATE FAMILY OF MARK MY
DISTRICT. OF MY OFFICE THE-
CHIEF OF STAFF OF MY OFFICE
ANIMAL IN RHETORIC IS LOST. HER
FATHER THIS PAST WEEK OF COURSE
HER FAMILY'S GOING THROUGH A
DIFFICULT TIME- JULY. I'VE WON
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO.
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A
WONDERFUL MAN- THE MAN THAT-
HAS WONDERFUL QUALITIES THAT
LUCKILY WERE PASSED ON TO HIS
DAUGHTER THERE IS A VERY HARD
WORKING WOMAN THAT HAS BEEN A
VERY COMMITTED TO WORKING FOR
ME AND SHE'S BEEN A WONDERFUL
MOTHER AND A WONDERFUL WIFE AND
WONDERFUL PERSON AND COURSE
YOU'VE GOT A LOT OF THOSE. ARE
TRAITS FROM HER FATHER. YOUR
FATHER WAS RAYMOND HEY MALINA.
HE WAS BORN JANUARY TWENTY
THIRD IN NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT
IN PHOENIX ARIZONA HE WAS A SON
OF A BUT I SAID- THAT MOVED
QUITE OFTEN THROUGHOUT MEXICO
AND THE UNITED STATES UNTIL
MOVING TO CALIFORNIA
PERMANENTLY. IN NINETEEN FORTY
SIX. IN NINETEEN SIXTY HE
MARRIED LET LILIA G. MOLINA. TO
WHICH HE WOULD REMAIN MARRIED
FOR SIXTY ONE YEARS. RAYMOND
MOLINA WAS A MAN OF UNWAVERING
COMMITMENT HE WAS A CONSUMMATE
FAMILY MAN THAT WAS ALWAYS
THERE FOR HIS FAMILY HE WAS A
COMMITTED WORKER. THAT RARELY
MISSED A DAY OF WORK AND WORKED
UNTIL THE AGE OF EIGHTY TWO. HE
NEVER MISSED AN ELECTION AND
REMAINED ACTIVE UNTIL HIS FINAL
DATE TO EVERYONE THAT KNEW HIM.
RAYMOND MOLINA WAS ALWAYS VERY
POSITIVE AND NEVER LOST HIS
TEMPER IN THE FACE OF DESPAIR.
HE HE WILL BE CLEARLY AND
DEARLY MISSED BY HIS COMMUNITY.
A COMMUNITY IN WHICH SHE
RESIDED AND ADVOCATED FOR FORTY
FIVE YEARS. IN THE CITY OF
NATIONAL CITY CALIFORNIA.
RAYMOND IS SURVIVED BY HIS
LOVING FAMILY HIS WIFE OF SIXTY
ONE YEARS. EARLIER G. MOLINA
AND HIS CHILDREN FREEMAN TO
FERNANDO AND ANNA LIVIA MOLINA.
HIS GRANDCHILDREN EXTENDED
FAMILY AND MANY FRIENDS. THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO ADJOURN
IN HIS MEMORY TODAY. THANK YOU
SENATOR WAY SO PLEASE BRING HIS
NAME FORWARD SO HE MAY BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BUT
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. IS
REMOVED TO SENATOR RUBIO. SEND
UP VERY GOOD THANK YOU PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS OF THIS BODY TODAY I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
THE FORMER ASSEMBLY WOMAN SALLY
TANNER A PRIMARY MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE WHO DIED
RECENTLY AT THE AGE OF NINETY
FOUR. ASSEMBLYWOMAN TANNER WAS
THE FIRST WOMAN ELECTED FROM
THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY THE
LEGISLATURE IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT SHE WAS FROM ARMANI AND
REPRESENT AT THE SIXTIETH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AT THAT TIME
WHICH COVERED PORTIONS OF MY
DISTRICT. IT IS NOT LOST ON ME
THAT I'M HERE ON THE SENATE
FLOOR BECAUSE OF HER EFFORTS
AND HER COURAGE. THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK SHE DID FOR
MY CONSTITUENTS DURING THE
FOURTEEN YEARS. WORK AND GROUND
BREAKING. HE TARGETED
GROUNDWATER CONTAMINATION. AIR
POLLUTION AND TOXIC WASTE SHE
HELPED CREATE THE STATE
SUPERFUND FOR TOXIC SUBSTANCE
CLEANUP AND AUTHORED LANDMARK
BILL REQUIRING TO THE STATE TO
IDENTIFY HAZARDOUS CHEMICAL
PESTICIDES. SHE ALSO WROTE THAT
NOW FAMOUS CALIFORNIA LEMON LAW
THAT REQUIRES AUTOMAKERS TO
REPLACE NEW CARS THAT ARE
HOPELESSLY DEFECTIVE OR GIVE
CUSTOMERS THEIR MONEY BACK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANNER WAS A
FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMAN'S CAUCUS AND
CO FOUNDER OF THE WOMAN OF THE
YEAR EVEN. ALL THE WOMEN ON
THIS FLOOR AND THE ASSEMBLY FOR
OUR EXTREMELY THING FOR
THANKFUL FOR HER LEADERSHIP.
AND LEADING THE WAY FOR ALL OF
US TO BE HERE TODAY. WE THANK
AND HONOR HER FOR HER
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE SANGRO
VALLEY MY DISTRICT FOR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THIS GREAT.
LEGISLATURE AND WE WANT TO DO
IS KEEP HER IN PRAYER AND IN
OUR HEARTS. ALL SHE WAS FROM HE
RETIRED IN. THE SENATOR'S
DISTRICT- ACQUIRE SO I'LL TURN
IT OVER FOR HIM FOR A FEW WORDS
THANK YOU. THERMOFORM THANK YOU
SO MUCH VERY GRATEFUL TO BE
ABLE TO TEAM UP WITH SIN RUBIO
ON THIS INTERNAL MEMORY I WAS
HONORED TO BE ABLE TO GET TO
KNOW A SALOON TENOR. SHE LIVES
A STORIED LIFE DIED AT AGE
NINETY FOUR GOT INTO POLITICS
MOTIVATED AS A VOLUNTEER. FOR
THE CAMPAIGN OF MR STEVENSON.
SHE HAD A HEART OF GOLD IN
AFTER SHE WAS DONE IN HER TIME
IN THE ASSEMBLY. HE MOVED TO
THE GREAT NORTH THE GREAT NORTH
COAST. SHE WAS WELL KNOWN AND
RESPECTED IN THE COMMUNITY IN
RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO FOR
WORKING WITH. BOTH PARTIES. IT
WASN'T ABOUT POLITICS IT WAS
ALWAYS ABOUT PEOPLE FROM MISS
TANNER. SHE MOVED TO FERNDALE.
AND IT HAD THE HONOR TO BE TO
WORK WITH- HER LIVING ROOM
MEMBERS HER LIVING ROOM WAS THE
HUB OF THE COMMUNITY SO MANY
SUCCESSFUL LARGE EVENTSGOT
THEIR START INNOCENTLY WOMAN
TANNER'S LIVING ROOM IN
DOWNTOWN FERNDALE. HER LIVING
ROOM WAS ALSO THE EPICENTER FOR
MANY POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS AND
ISSUES SHE WAS A MEMBER OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THROUGHOUT HER
LIFE. IN HUMBLE COUNTY GOT TO
TELL YOU HUMBLE COUNTY IS A
BETTER PLACE BECAUSE OF THIS
AND THE WOMAN TEN. SHE WAS A
TREMENDOUS PUBLIC SERVANT. BUT
SHE WAS JUST A WONDERFUL PERSON.
IT'S SUCH A KIND HEART AND SHE
WAS BELOVED BY SO MANY IN HER
ADOPTED COMMUNITY OF HUMBOLDT
COUNTY. END. YOUR JOURNEY IN
MEMORY FOR EVER REMEMBER FOR
SERVICE TO THIS GREAT STATE.
AND THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
MCGUIRE AND THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO PLEASE BRING HER NAME
FORWARD SO THAT SHE MAY BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING BACK TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THIS
WOULD BE THE APPROPRIATE TIME
TO TAKE ANY. BILLS OFF OF. OR
MOVE THEM. SENATOR CORTESE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT PLEASE
MOVE FOLLOWED IN THIRTY A. B.
THREE THIRTY FOUR MOMENT THE
INACTIVE FOLLOW THROUGH BECAUSE
THE AUTHOR THANK THE DESK ONE
OF THANK YOU SENATOR CORTESE
MEMBERS ANYONE ELSE HAVE
ANYTHING THAT THEY WOULD LIKE
TO MOVE AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A BRIEF PAUSE BUT
PLEASE DO NOT LEAVE THE RED
CARPET.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY BUT
PLEASE DO NOT LEAVE THE
BUILDING SO THAT WE CAN START
PROMPTLY AT THREE THIRTY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND WE'LL
SEE YOU IN THIRTY MINUTES.
MEMBERS WELCOME BACK. MEMBERS
WE'RE MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS I WOULD LIKE TO
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND THE SENATE RULES AND
TAKE UP THE ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
SIXTY ONE OUT OF FILE ORDER.
SEEING NO OBJECTION I AM GOING
TO GO TO SENATOR CAVALEIRO BUT
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
AN ACT RELATING TO OPEN
MEETINGS IN DECLARING THAT
URGENCY THERE AT STAKE TO BE
DEALING. THIRD CABALLERO THANK
YOU MATT MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SP THREE SIXTY
ONE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ROBERT REAVIS. THIS BILL WILL
TEMPORARILY GRANT LOCAL
AGENCIES THE FLEXIBILITY TO
MEET REMOTELY DURING GOVERNOR
DECLARED EMERGENCIES THAT MAKE
MEETING IN PERSON IMPOSSIBLE
SUCH AS WILD FIRES EARTHQUAKES
AND PANDEMICS. RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO EIGHTY THREE
SIXTY ONE WILL ALSO EXTEND
THESE TELECONFERENCING
FLEXIBILITIES TO STATE AGENCIES
FOR THE NEXT FOUR MONTHS UNTIL
JANUARY THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. TO ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY THE BILL ALSO
REQUIRES THAT THE PUBLIC BE
ABLE TO JOIN THESE REMOTE
HEARINGS EITHER VIA PHONE OR
VIDEO CONFERENCE. AB THREE
SIXTY ONE BUILDS ON AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER THE GOVERNOR
ISSUED DURING THE PANDEMIC THAT
HELP PROVIDE FOR SUCCESSFUL
DELIVERY OF GOVERNMENT SERVICES
WHEN MEETING IN PERSON WAS
IMPOSSIBLE. AB THREE SIXTY ONE
HAS ENJOYED BROAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
SENATOR CAFIERO MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
YES SENATOR BATES. OUR
PRESIDENT I BELIEVE THE ISSUE
WITH THIS PARTICULAR- MEASURE
COMPARED TO THE ONE WE HAD
YESTERDAY IS THAT THIS ONE DOES
NOT REQUIRE OFF FOLLOWING THE
OPEN ON MEETING ALL
REQUIREMENTS- BAGLEY CAME WITH
A- ANYWAY. THAT'S THE REAL
PROBLEM WITH THIS BILL SO I
WON'T BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT
OKAY. UNDER BATES MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM SEND A
COVER WHICH I'D CLOSE RESPECT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I FACE NO
BACKER. FORTUS I BRADFORD. I
COME BY OTHER HIGH COURT HAS HE-
I DALLY NO DOG. TORONTO AIKMAN
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE GROSS. NO
HERZBERG I WEAR SO I- TANTO I
JONES NO CAN A LONGER. I
LAYERED I LABOUR I THE MOON.
REQUIRE FIVE MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON. NO- TO A VOTE.
PAM HI PORT IN CHINO I ROSS I
RUBIO. I SKINNER. STERN NUMBER
I LIKE HOW SKI HI WINNER I WILL
KNOW SENATOR MOVED TO CALL
MEMBERS REMOVING THE FINAL ITEM
FIFTY TWO. ALSO SENATOR CAFIERO
MEN'S SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE TWENTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOSE THREE BASS
AN ACT RELATING TO STATE
GOVERNMENT. SENATOR BYRON THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB TWELVE
TWENTY ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOUIS REAVIS THIS BILL
IS A RESULT OF CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION ABOUT
GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT IN OUR EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS. AB TWENTY
TWENTY TWELVE TWENTY MAKES A
NUMBER OF STRUCTURAL CHANGES TO
THE CURRENT HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL ONE IT RENAMES THE
COUNSEL TO THE CALIFORNIA
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS WHICH MORE
ACCURATELY ACCURATELY
REPRESENTS THE PURPOSE OF THE
COUNCIL AND WILL SET THE STAGE
FOR THE RESTRUCTURING OF THE
COUNCIL MEMBERSHIP AND
COMMITTEES. THE COUNCIL WILL BE
CO CHAIRED BY THE SECRETARY OF
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AND THE SECRETARY OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY AND MEMBERSHIP WILL
CONSIST OF VARIOUS STATE
DIRECTORS AND SECRETARIES. THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS DEDICATED
SUBSTANTIAL FINANCIAL RESOURCES
TO COMBAT HOMELESSNESS BUT
FUNDING ALONE WILL NOT SOLVE
SYSTEMATIC ISSUES WE MUST
ENSURE THE COUNCIL IS COMPRISED
OF STATE LEADERS AND DEPARTMENT
HEADS FOR BEST EQUIPPED TO
EFFECTIVELY COORDINATE AND
CRAFT SOLUTIONS. TO
HOMELESSNESS THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU SENATOR CAFIERO
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT
KINS I BABIES I BECKER. FORTUS
BRADFORD. COME BY ADAM HI
CORTESE I DOLLY. I DON HI
TORONTO. AIKMAN GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE GROSS. I HURTS BERG
I WAS SO. HI HER TADO I JONES I
CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I LABOR
HI THE MOON MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S
I MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. I
ASSURE BOTH I CAN I PERSON TINA
I BROUGHT I REVIEW. I'D SKINNER.
STERN AMBERG HI I LIKE HOW SKI
I WINNER I WILL. HI SENATOR
SENATOR MOVES TO CALL MEMBERS
WERE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
FIFTY THREE SENATOR PORTENT
TINO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER JOHN SAWYER
AN ACT RELATING TO PEACE
OFFICERS THE REPORT TINO THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
AS A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT A B. EIGHTY
NINE THE EACE OFFICER
EDUCATION IN H. CONDITIONS FOR
EMPLOYMENT ACT. OR THE PEACE
ACT AS MEMBERS OF THIS BODY MAY
KNOW THE AUTHOR AND I BOTH
INTRODUCED A BILL TO ENHANCE
CALIFORNIA'S PEACE OFFICERS
EDUCATION STANDARDS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH ADVOCATES AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT WE CAME
TOGETHER TO INCORPORATE
ELEMENTS FROM BOTH BILLS TO
DEVELOP THIS COMPREHENSIVE.
EDUCATION BILL FIRST AB EIGHTY
NINE INCREASES THE MINIMUM WAGE
FOR INC IF YOU MEET THE MINIMUM
AGE FOR INCOMING OFFICERS FROM
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY ONE YEARS
OLD THIS ALIGNS WITH OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND ALSO
THE LEGAL AGE TO PURCHASE A
FIREARM. THE PEACE ACT ALSO
REQUIRES POST THE CSU FACULTY
MEMBERS COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT TO SERVE AS
AN ADVISORY MEMBERS FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IN DEVELOPING A FRAMEWORK FOR
MODERN POLICING DEGREE PROGRAM
THIS DEGREE WILL INCLUDE
COURSES IN PSYCHOLOGY
COMMUNICATIONS HISTORY ETHNIC
STUDIES LAW. AND THOSE IN
CRITICAL THINKING AND EMOTIONAL
INTELLIGENCE THE FRAMEWORK AIMS
TO A CLICK OFFICERS WITH SKILLS
NECESSARY FOR DE ESCALATION
WHILE ALSO GUARANTEEING THEM
THAT THEY DEVELOP A CRITICAL
UNDERSTANDING OF HISTORY OF
COMMUNITIES FROM VARIOUS
BACKGROUNDS AND CULTURES BY
PARTNERING WITH ONE OF THE BEST
TUITION FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEMS IN THE NATION. AND
REQUIRING HIGHER EDUCATION
EXPERTS TO CREATE A FINANCIAL
AID PROGRAM AIMED AT SUPPORTING
STUDENTS OF LOW INCOME AND
UNDERREPRESENTED BACKGROUNDS WE
INSURE A CAREER IN MODERN
POLICING IS ACCESSIBLE AND THAT
PEACE OFFICERS ARE REFLECTIVE
OF THE COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE.
WHEN WE IMPROVE EMPLOYMENT
STANDARDS WE STRENGTHEN
COMMUNITY TRUST IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND ENSURE PUBLIC
SAFETY ESPECIALLY FOR OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THE EXCESSIVE USE
OF FORCE. THIS BILL IS RISK THE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN RECENT
AMENDMENTS REMOVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OPPOSITION THE P.
SAC WILL INCREASE DIVERSITY
AMONGST THE RANKS AS WELL AS
PROFESSIONAL LICE POLICING BY
ENSURING A MORE MATURE AND
BETTER EDUCATED WORK FORCE
MARKING A TRANSITION AND
ADDRESSING THE ROOT CAUSES
BEHIND MANY OF THE EXCESSIVE
FORCE INCIDENCES. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER PORTENT
TINO MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI AT
KINS I FACE I BECKER. GORGEOUS
HIGH BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
CORTESE I DALLY NO DOG. HI
THERE ALSO. AIKMAN GLAZER. I
CONSOLIDATED GROSS. HI HURTS
BERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LAVER I THE MOON HI WIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MAN. NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO TROUBLE I CAN I
FORTUNE TINA I BROUGHT I REVIEW.
I SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG I
LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL HI.
IT'S CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
FACTOR. I. THERE ALSO I. AIKMAN
IN DALLAS- TADO. MEN STERN.
FIVE THIRTY TWO KNOWS THREE THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
MOVING THE FILE AND I'M FIFTY
FOUR SENATOR OTOBO AND
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN FORTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS AN ACT
RELATING TO COMMUNICATIONS.
CENTER TO ABOVE THAT IN
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I'M PLEASED
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLYMEMBR MATHIS AB
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE SIMPLY
CLARIFIES THAT THE NONPROFIT
RELIGIOUS ORGANIZATIONS ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR FUNDS WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCE SERVICES
FUND. IN LATE OCTOBER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
WITHIN CALIFORNIA HAS NEVER
BEEN MORE APPARENT AN
UNDENIABLE AND THE NEED FOR
RELIABLE IS NOT EASILY.
ACCESSIBLE INTERNET ACCESS IS
OF CRITICAL IMPORTANCE THE
BUILDINGS OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS OFTEN PROVIDE A
KEY SOURCE OF SOCIAL
INTERACTION FOR THE ELDERLY AS
THE VENUE IS USED FOR WEEKLY
SENIOR LUNCHES AND COFFEES.
FURTHERMORE THE BUILDINGS ALSO
SERVE AS THE LOCATION FOR
MULTIPLE GROUPS TO PROVIDE
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT AND IT
DICTION RECOVERY SERVICES. AB
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE WILL HELP
CLOSE THE DAY AT ST DIGITAL
DIVIDE AND PROVIDE AN AVENUE TO
INCREASE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE AND
AFTER SCHOOL BROADBAND ACCESS
TO MANY OF CALIFORNIA'S POOREST
AND MOST VULNERABLE RURAL AND
URBAN COMMUNITIES. RECENT
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS CHAPTER YG
ISSUES WITH SP ONE FIFTY SIX
PASSED EARLIER THIS YEAR. ABC
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT AND ZERO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NIGHT
OUT. THANK YOU SENATOR CHOKE
MEMBERS. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THE AND
HEARING THE MEMBER IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING AND HEARIN
NONE EYES THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
THE BOTTOM FIFTY FIVE SENATOR
COM LOCKER MEN SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TWENTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CAM
LONGER AN ACT RELATING TO
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE SERVER COME
OVER. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
I AM HERE TO RE PRESENT AB ONE
TWENTY FOUR JUSTICE FOR
SURVIVORS THIS IS A LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS PRIORITY BILL.
IF YOU WILL REMEMBER. A FEW
DAYS AGO WE ACTUALLY VOTED ON
THIS AND WE HAD TO ASK FOR
RECONSIDERATION BECAUSE OF
CHATTERING AMNDMENTS IT IS
HERE BEFORE YOU AGAIN NOTHING
HAS CHANGED IT IS A MODEST
VERSION OF ITS ORIGINAL FORM
AND WILL GIVE MANY SURVIVORS A
MECHANISM TO SEEK JUSTICE THAT
IS HOLISTIC AND REHABILITATIVE
I ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK
YOU SENATOR COM LONGER MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ADKINS I BASE NO BACKER. HI
FORGES. NO BRADFORD I COME BY
OTHER. CORTESE I DALLY NO DOG.
HI TORONTO. HI EGGMAN GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG. WHAT I FOUND. I HER
TADO. JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LABOUR HI THE MOON
HI WIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN.
FIVE NEWMAN. NIELSEN NO A SHOW
OF THE- PAN HI PERSON TINA I
BROUGHT. I RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN AMBERG. WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WINNER I WILL. NO PLEASE CALL
THE OPPOSITE MEMBERS. COME BY
OTHER I. EGGMAN GONZALES
HERTZBERG. HER TADO. NEWMAN A
CHORE VOGUE. STERN AMBERG MEAN
I DON'T KNOW MAN I DON'T KNOW.
FIVE TWENTY THREE KNOWS NINE
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE
ARE NOW GOING TO LIFT THE CALL
ON BILLS WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH FIVE AND THIRTY SIX AB
FORTY ONE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
EGGMAN WEST SO. I. FORTUNE TINO
I STERN. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING TO FOLLOWED IN
FORTY SIX EIGHTY NINE THIRTEEN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN I FORTUS. BRADFORD I. FOR
JUST I. AIKMAN GONZALEZ SO. I
CAMEL OWNER. NIELSEN I THIRD.
FIVE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING THE
ALPINE FORTY FOUR A. B. ELEVEN
OH THREE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. PORCHES. EIGHT MEN
ABOARD JUST I EGGMAN GONZALEZ.
CAN LONGER I NIELSEN I STERN
HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FELL ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB THREE SIXTY ONE PLEASE
CALL THE OFFICE AND MEMBERS.
ALAN I BACKER. I DOT. TORONTO I
AIKMAN GONZALEZ THE MON. I
ALTHOUGH. SKINNER I STERN.
TWENTY EIGHT NO SEVEN ON THE
URGENCY TWENTY EIGHT NO SEVEN
THE MEASURE PASSES ME TO FILE
ITEMFIFTY TWO AB TWELVE TWENTY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BACKER I OR JUST. HI BRADFORD I
TORONTO I EGGMAN GONZALES THE
MON. I SKINNER. I STERN. FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. YEAH THAT WAS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION PURSUANT TO
JOINT RULE THIRTY THREE POINT
ONE JOINT RULE TEN POINT FIVE
SIXTY ONE AND SIXTY TWO WILL BE
SUSPENDED TO ALLOW THE LABOR
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE TO MEET
AND REPORT AB SIX FIFTY FOUR
AFTER THE DEADLINES AND WITHOUT
FOUR DAYS NOTICE IN THE DAILY
FILE THIS REQUEST HAS BEEN
APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE. SENATOR CORTESE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT TERM.
LIVER PUBLIC POINT RETIREMENT
COMMITTEE. MEETING UP FOR THAT
PURPOSE WILL BE HELD IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE-
IMMEDIATELY- UPON THE CALLED A
RECESS THANK YOU. THANK YOU AS
SOON AS WE CALL A RECESS THOSE
OF YOU ON THE LABOR COMMITTEE
WILL GO TO ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE.
IT HURTS FOR WHAT
PURPOSE THE RICE. PRESIDENT TO
CHURN. IN THE MEMORY. OF A
MEMBER OF THIS HOUSE THE FORMER
HOUSE. BETTY CORNET WHO SERVED.
IN THE OTHER HOUSE IN NINETY
TWO NINETY FOUR. WHO SERVED
HERE FROM NINETY SIX TO TWO
THOUSAND AND FOUR. AND AGAIN TO
THE OTHER HOUSE IN TWO THOUSAND
FOUR TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT. IN
THE FUTURE THEY SHOULD BE
SITTING THERE RIGHT NEXT TO THE
CENTER FROM RIVERSIDE. THE DESK
OVER THERE AND SHE WAS SUCH A-
FAMILIAR. PRESENCE IN THE FALL
OF NINETY TWO MEMBERS. NINETEEN
NINETY TWO. A LIFE LONG MEMBER
OF THEIR PARTY IN A MATH
TEACHER FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS.
FOUND HERSELF IN A MEETING WITH
A FEW OVER FELLOW. ACTIVISTS
WANT TO RUN FOR OFFICE. NOT
ONLY DID WANT HER TO RUN IN THE
SOLIDLY DISTRICT OF PONANT. OF
THE OTHER PARTY. BUT THEY WANT
TO RUN AGAINST A FOURTEEN YEAR
INCUMBENT WOULD MOURN HIS
CAMPAIGN WAR CHESTS THAN SHE
MADE IN THE YEAR. WHEN ASKED IF
SHE WOULD RUN BY THE CARD IT
SAID IN THE TYPICAL BODY STYLE
FOR ANY OF US SOON OVER WITH
THAT KENTUCKY VOICES IS WHY
NOT. IT'S A CHALLENGE AND WILL
GIVE ME SOMETHING NEW TO DO
SOMETHING- SOMEONE OPENS THE
DOOR. WHEN YOU WALK THROUGH IT
SHE USED TO SAY ALL THE TIME.
NINE MONTHS LATER. BETTY BEAT
HER OPPONENT BUT MORE THAN
TWELVE THOUSAND VOTES AND BEGAN
A REMARKABLE FOURTEEN YEAR
CAREER HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE
IN BOTH HOUSE LEGISLATURE. THAT
WILL FOREVER SERVE AS A MASTER
CLASS IN EXCELLENCE. WITHIN
THIS IMPORTANT INSTITUTION.
BETTY WAS BORN IN PADUCAH
KENTUCKY AS MR HOMBURG WILL
TELL YOU THAT THE TAIL END OF
THE GREAT DEPRESSION. AND
ATTENDED HELP- HEALTH HIGH
SCHOOL WHERE SHE WAS CLASS
PRESIDENT OF THE GRADUATING
CLASS. OF ONLY THIRTY EIGHT
STUDENTS. HE STUDIED PRE MED
THE LOCAL JUNIOR COLLEGE WHEN
SHE RAN OUT OF MONEY SHE MOVED
TO CHICAGO AND TOOK A JOB AS A
TYPIST WHERE SHE MET HER FUTURE
HUSBAND RICHARD. AND IN
NINETEEN FIFTY TWO THEY MOVED
TO LONG BEACH. SHE WORKED AS A
SECRETARY AND TWO SHE RECEIVED
HER TEACHING CREDENTIAL FROM
CAL STATE LONG BEACH IN
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE. AND
IMMEDIATELY GOT A JOB MEMBERS
IS A TEACHER. LAUNCHING WHAT
WOULD BE A THIRTY YEAR CAREER
AS AN EDUCATOR IN LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT EARLY
IN HER TEACHING CAREER SHE
IMMERSED HERSELF IN STATE AND
LOCAL POLITICS WORKING IN
CAMPAIGNS BECOMING AN ACTIVE
MEMBER. OVER TEACHERS UNION
ULTIMATELY BEING ELECTED. TO
THE STATE COUNCIL THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO AS I
SUGGESTED SHE BROUGHT HER
POLITICAL SAVVY AND EXPERIENCED
AND EDUCATED BEER HERE IN THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE AND
EVERYONE WHO WORK WITH HER
INCLUDING MYSELF. THIRD ONE
THING. THE CARD THAT WAS
UNSTOPPABLE. ANYONE WHO KNEW
HER WELL I KNEW THAT HER
TERMINATION TO GET THINGS DONE
WAS ROOTED IN A DEEP AND
GENUINE PASSION FOR THE ISSUES
FEW AUTHORED LANDMARK
LEGISLATION IMPRESSIVE ARRAY OF
ISSUES OF HOLDING ELECTION
INTEGRITY. PROTECTING THE
RIGHTS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
VICTIMS PRESERVING ENDANGERED
SPECIES AND STRENGTHENING OUR
STATE'S TRADE AND
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND WHILE SHE WAS KNOWN FOR HER
LOVE OF EDUCATION SHE WAS ALSO
A ZEALOUS ADVOCATE. FOR
STUDENTS OF CIVIL RIGHTS. NOT
MANY KNOW THAT OUR HIGH SCHOOL
IN KENTUCKY BETTY WAS ONE OF
FOUR WHITE MEMBERS OF THE LOCAL
CHAPTER OF THE N. DOUBLE ACP.
AND ACTUALLY WENT ON TO WRITE
HER MASTER'S THESIS ON THE
HISTORY OF EDUCATION FOR
AFRICAN AMERICANS BEFORE THE
CIVIL WAR. BEIJING NATIONALLY
IN DETERMINATION TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS WITH MATCHED. ONLY BY
HER DISARMING AND GREGARIOUS
PERSONALITY SHE WAS NEVER SHY
LOOKED ABOUT LOOKING SOMEONE
STRAIGHT IN THE EYE. AND SAYING
EXACTLY WHAT WAS ON HER MIND
LIKE IT OR NOT. BUT IT WAS THIS
CANDID PORTRAIT MRS FOLKSY
ENTHUSIASM FOR THE JOB THAT
MADE HER SUCH A FORCE IN THIS
LEGISLATURE. HE WAS A
TRAILBLAZER FIERCE ADVOCATE A
BRILLIANT EDUCATOR BUT MORE
THAN ANYTHING BUT HE WAS A DEAR
FRIEND. AND MENTOR SOMEONE
WHOSE TRUST VICE I COULD ALWAYS
COUNT ON MY SERVICE HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE SHE WILL
UNDOUBTEDLY BE MISSED BY SO
MANY FRIENDS AND SO MANY WHO
DON'T EVEN KNOW HER NAME. WE
ALL ARE USED TO THE CAR NET
RULE WHICH IS HOW WE BEST
THINGS THAT WAS BETTY'S LAW WE
CALL THAT THE CORNET ROOM THE
OLD DAYS AND- IN THE NEW DAYS
THEY CALLED PROTESTING. AS WE
ALL HAVE TO DO THAT IS ONE OF
OUR MANY MANY ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
THE GREAT CREDIT CARD THAT IS
SURVIVED BY HER DAUGHTER MARY.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
THIS SENATE. TURN IN THE MEMORY.
OF ONE OF OUR OWN. THANK YOU
MET A PERSON THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG PLEASE BE SURE TO
BRING HER NAME FORWARD SO SHE
MAY BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED AT
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
FORGIVE ME SENATOR AMBER I
DIDN'T SEE YOUR MIKE UP PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU. AS IN
COLLEAGUES YOU CAN'T SEE MY
FACE BECAUSE WE'VE GOT MASKS
ON. BUT THE NAME BETTY CARD
THAT JUST MAKES ME SMILE IN
THIS PHOTO COLLAGE IN FRONT
REALLY CAPTURES BETTY I SERVE
WITH BETTY WHEN SHE WAS ELECTED
IN THE EARLY NINETEEN NINETIES
AND THEN AGAIN IN THE MID TWO
THOUSANDS. AND BETTY AS SOME
OUR OUR GOOD FRIEND FROM LOS
ANGELES POINTED OUT COULD BE
EXTREMELY DISARMING AN
EXTREMELY EXTREMELY JOVIAL- BUT
THAT WAS A VENEER THAT COVERED-
A BACKBONE OF STEEL CHOOSE A
TEACHER SHE WAS A TEACHER AT
HEART. AND WE WERE ALL HER
STUDENTS AND SHE WAS THE-
REALLY THE DEN MOTHER OF THE
ASSEMBLY WHEN I WAS THERE. SHE
WHAT IS THE ESSENCE OF LONG
BEACH SHE LOVES LONG BEACH SHE
LOVED HER COMMUNITY SHE LOVED
BEING AN EDUCATOR SHE LOVED
EDUCATING ALL OF US. JUDY
MULLER LIFE TO PUBLIC SERVICE
SHOULD WILDER LIFE HER HUSBAND
DICK AND SHE DEVOTED HER LIFE
TO HER DAUGHTER MARY WHO
SURVIVES HER AND SHE WOULD
LIGHT UP WHEN SHE WOULD TALK
ABOUT MERRY. SHE ABSOLUTELY
EVOKE THIS INCREDIBLE SENSE OF
OPTIMISM SHE WILL BE MISSED I
AM SO GRATEFUL THAT I HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE WITH BETTY.
AND BECOME HER FRIEND- MAY SHE
REST IN PEACE GOD LOVE YOU
BUDDY. THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG
CENTER LAYERED- THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I WOULD LIKE TO JOIN
INDIA GERMS AS WELL AND IT'S
HARD TO TOP THE TWO STATEMENTS
THAT ARE MADE BUT- WHEN BETTY
LOST THE SEAT IN THE ASSEMBLY
BEFORE SHE WAS ELECTED. TO THE
SENATE SHE WAS APPOINTED CHAIR
OF A PARTY COMMITTEE AND I WAS
HER CULTURE AND IT WAS ON
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZING WHICH WAS
REALLY HER EXPERTISE SAID IT
WAS A TIME WHERE THERE WAS A
REAL DOWNTURN I MEAN OTHER
PEOPLE LOST THEIR SEATS AND SHE
WAS DETERMINED TO PUT ALL THE
EFFORT. AND IN PARTICULAR WITH
HER FELLOW TEACHERS IN
ORGANIZING ACROSS THE STATE TO
MAKE SURE THOSE ISSUE SHOWED UP
IN ELECTIONS AND SHOWED UP IN
PEOPLE WINNING AND THEN YOU GO
FORWARD ABOUT TWELVE OR
FOURTEEN YEARS AND SHE AND I
SERVED TOGETHER IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY. AND I WAS BUDGET
CHAIR AND I CANNOT DO JUSTICE I
DIDN'T HEAR IT IN IN THE OTHER
TWO I CANNOT DO JUSTICE TO HER
ACCENT UP- SHE SOUNDED LIKE SHE
WALKED OUT OF KENTUCKY THE DAY
BEFORE SHE MET YOU. SHE WOULD
CALM AND JUST SAY AS WE WERE
DOING THE BUDGET ARE WE GOOD IN
EDUCATION ARE WE GOOD FOR THE
TEACHERS I'M JUST CHECKING DO I
HAVE TO WORK. HARD CAUSE A
SCENE AND THAT WAS JUST WHERE
ART WAS AND WE'RE AFTER WAS IT
IT WAS WHY SHE WAS SUCH A GOOD
PUBLIC SERVANT AND I JOINED. IN
AND TURNING IN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU CENTER LAYER CENTER
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I DO JUST WANT TO SAY
I HAD MY VOICE TO ALL THAT'S
BEEN SAID ABOUT. THE CAR NET
WHO'S AN AMAZING PUBLIC SERVANT
AND THAT'S THE WAY I WOULD
DESCRIBE HER- SHE WAS GENUINE
SHE WAS CRYING. SHE WAS ALL
THOSE THINGS THAT- OKAY SIR MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE- STATED ALREADY
AND- AS YOU LOOK AT THE FACE IT
WAS AS WARM AND GENUINE. AND
SHE TOOK ME UNDER HER WINGS
BEFORE I. GOT TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND ENCOURAGE ME TO
BE INVOLVED IN THE COMMUNITY
AND THAT'S WHAT PUBLIC SERVICE
IS REALLY ALL ABOUT BEING
INVOLVED IN JUST BEING ENGAGED
AND SO. I WANT TO THANK HER FOR
HER MENTORSHIP FOR FRIENDSHIP
AND HER ENCOURAGEMENT- AND HER
ENDORSEMENT WHEN I RAN IN OH
NINE AND- SO I APPRECIATE. ALL
THAT SHE MEANT NOT ONLY TO THIS
INSTITUTION BUT TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND TO. ALL THE
YOUNG FOLKS WHO SHE IMPACTED
THEIRLIVES AS AN EDUCATOR AS A
FRIEND AS A MENTOR SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD. ANY
FURTHER ADJOURNS. YOU CAN TAKE
A SMALL BREAK MEMBERS. STAY
WHERE YOU ARE STAY TUNED.
MEMBERS THAT WAS A GREAT
PICTURE DO NOT LEAVE THE RED
CARPET PLEASE.
MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP ASSEMBLY ITEMS
FORTY EIGHT AND.
FIFTY SIX.
MEMBERS ARE GONNA START UP
AGAIN. THE MOVING TO ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE. WELL ITEM
NUMBER FORTY EIGHT SENATOR
LEYVA THANK YOU MATTER DOES
ADAM MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SIXTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAY AS
AN ACT RELATING TO PEOPLE
INSTRUCTION. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS TODAY I
PRESENT TO YOU A B. FOR SIXTY
NINE WHICH REQUIRES LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES ELEAZAR TO
ENSURE ALL HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS
COMPLETE THE FAST FOUR OR THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT
APPLICATION FOR FINANCIAL AID
BEFORE GRADUATING THIS BILL
ALIGNS WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND ADDS TO CLEAN UP
PROVISIONS INCLUDING DATA
SHARING LANGUAGE AND A
DEFINITION FOR THE TYPES OF
NONPROFITS QUALIFIED TO ASSIST
WITH APPLICATIONS. IN ORDER TO
ENSURE EFFETIVE IMPLEMENTATION
MEMBERS ARE STRICTLY OUT FOR AN
IPHONE IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
DRAWS A- YES I DO OUR RIGHTS ON
BEHALF OF THE LATINO CAUCUS AS
A PRIORITY BILL. AND AGAIN FOR
ALL THE REASONS THAT WERE JUST
A PUT FORWARD TO US IT'S A VERY
VERY IMPORTANT- TO BE ABLE TO
OFFER THESE OPPORTUNITIES TO
OUR YOUNG. ADULTS SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SINGMAN
CENTER LATER YOU MAY CONCLUDE.
A RESPECTFUL ENOUGH FRONT I'VE
OPEN ANY OF YOU WHO HAVE KIDS
IN COLLEGE YOU KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT THE FAST FOR IT IS
YOU CAN GET NO FINANCIAL AID
UNLESS THAT'S FILLED OUT AND
SOME PARENTS JUST DON'T KNOW
ABOUT IT SO BY HAVING IT IN
HIGH SCHOOL IT'LL REALLY HELP
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS RESPECT
FAILS FOR NINE. MEMBERS THIS
ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USE IT UTILIZING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
NONE. I THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS
WERE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
FIFTY SIX. AND THAT IS FENDER
DALI WHO IS PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE SIXTEEN BY A FAMILY
MEMBER DALLY AN ACT RELATING TO
PEOPLE AND TENDONS SENATOR DOLE
IN. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT-
A RISE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYWOMAN DALLY TO PRESENT
AV FIVE SIXTEEN A STRAIGHT FOR
A BILL THAT ALL WILL ALLOW K.
TWELVE STUDENTS TO BE EXCUSED
FROM SCHOOL. WHEN THEIR ABSENCE
OUR PARTICIPATION IN CULTURAL
CEREMONIES THIS BILL WAS ON
CONSENT BUT PULLED. AN AMENDED
FOR ADJUSTING CHAPTER YES USE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR HOLLINGS
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CENTER HERZBERG. YEAH I
JUST WANT TO QUESTION THE
AUTHOR. CENTER DOLLAR WE TAKE A
QUESTION ABSOLUTELY PLEASE
PROCEED YEAH I JUST WANTED TO
ASK HIM IF HE HAD HADN'T HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR OF
THIS MEASURE TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND IT'S IMPORTANT
PURPOSE. IS GONE TO THE VARIOUS
CROSS REFERENCES IN THE CODE
SECTIONS- IF YOU CAN INFORM US
THAT APPRECIATE THAT. HUNDRED
DOLLAR ABSOLUTELY IT CAME TO
US- FROM ONE OF OUR SCHOOLS IN
THE DISTRICT. AND THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN WAS VERY ENGAGED WITH THE
PROCESS AND- STUDENTS WHO- WHEN
I GO OUT AND DO THEIR
CEREMONIAL- CULTURES WITH THEIR
ELDERS- WE'RE NOT EXCUSE FROM
SCHOOL AND THAT'S THE REASON
FOR THIS BILL. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION. THANK YOU SENATOR
ALI MEMBERS FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING AND HEARING
THEM HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES.
ALL RIGHT
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE WILL BE
IN RECESS UNTIL SIX PM IN ORDER
TO ALLOW ALL OF THE LABOR
COMMITTEE TO MEET THEY'LL BE
MEETING IN THIRTY ONE AND
NINETY ONE. DINNER WILL BE
READY AT FIVE O'CLOCK WHICH IS
ACTUALLY RIGHT NOW AND WE WILL
BE BACK AT SIX O'CLOCK OR WE
WILL TAKE A. STAND BY. NOBODY
LEAVES PLEASE ONE MOMENT.
MEMBERS BEAR WITH US FOR JUST A
MINUTE PLEASE.
MEMBERS I DO
APOLOGIZE I AM ONLY AS GOOD AS
THE INFORMATION THAT'S GIVEN TO
ME WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO TAKE
UP FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN
SENATOR MAN. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
HUNDRED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAY
AS AN ACT RELATING TO TRUSTS
CINNAMON. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- AB NINE HUNDRED
SIMPLY FIXES INCONSISTENCY IN
CURRENT LAW. ENSURING THE
TRUSTEES ARE ACTING IN GOOD
FAITH. UNDER EXISTINGLAWS
NONPROFIT PUBLIC BENEFIT
CORPORATIONS ARE REQUIRED TO
GIVE WRITTEN NOTICE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL. IN THE
CORPORATION INTENDS TO MOVE
SUBSTANTIALLY ALL OF ITS
ASSETS. HOWEVER DUE TO AN
EXISTING INCONSISTENCY WITHIN
CALIFORNIA LAW CHARITABLE
TRUSTS HAVE BEEN ALLOWED TO
CIRCUMNAVIGATE THIS SIMPLE
NOTICE. THAT ALL OTHER
NONPROFIT CORPORATIONS ARE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE. RECENT
AMENDMENTS AT A DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION AND REMOVE ALL
OPPOSITION SO THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION IS BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A- THANK YOU SENATOR MEN
MEMBERS. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI ADKINS.
EIGHT BACKER. I PORCHES. NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T HI
CORTEZ HE. DALLY NO DOT I
TORONTO HI EGGMAN LASER I
CONSOLIDATED GROSS. NO HERZBERG
I WENT SO. WEST SO. HI HER TADO
HI JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I. LEIVA. HI THE MON HI
WIRE. I BELINDA NO MAN I NEWMAN
I NIELSEN. I TRIED BOTH. NO CAN
I FORTUNE TINO. HI RON I REVIEW
I SKINNER I STERN AMBERG I LIKE
HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL. NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AT KINS BATES NO CORTEZ V. I.
EGGMAN GONZALEZ NIELSEN. STERN.
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN NEWS EIGHT
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE
ARE NOW GOING TO BREAK FOR
DINNER SO THAT THE LABOR
COMMITTEE CAN MEET PLEASE BE
BACK HERE AT SIX PM THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
MEMBERS I
THANK YOU GREATLY FOR YOUR
PATIENCE WE'RE GOING BACK TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS WE'RE SORRY
WITH FILE ITEM SIXTY THREE
SENATOR WIENER. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
SEVENTY THREE BY SENATOR WIENER
AN ACT RELATING TO PROBATION
SENATOR WIENER I THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
BECAUSE SP SEVENTY THREE IS
BACK FROM THE ASSEMBLY ON
CONCURRENCE AS YOU RECALL THE
SIMPLY PROVIDES COURTS WITH HIS
JUDICIAL DISCRETION TO SENTENCE
SOMEONE TO PROBATION FOR
NONVIOLENT DRUG OFFENSES ON A
CASE BY CASE BASIS A COURT WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE DISCRETION TO.
SEND SOMEONE TO JAIL UT WILL
NO LONGER BE MANDATED TO DO SO-
IN THE- AMENDMENTS AND HIS
FAMILY WERE MINORAND TECHNICAL
IN NATURE AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
THEM MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
ATKINS. FATE NO BACKER. I
PORCHES NO BRADFORD I HAVE A I
PROTESTING I DALLY. NO DOG I
DRAW SO I EXAMINE GLAZER. I
CONSOLIDATE GROWTH NO HERTZBERG
I WENT SO. HI HER TADO. JONES
NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LABOR
HI THE MOON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MAN. NEWMAN
NIELSEN. A CHARTER BOAT NO PAN
HI PERSONS YOU KNOW. I BROUGHT
I REVIEW. SKINNER HI STERN I'M
BERG. CASKEY I WINNER FIVE WELL
LOOK NO. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ARCHULETA ATKINS.
EGGMAN GONZALES HER TADO NO.
MAN NEWMAN NIELSEN. RUBIO I
STERN I'M VERY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ARCHULETA AT
KINS. I COMMEND GONZALEZ MAN NO.
NEWMAN NIELSEN NO STERN ON
BERGEN. AMBERG NOW BUYS TWENTY
TWO KNOWS TWELVE DECEMBER
MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN MOVING
THE FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR
SENATOR ROTH MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SIX
SIXTY SEVEN BY SENATOR ROTH AN
ACT RELATING TO TAXATION
ETCETERA. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT THE BILL BACK ON
CONCURRENCE CLARIFIES WHO IS
AUTHORIZED TO FILE A DISABLED
VETERANS PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION
ON BEHALF OF AN ELIGIBLE
VETERAN. FOR HIS HER OR THEIR
SURVIVING SPOUSE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
TRUSTEES AND PERSONAL LEGAL
REPRESENTATIVES TO THE LIST OF
AUTHORISED ROLLS RESPECTFULLY
AS YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU
SENATOR ROTH MEMBERS DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THESE SUPPLEMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. PART I ITEM SIXTY FIVE
SENATOR LA MON. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL SEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN BY SENATOR LAMONT
AN ACT RELATING TO STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID CENTER LEVEL.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SB
SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN IS BACK ON
CONCURRENT FISCAL UPDATE THE
GOVERNING STATUTE OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE OPPORTUNE
ACCESS PROGRAMKNOWN AS COUNSEL
TO BOTH REFLECT THE POST
SECONDARY AXIS NEEDS OF TODAY'S
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS CAN'T
ALIGN EXISTING BEST PRACTICES.
AT EACH OF THE KELSO PROJECTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU CEREMONY MEMBERS DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING
THEN MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
I. ATKINS I BAIT NO BACKER. I
PORCHES. NO BRADFORD I HAVE MY
OTHER EYE PROTESTING I. DALI NO
DOT. I THE RUSSELL I EGGMAN
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE GROSS NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO
HI JONES NO CAN LONGER. LAYERED
HI LABOUR I THE MOON I REQUIRE
I MELINDA'S NO MAN. I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF BOTH HI
PAM I PORTS AND YOU KNOW I ROTH
I REVERE FIVE SKINNER. I STERN
NUMBER I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER
I WILL. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. EGGMAN GONZALEZ
CAMCORDER I STERN WELL. FIVE
TWENTY NINE ASSEMBLY NO SEVEN
THE SETTLEMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FALLON I'M SIXTY SIX SENATOR
CORTESE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN NINETY
ONE BY SENATOR CORTEZ HE AN ACT
RELATING TO LAND USE CENTER
COURT. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND SENATORS SO TODAY I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT S. P. SEVEN
NINETY ONE FOR CONCURRENCE.
THIS IS A BILL THAT CREATES A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE UNIT
WITHIN EIGHT C. D. THAT WILL
FACILITATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT ON LOCAL SURPLUS
LAND. BY PROVIDING VOLUNTARY
TECHNICAL AND FINANCIAL
pASSISTANCE TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THE ASSEMBLY MOMENTS NEAR THE
POWERS OF THE UNIT REMOVED ALL
OPPOSITION FROM THE BILL. THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU CENTER CORTESE
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA. I ADKINS. I
HATE. BACKER I PORCHES.
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
CORTEZ C. I. DALI. DOT HI THERE
ALSO HI ADNAN GLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES GROVE. HERTZBERG I
WAS SO HI HER TADO I JONES. CAN
LONGER I LAYERED I LAVER I THE
MOON I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN
I NEWMAN I NELSON. A SHOW OF
BOTH I CAN HI PERSON TINA. I
ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN
I WILL HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BASE PORCHES.
DALLY EKMAN. GONZALES GROWTH.
JONES I. MELINDA'S NIELSEN
STERN. FIVE THIRTY ONE NO ZERO
THE ASSEMBLY MOMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN BY LINE AND SIXTY
SEVEN SENATOR ROTH AND
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL EIGHT OH TWO BY SENATOR
ROTH AN ACT RELATING TO PRIVATE
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE SEND RAW THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THIS IS THE
SUNSET BILL FOR THE BUREAU FOR
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION. THE BILL CONTINUES
THE ACT AND BUREAU OPERATIONS
FOR ONE YEAR SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE WORKING ON ISSUES
RELATED TO THE BUREAU'S
SOLVENCY AND FUNDING MECHANISMS
REGULATION OF SPECIALTY
PROGRAMS ENHANCED OVERSIGHT ON
THE FRONT END OF THE LICENSURE
PROCESS. ANALYST OF OTHER
TOPICS PLEASE VOTE I. THANK YOU
SENATOR ROTH MEMBERS DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE EYES THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FINE I'M SIXTY
EIGHT SENATOR ROTH AND
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL EIGHT OH SIX FIVE SENATOR
ROTH AN ACT RELATING TO HEALING
ARTS. THANK YOU- MADAM
PRESIDENT THIS MAY BE THE LAST
TIME HERE FOR ME THIS IS THE
SUNSET BILL FOR THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA OSTEOPATHIC
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA THE
PODIA ETTRICK MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THE PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANT BOARD THE PROGRAM'S
ALL EXPIRE ON JANUARY ONE TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO THIS
MEASURE IS NECESSARY TO
CONTINUE THE EXIT THE BOARD'S
EXISTENCE WHILE ENSURING
PATIENTS AND THE PUBLIC ARE
PROTECTED AND THE CRITICAL
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS ARE
LICENSED. RESPECTFULLY AS RIVAL
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI I. ARCHULETA I ADKINS I
FACE I BECKER I PORCHES HI
BRADFORD I HAVE I DON'T I
PROTESTING I DOLLY. GOD I DRAW
SO I EXAMINE. GLAZER ARKANSAS
AS GROWTH. HERTZBERG I WAS SO
HYPER TANTO I JONES. I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED. I LABOUR HI
THE MOON I REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S.
MISS MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN
I NIELSEN. I WOULD SHOW UP BOTH.
PAN I PRESENT YOU KNOW I
BROUGHT. I RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN AMBERG HI MIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL. PLEASE CALL THE
UPSET MEMBERS. WELL NOW. TALLY
NO. ADMIN GONZALEZ GROVE. THE
TROUBLE. STERN. FIVE THIRTY TWO
THOSE THREE DECEMBER AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE I'M SIXTY
NINE SENATOR SKINNER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE FIFTY FOUR BY
SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT RELATING
TO PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES
SANDERS CAN- THANK YOU- MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SP THREE
FIFTY FOUR BACK IN CONCURRENCE.
HELPS US ENSURE THAT OUR
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE CAN BE
PLACED WITH A RELATIVE WHERE
THAT IS AN APPROPRIATE
PLACEMENT THE BILL AS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN BOTH
HOUSES IT- WE DID SOME
AMENDMENTS THAT- CONFORMS
CHANGES TO FEDERAL FUNDING
REQUIREMENTS. AND CLARIFIED
THAT THE BILLS BILL PRIDE PLIES
TO TRIBALLY APPROVED HOMES
WITHOUT I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY. OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
OKAY
SEEING NO OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL HIGHS
THIRTY SIX. THE FOLLOWING.
THIRTY SEVEN FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
NO ZERO DECEMBER AMENDMENTS ARE
INCURRED IN ITS HELPFUL WHEN
YOU STAY ON THE FLOOR MEMBERS
FIND ITEM SEVENTY SENATOR
WIENER MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR WIENER AN ACT
RELATING TO CRIMES SENATOR
WIENER. I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES SP THREE
FIFTY SEVEN IS BACK FROM THE
ASSEMBLY ON CONCURRENCE THIS
BILL REPEALS. THE CRIME OF
LOITERING WITH INTENT TO ENGAGE
IN SEX WORK- AMENDMENTS TAKEN
AND IF SOMEBODY OR CLARIFYING
IN NATURE AND ADDRESS CHAPTER
IN COMPLEX. SP THREE FIFTY
SEVEN SIMPLY ELIMINATES AN
OVERLY BROAD OFFENSE- STATUS
BASED PROFILING OFFENSE THE
RESULTS IN THE LEGAL PROFILING
OF LGBTQ BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
AND PERMITS THERE REST OF THE
WAY THEY LOOK AND THE WAY THEY
DRESS IT'S NOT CONSISTENT WITH
CALIFORNIA VALUES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPO.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
C. AND HEARING. HAVE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I HATE NO
BACKER I FORGES NO BRADFORD. I
COME BY OTHER HYPERTENSIVE. I
DALLY NO DOG HI TORONTO HI
EGGMAN GLAZER ICONS ALL AS
GROWTH NO HERTZBERG. WEST SO HI
HER TADO. HI JONES NO CAN
LONGER I LAYERED I LLEVA HI THE
MOON HI WIRE HI MELINDA'S NO
MAN I NEWMAN. HI HI NIELSEN. NO
A SHOW OF BOTH NO CAN I FORTUNE
TINO HI RALPH ALL RIGHT RUBIO.
HI SKINNER. FIVE STERNE AMBERG.
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WINNER I WILL
KNOW. PLEASE HOLD IF THE
MEMBERS EKMAN IS ALL THIS
HERTZBERG. STERN AMBERG. FIVE
TWENTY SIX KNOWS NINE DECEMBER
MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN PART I
ITEM SEVENTY ONE SENATOR
PORTENT TINO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL READ. SENATE BILL
SEVEN FIFTEEN BY SENATOR
FORTINO AN ACT RELATING TO
CRIMINAL LAW CENTER FORTINO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SP SEVEN FIFTEEN IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE WITH
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN- WHEN
I USED THAT ADDRESS TECHNICAL
CLEAN UP WITH PROVISIONS FOR
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION THEY
ALSO REMOVE A SECTION OF THE
BILL AND GIFTING SUGGEST THEN
SUGGESTED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. AND THE FBI LASTLY
THEY ADDRESS TRAPPING OUT
ISSUES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER FLORENTINO MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I
HATE NO BACKER. ALL RIGHT
FORGES NO BRADFORD I HAVE A I
DON'T. CORTESE I DALLY NO DONT
I TORONTO HI ADNAN GLAZER ICONS
ALL THIS GROWTH NO HERZBERG I
WAS SO. I HER TADO. JONES NO
CAN LONGER. I LAYERED HI LABOUR
HI THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON. NO CHOKO NO CAN I
FORTINO FIVE ROSS I REVIEW I
SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG HI I
LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL
KNOW. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. COME BY OTHER. EGGMAN
GONZALEZ HER TADO. STERN. FIVE
TWENTY SIX NEWS NINE THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FALLON SENT
SEVENTY TWO SENATOR RUBIO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL EIGHT OH FIVE BY SENATOR
RUBIO AN ACT RELATING TO STATE
GOVERNMENT CENTER ROOM. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE I RISE
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL EIGHT OH
FIVE WHICH IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
DELETED SECTION FOUR OF THE
BILL TO ADDRESS FUNDING. ISSUES
RAISED AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY HAS REMOVED ALL
OPPOSITION. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I BOTH THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR RUBIO MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
FACE. BACKER I PORCHES NO
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM I
PROTESTING I DALLY. GODI
TORONTO HI EGGMAN LASER I
CONSOLIDATE GROWTH. HERTZBERG I
WEAR SO HI HER TADO I JONES NO
CAN LONGER. I LAYERED HI LABOUR
I THE MOON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S. I MEN HI NEWMAN I
NELSON I A SHOW OF BOTH. NO PAN
HI FORTUNE TINO I BROUGHT I
RUBIO. I SCANNER. I TURNED
AMBER HI HI FI CASKEY I WINNER.
I WILL NO PLEASE CALL THE
OFFICE AND MEMBERS. THE BASE NO.
DALLY EGGMAN GONZALEZ GROVE NO.
STERN EYES THIRTY NO SIXTIES
AND WOMEN'S ARE CONCURRED IN
PART I ITEM SEVENTY THREE
SENATOR MCGUIRE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL EIGHT
TWENTY FIVE BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE AN ACT RELATING TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FINANCE.
SENATOR MCGUIRE GOOD EVENING
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS- IT S.
T. TWENTY FIVE IS THIS IN
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE ON THIS BILL WHICH
COMBINES SEVERAL LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSALS INTO ONE MEASURE TO
HELP. TAX ADMINISTRATION.
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT THE BILL
CONTAINS NON CONTROVERSIAL
CHANGES IN TAX SUGGESTED BY THE
STATE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION-
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION KIND
TREASURERS AND TAX COLLECTORS
HAS NO OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I DON'T. THINK HE
SENT A REQUIREMENT OR
SUBSCRIPTION OR DEBATE SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING THEN FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
KNOWS ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY FOUR SENATOR
MCGUIRE MAN'S SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL EIGHTY BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AN ACT RELATING
TO COMMERCIAL FISH FISHING AND
ACQUIRING THE URGENCY THERE OF
CIGNA TO MEDIUM LENGTH THE
NUMBER THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT WRITES A PRISON SP
EIGHTY EIGHT SENIOR JOINT
COMMITTEE ON FISHERIES AND
AQUACULTURE. OMNIBUS BILLS THE
ONE THAT YOU'VE ALL BEEN
WAITING FOR ALL EVENING- AND
THEN MISTAKEN THESE SIMPLY
AUTHORIZE THE COPPER DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO COLLECT
MODESTY ON FISH PROCESSORS TO
COVER THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
REVIEWING AND APPROVING THIS
SERRATION PLANTS. THAT'S RIGHT
SUBMITTED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
PROCESSORS PROCESS OF REVIEW
THE CINNAMON SIGNED OFF ON IT
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED NO. NO
VOTES WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN ITEM. THE YOU SENATOR
REQUIRE. MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE. CENTER MORICHES. AND
PRESIDENT IT IS THE ONE TO POSE
A QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR SO IN
ORDER WE TAKE A LOOK. PLEASE
PROCEED THE MODESTY OF THREE
FIFTY IS THAT CORRECT YES SIR
THREE FIFTY DOLLARS IS THAT
MODEST. BUT IN THE BIG SCHEME
OF THINGS YES IT IS OKAY YES
YEAH I HEAR YOU'RE SAYING.
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU
SENATOR BOARD JUST ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE. SENATOR
MCGUIRE WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPHONE THANK YOU SIR MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN
NEWS ZERO THE MISS SOME
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
INFECTIOUS. HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN
TO ZERO URGENT ON THE URGENCY
FIVE THREE SEVEN NINE ZERO AND
TE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED AND FILE ITEM SEVENTY
FIVE SENATOR REQUIRE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL NINETY EIGHT BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC SAFETY. CENTER BEFORE
THANK YOU SO MUCH AMANDA
PRESIDENT SP NINETY EIGHT IS
THE FREEDOM OF THE PRESS ACT
WHICH WILL ENSURE THE
JOURNALISTS ARE PROTECTED AS
THEY TEN DEMONSTRATIONS MARCHES
PROTESTS AND RALLIES. LONG
STORY SHORT AN IMAGE TAKEN IN
THE SIMPLY CLARIFY LANGUAGE AT
REGARDING ACCESS RELATED TO
COMMAND POST TO FULLY ALIGN THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL WITH
EXISTING LAW WHERE THERE IS NO
UNFETTERED ACCESS TO COMMAND
POST TODAY. IN ADDITION IT
CLARIFIES THAT PROTECTION FROM
ARREST UNDER PENAL CODE ONE
FORTY EIGHT WILL ONLY APPLY TO
MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA WHEN
THEY'RE GATHERING RECEIVING OR
PROCESSING INFORMATION THIS.
BILL COMES BACK TO US WITHIN
MINUTES ALSO THAT CLARIFIES
THAT THE BILL SHOULD NOT BE A
BASIS FOR CRIMINAL LIABILITY.
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
I DON'T. THANK YOU SENATOR MIKE.
MEMBERS TO. OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE CENTER
GORGEOUS. SORRY ANOTHER
QUESTION FOR THE OFFICE PLEASE
SEND REQUIRE WE TAKE A QUESTION
YES HIM THINKING THIS WOULD BE
THE AMENDMENT HERE'S THAT. THE
ASSEMBLY DELETED LANGUAGE
REQUIRING THE NEWS ENTITIES
RECEIVE AUTHORIZATION FROM A
COMMANDING OFFICER ON SCENE
BEFORE ENTERING CLOSED AREAS. I
GUESS MY QUESTION TO YOU WOULD
BE. DID WE FINE TUNE THE
DEFINITION OF THOSE THAT ARE IN
THE MEDIA. I THINK WE DEALT
WITH THIS BEFORE YEAH BUT YOU
KNOW IT SEEMS LIKE EVERY TOM
DICK AND HARRY CAN HAVE A
FACEBOOK PAGE IN TWELVE
FOLLOWERS AND CALL THEMSELVES
AN OUTLET. AND BEFORE MOVING
INTO A DYNAMIC AND DANGEROUS
SITUATION NORMALLY ALLOWING.
MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA TO
PARTICIPATE. DID WE EVER FIND
TUNE WHAT IT IS TO BE A MEMBER
OF AUTHORIZED MEDIA. OR
RECOGNIZE MEDIA SO THERE IS NO
FEDERAL DEFINITION OF
AUTHORIZED MEDIA THERE IS NO
STATE DEFINITION OF AUTHORIZED
MEDIA. IN WHAT WE KNOW. OVER
THE PAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
DURING A SERIES OF PROTESTS
RALLIES. THERE'VE BEEN A RECORD
NUMBER OF JOURNALISTS WHO HAVE
BEEN. APPREHENDED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT THEY HAVE BEEN
ACCOSTED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THEY HAD BEEN. BEATEN BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND UNFAIRLY
ARRESTED. SO THERE IS NOT A
FORMAL DEFINITION BOTH ON THE
FEDERAL AS WELL AS THE STATE
LEVELS AND THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL IS TO ALLOW THE PRESS TO
DO THE WORK THAT THEY HAVE A
RIGHT TO DO UNDER THE FIRST
AMENDMENT. AND I WOULD HAVE
BEEN ON MY OWN TIME I WOULD
ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH THAT SOME
MUNICIPALITY IN FACT THE MOST
MUNICIPALITIES OR EVEN COUNTING
IS. CREATE A PRESS POOL MEANING
THAT THEY ARE A RECOGNIZED
MEMBER OF A- RECOGNIZED PRESS
OUTLET. AND I'M WONDERING AND
UNDER THESE CIRCUMSTANCES. IS
THE RESPECTIVE JURISDICTION
USING THE MUNICIPALITY OR THE
COUNTY DESIGNATION. OF AN
AUTHORIZED REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE NEWS OUTLETS. THIS BILL IN
NO WAY PROHIBITS LAW
ENFORCEMENT ON THE SCENE TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE A CALL ON WHO IS A
MEMBER OF THE PRESS AND WHO IS
NOT. AT SO- WOULD ENCOURAGE IN
AND I'M NOT ALL SEEN THIS TO
THE GOOD SENATOR AT ALL BUT
THIS BILL. DOES NOT DEFINE.
WHAT AND WHO A MEMBER OF THE
PRESS IS. BUT IT ALSO DOES NOT
PRECLUDE LAW ENFORCEMENT. FROM
INSURING THAT THE PRESS ARE
SAFE IN ADDITION- IT DOES NOT.
DETERMINE DETERMINE THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT- DOES NOT
PREDETERMINE HOOP AND MEMBER OF
THE PRESS IS NUMBER ONE NUMBER
TWO- INSURERS THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT STILL HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
PRESS ALONG IF NEED BE BASED
OFF OF PUBLIC SAFETY. IS THAT
PRECLUDE THAT FROM THAT HI IN
THIS BILL. CENTER GROVE. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT A QUESTION
OF THE AUTHOR YES PLEASE HE
WILL ACCEPT THE QUESTION THANK
YOU ACCORDING TO THE OPPOSITION
THE CALIFORNIA PETE POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION GIVES A
SCENARIO THIS IS BASICALLY FOR
EXAMPLE IMAGINE A SITUATION IT
TURNS VIOLENT DUE TO THE DANGER
IN THE SPECIFIC AREA CLOSE TO
THE PUBLIC NOW UNDER SB NINETY
EIGHT ANY PERSON CLAIMING TO BE
A REPRESENTATIVE THE NEW
SERVICE WEB ACCESS TO THAT
RESTRICTED AREA YOU WILL
INHIBIT- POLICE OFFICERS AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO KEEP THOSE
INDIVIDUAL SAFE BUT THE COMMENT
THAT YOU JUST MADE CAN YOU
REITERATE THAT. OR CAN YOU
REPEAT THAT BECAUSE ACCORDING
TO THE PEOPLE THAT ARE GONNA BE
WORKING THESE. SITUATIONS ON
THE GROUND- THEY THINK THAT
THIS ONE HIT THEM FOR
PROTECTING PEOPLE AND KEEPING
THEM SAFE MEANING THE PEOPLE ON
THE GROUND THAT ACTUALLY DO THE
WORK THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS. SO WE WE'VE HAD
NUMEROUS CONVERSATIONS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT OVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS BUT THIS BILL IS BACK IN
FRONT OF US- AFTER JUST BEING
CANDID WITH HIS BODY THAT WAS
VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR WE TOOK
THE FEEDBACK THAT WE RECEIVED
IN THAT MEDIA MESSAGE SERIOUSLY
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH- ALL
SIDES ON THIS ISSUE. TO ENSURE
THAT IT'S GONNA BE SUCCESSFUL
BUT HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES. IT ALLOWS
PRESS TO HAVE THE SAME FREEDOM.
AS THEY ALREADY ARE ALLOWED IN
LAW DURING THE TIME OF NATURAL
DISASTER. FIRE FLOOD
EARTHQUAKE. WE'RE NOT CHECKING
PRESS CREDENTIALS IN FACT WE
ALLOW PRESSED TO BE ABLE TO GO
BEHIND FIRE LINES WE ALLOW.
JOURNALISTS TO BE ABLE TO DO
THEIR JOB TO BE ABLE TO COVER
EARTHQUAKES IN THIS SIMPLY
TAKES THAT DEFINITION. IT PUTS
IT TOWARDS IN IMPLEMENTS IT FOR
FIRST AMENDMENT DEMONSTRATIONS
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE LEADING
THE WAY WHEN IT COMES TO THE
PROTECTION. OF PRESS FREEDOM IN
THE FIRST AMENDMENT IF WE TAKE
A LOOK AT THE STATE THE
STATISTICS. THE ONES THAT NEED
TO BE PROTECTED AT THIS MOMENT.
THE ONES THAT NEED TO BE
PROTECTED IN THIS NATION IN THE
STATE ARE THE JOURNALISTS THEY
ARE BEING UNFAIRLY ARRESTED.
THEY'RE BEING ACCOSTED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT A MINORITY OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT I MIGHT ADD. BUT
LET'S JUST TAKE A LOOK AT THE
STATISTICS ACROSS THIS NATION
OVER THE LAST EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS. JOURNALISTS
ARE THE ONES THAT ARE PUTTING
THEMSELVES IN DANGER TIME IN
AND TIME OUT COVERING FIRST AND
THEN THE DEMONSTRATIONS.
PROVIDING THE PUBLIC THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED AND
CANDIDLY. I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SOME RED HERRINGS OUT THERE
SOMEONE WITH A CELL PHONE FROM
FACEBOOK IS GOING TO BE- SAY
THAT THEY'RE A REPORTER. THIS
BILL DOESN'T CHANGE A LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO. MOVE THAT INDIVIDUAL
LONG I CAN REALLY FEEL THAT
THAT IS A RED HERRING ARGUMENT
I'VE HEARD IT OVER AND OVER
AGAIN I HAVE GREAT RESPECT BY
THE WAY. FOR THE SENATOR IN
LOVE WORKING WITH HER BUT I. I
DID SIMPLY DON'T SEE THAT IN
FACT I SEE THE OPPOSITE WHERE
JOURNALISTS ARE THE ONES THAT
ARE PUTTING THEMSELVES IN
HARM'S WAY. THEY'RE THE ONES
THAT ARE BEING ACCOSTED
UNFAIRLY DETAINED ARRESTED AND
CANDIDLY SUMMER BEING BEATEN
SHOT WITH RUBBER BULLETS IT IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL HAT THIS.
LEGISLATURE PASSES BILL. THANK
YOU AM I MY OWN TO MAYBE SHE'S
READING THE LETTERS OF
OPPOSITION FROM THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT INDIVIDUALS THAT
WERE ON THE GROUND AND THAT'S
WHAT POSE THOSE QUESTIONS. AND
THEY ALSO SAY THAT CURRENT
LOTTERY ALREADY GIVES DULY
AUTHORIZED ME PERSONAL ACCESS
TO THESE EVENTS. SB NINETY
EIGHT ADDS A VAGUE NEW STATUTE
THAT CREATES A NEW VIOLATION
THAT OVER IT'S OVERLY BROAD.
ACCORDING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND IT CUT IS. BOUND FOR COSTLY
LITIGATION. AND SO I'D
RECOMMEND A NO VOTE AND THEN
I'D ALSO LIKE TO JUST- WITH
DEEP RESPECT TO THE- TO THE
AUTHOR. YOU KNOW LIKE I LOVE
WORKING WITH HIM TOO. AND IN
THE LAST FEW DAYS WE'VE LIMITED
PRESS- YOU KNOW. ROGER VERITAS
AND OTHER ORGANIZATIONS THAT GO
UNDER COVER AND GET INFORMATION
AND THAT. YOU KNOW SO I THINK
THAT THIS BODY TENDS TO PROTECT
SOME SPEECH THAT THEY LIKE BUT
NOT SPEECH THAT THEY DON'T
LIKE. AND IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
COMPLETELY AGAINST THIS BILL
BECAUSE THEY FEEL LIKE IT
JEOPARDIZES THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE CLAIMING TO BE PRESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NEVER.
FENDER KAMMERER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT QUESTION FOR
THE OFFICE. WILL YOU ACCEPT THE
QUESTION YES MA'AM HE WILL.
WITH DEEP APOLOGIES I HAVE TO
SAY THAT- I WA NOT ABLE TO
HEAR ALL OF THE RESPONSES THAT
YOU- GAVE EARLIER BECAUSE AS
YOU KNOW I AM IN THE BACK AND
SOMETIMES IT IS HARD TO HEAR- I
RECEIVED. SO MANY CALLS FROM
CONSTITUENTS IN MY DISTRICT
ABOUT SOME OF THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE TAKEN ON THIS SIDE OF
THE AISLE BEFORE IT- MOVED OVER
TO THE OTHER SIDE- AND MANY OF
THEM WERE. DISMAYED TO SAY THE
LEAST AND SO I HAVE RE READ THE
BILL WHILE I WAS LISTENING TO.
SOME OF YOUR RESPONSES AND
STATEMENTS WHICH HAS PROBABLY
ALSO CONTRIBUTED TO THIS
QUESTION I WAS JUST HOPING THAT
YOU COULD REITERATE- THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN ON
THE ASSEMBLY SIDE- AND WHERE
THIS STILL STANDS- JUST BECAUSE
THERE WAS SUCH CONCERN. ABOUT
THE CHANGES THAT WERE MADE- AND
HOW THAT WOULD IMPACT ON
JOURNALISTS IN THEIR EFFORT TO-
TO BE ABLE TO COVER PROTESTS
EXTRATERRESTRIAL. IT WOULD JUST
FOR MY ADORATION IF YOU COULD-
REPEAT OME OF THE CHANGES THAT
HAVE NOW BEEN MADE AND ARE
INCORPORATED IN THE BILL THANK
YOU THE COMMAND CENTER. THE
FIRST AND FOREMOST WHEN THIS
BILL STARTED THERE WAS A
MISDEMEANOR IN THE BILL. THAT
WAS AMENDED OUT. THEN THERE WAS
A FINE IN THE BILL THAT'S FINE
FOR. ILLEGALLY ARRESTING
JOURNALISTS FOR BEATING A
JOURNALIST. THAT WAS AMENDED
OUT THERE WE CLARIFIED LANGUAGE
RELATED TO COME COMMAND TALKS
TO FULLY ALIGN THE LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL WITH EXISTING LAW.
THEN WE NEEDED ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS TO BE ABLE TO
CLARIFY THAT PROTECTIONS FROM
THE REST UNDER PENAL CODE WILL
ONLY APPLY TO MEMBERS OF THE
MEDIA WHEN THEY'RE GATHERING
RECEIVING OR PROCESSING
INFORMATION THEN WE ARE ASKED
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE AN
ADDITIONAL ON THEM TO CLARIFY
THE BILL CANNOT BE A BASIS FOR
CRIMINAL LIABILITY ON TOP OF
ALREADY TAKING THE MISDEMEANOR
OUT OF THE BILL. THEN WE NEEDED
TO BE ABLE TO ADD INTENT
LANGUAGE TO SEND A MESSAGE TO
THE COURT SAID IT IS THE INTENT
OF THE LEGISLATURE FOR THE
COURT AND THE COURTS TO
INTERPRET SP NINETY EIGHT TO
AFFORD THE SAME MEDIA
PROTECTIONS PROVIDED UNDER
EXISTING LAW THAT'S THE LAW
THAT I WAS TALKING ABOUT NOW
WHERE. A JOURNALIST MEDIUM
MEMBERS OF THEPRESS HAVE
FREEDOM WHEN IT COMES TO
NATURAL DISASTERS IN THE STATE
I WILL TELL YOU WE HAVE WORKED
HARD WE WORK WITH JOURNALISTS
UP AND DOWN THE EAST COAST WITH
THE CALIFORNIA NEWSPAPERS
ASSOCIATION TO BE ABLE TO BRING
CONSENSUS ON THIS BILL. AND I
JUST WANT TO- INDEED HERE
OBVIOUSLY HAPPY TO TAKE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE DATA. THAT'S IN
FRONT OF US RIGHT NOW. SIX
HUNDRED INCIDENTS SIX HUNDRED
INCIDENTS HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES. OF AGGRESSIONS AGAINST
MEMBERS OF THE PRESS TO DO
THEIR JOBS TO COVER FIRST
INTIMATE DEMONSTRATIONS. IN
TWENTY TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. AND WHAT WE ALSO KNOW IS
THAT MEMBERS OF THE PRESS
LITERALLY RISK THEIR LIVES EACH
AND EVERY DAY TO BE ABLE TO
DELIVER. FAIR AND ACCURATE NEWS
TO THE PUBLIC HERE IN THIS
STATE THIS LOSS SIMPLY TAKES
WHAT'S ALREADY IN LAW FOR
NATURAL DISASTERS IN TRANSITION
TO. GIVE EQUITY TOWARDS.
ENSURING THE JOURNALISTS HAVE
UNFETTERED ACCESS DURING FIRST
AND THEN THE DEMONSTRATIONS IT
ALREADY HAPPENS IN TIMES OF
EMERGENCY. AND I JUST WANT TO
ADDRESS FINALLY THE CONCERNS-
THAT WE CONTINUE TO HEAR ABOUT
NUMBER ONE. WE KEEP HEARING
THAT JOURNALISTS ARE GOING TO
HAVE UNFETTERED ACCESS TO
MOBILE COMMAND POST. THAT'S
MALARKEY. I NEED A- MEMBER OF
THE PRESS CAN'T WALK INTO A
POLICE STATION HAVE HAVE
UNFETTERED ACCESS. TO A POLICE
STATION SAME THING IS GOING TO
BE FOR MOBILE COMMAND POST
SECONDLY AGAIN WE REMOVE THE
MISDEMEANOR IN THIS BILL AND
THEN FINALLY. WE KEEP HEARING
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT WON'T BE
ABLE TO REMOVE MALICIOUS NUMBER
THE PRESS WAS OBSTRUCTING LAW
ENFORCEMENT FIRST OF ALL AGAIN
IT'S A RED HERRING. WELL WE
HAVEN'T SEEN THAT SITUATION.
WE'VE DOCUMENTED CASES OF
POLICE ARRESTING THE MEDIA IN
THIS BILL DOES NOT PROVIDE
BLANKET IMMUNITY ONE MORE TIME
BLANKET IMMUNITY FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PRESS TO INTENTIONALLY
OBSTRUCT ONE FORCING. ONE MORE
TIME DOES NOT PROVIDE BLANKET
IMMUNITY FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PRESS THAT INTENTIONALLY
OBSTRUCT LAW ENFORCEMENT. THE
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS HAS BEEN
UNDER ATTACK IN THIS NATION. WE
HAVE TO LEAD THIS NATION FOR
PROTECTIONS OF THE FIRST
AMENDMENT WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I VOTE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I
FACE. BACKER HI FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
CORTEZ HE- I DALLY. DOT FIVE
TORONTO HI AIKMAN GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE GROWTH NO HERTZBERG
I WENT SO I HER TADO. I JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LLEVA I
THE MON HI MCGUIRE. I MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN I NELSON NO A SHOW
OF BOTH. PAN ARCADE PORTS AND
YOU KNOW I RAW HIDE RUBIO. I
SKINNER. HI STERN I'M BURKE I
LIKE HOW SKI. HI WINNER I WILL
NO PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. BATES BALLY. A COMMON
GONZALEZ MELINDA'S NO CONTROL
OF BOTH. STERN. FIVE TWENTY
NINE KNOWS FIVE THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. I
WAS GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY SIX CENTER
LABOR IS PREPARED PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY BY
SENATOR ADMIN AN ACT RELATING
TO END OF LIFE. CENTER LABOR
THE FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD EVENING
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT SP
THREE EIGHTY FOR SENATOR
AIKMAN. A BILL THAT MAKES SOME
IMPORTANT CHANGES TO THE END OF
LIFE OPTION ACT WHICH HAS BEEN
IN EFFECT SINCE JUNE TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN. SEVEN OR
EIGHT MEN HAS HELD TWO
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ACT WITH
INPUT FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH PROVIDERS
HOSPITALS PATIENTS FAMILIES AND
MORE. THROUGH THOSE HEARINGS AS
WELL AS ADDITIONAL DATA AND
ANECDOTES IT BECAME CLEAR THAT
SOME WELL INTENTIONED ASPECTS
OF THE LAW SERVE AS BARRIERS
FOR TERMINALLY ILL PATIENTS.
INTERESTED IN ACCESSING THE
OPTION AFTER FIVE YEARS OF
IMPLEMENTATION THE CURRENT
PROCESS TO OBTAIN MEDICAL AID
IN DYING DRUGS IS UNNECESSARILY
CUMBERSOME. CONTAINING TOO MANY
ROADBLOCKS FOR MANY DYING
PATIENTS. AS THREE THREE EIGHTY
WOULD MAKE SEVERAL IMPORTANT
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE END OF LIFE
OPTION AT. SINCE THE BILL
PASSED THE SENATE AMENDMENTS IN
THE ASSEMBLY INCLUDED TECHNICAL
CHANGES WORKED OUT WITH THE
HOSPITALS. AS WELL AS THE
REINSTATEMENT OF A SUNSET DATE
EXTENDED TO TWENTY THIRTY ONE
TO ALLOW ADDITIONAL DATA TO BE
COLLECTED ON THE CHANGES SP
THREE EIGHTY MAKES TO THE END
OF LIFE OPTIONS ACT. THE CORE
PROTECTIONS BUILT INTO THE LAW
HAVE BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO
BE EFFECTIVE. THERE BEEN NO
REPORTED INSTANCES OF ABUSE OR
COERCION. IT IS TIME TO REMOVE
UNNECESSARY BARRIERS TO ACCESS
THROUGH THE END OF LIFE OPTION
ACT AND ENSURE THAT ALL
ELIGIBLE TERMINALLY ILL
INDIVIDUALS WILL HAVE THE RIGHT
TO REMAIN A THOMAS. AND DIE
WITH DIGNITY IN THE MANNER THAT
THEY DESIRE MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
IS. THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. AND
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
BY ATKINS I BASE NO BACKER. I
PORCHES. BRADFORD I HAVE A I
DON'T. HI CORTESE DALLY NO DODD
HI TORONTO HI ADNAN GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE GROWTH NO HERTZBERG
I WISH. HYPER TANTO I JONES NO
KAMMERER. LAYERED I LIVE ON
FIVE THE MON I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. NO A TURBO NOPE PAM HI
PERSON TINA. ROSS HI RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG HI FI
CASKEY I WINNER I WILL KNOW
THEN REMOVE THE CALL NUMBER FOR
ME TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN
SENATOR ARCHULETA MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE NINETY TWO BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA AN ACT
RELATING TO COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENT CENTER TO A- THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY TWO
WHICH IS BACK A CONCURRENCE.
MANDATES HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
TO ELECTRONICALLY DELIVER
NOTICES OF DOCUMENTS TO ITS
MEMBERS BEGINNING JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THREE IF A
RESIDENT OPT IN TO RECEIVE
EMAILS COMMUNICATION IF A
RESIDENT CHOOSES NOT TO OPT IN
THE ASSOCIATION WILL CONTINUE
TO DELIVER THEIR DOCUMENTS. BY
MAIL. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS TO
PREVENT ANY POTENTIAL CHAPTER
NOW ON SENATE BILL THREE NINETY
TWO OF THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
NO OPPOSITION AND RECEIVE NO NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR BIBLE. THANK YOU SENATOR
ARCHULETA M. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
HI ADKINS HI BABES I BACKER. HI
FORTUS I BRADFORD I HAVE THE
OTHER HI CORTESE I DALLY I DONT.
I TORONTO HI EGGMAN GLASER
ALRIGHT GONZALEZ GROWTH I HURTS
BURKE I WAS SO. HI HER TADO I
JONES I CAN LONGER AIRED HI
LLEVA HI THE MOON I MACQUARIE-
I MELINDA'S FIVE MEN. I NEWMAN
I NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH I
CAN I FOURTEEN TO NO I ROSS I
RUBIO. HI SKINNER HI STERN
AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER
I WILL HI. THEN REMOVE THE CALL
RIVERS REMOVING THE FILE ITEM
SEVENTY EIGHT SOMEONE
PRESENTING FOR SENATOR STERN ON
FILE ITEM. SEVENTY EIGHT. USING
THE- VISIT YOU SENATOR BAKER.
WELL IT'S CALLED WATER SHE'S
OFF THE FLOOR SO WE WILL MOVE
ON THE FINAL ITEM SEVENTY NINE
SENATOR BRADFORD. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL FIVE EIGHTY SIX BY SENATOR
BRADFORD AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT CENTRE
BRADFORD THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SP FIVE EIGHT SIX IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
SIMPLY FIXES A LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL DRAFTING HERE AS IT
RELATES TO SP TWO WHICH IS
BETTER KNOWN AS THE KING OF
FROST'S JUNIOR POLICE TO
CERTIFICATION ACT. THERE WAS AN
AMENDMENT MADE ON S. THREE TWO
WITH CLARIFIED THAT EXISTING
LAW REGARDING ISSUE. LUJAN'S
APPLIES TO DECERTIFICATION
PROCEEDINGS HOWEVER THE MEMBER
WAS PLACED IN THE WRONG SECTION
AND DUE TO A TECHNICAL ISSUE
THIS ERROR WAS UNABLE TO BE
FIXED DIRECTLY IN SP TWO. US AS
FREE- FIVE EIGHT SIX DOES NOT
CHANGE ANY LANGUAGE. IN THAT
AMENDMENT IT JUST SIMPLY MOVE
IT TO THE CORRECT SECTION- OF
S. THREE TWO THAT IS ENACTED- I
RESPECT THAT'S PRIVATE. THE
CENTRE BRADFORD MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE BETTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
FACE NO BACKER. I PORCHES NOPE
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM I
PROTESTING I TALLY NO DOT I
TORONTO HI ADNAN GLAZER. I
CONSOLIDATE GROWTH OKAY NO
HERTZBERG. WEST SO HI FURTADO I
JONES NO CAMCORDER LAYERED I
LLEVA I THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MAN. I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO A CHOKO NO PAM I
FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH FIVE
RUBIO I SKINNER. HI STERN
NUMBER FIVE CASKEY I WINNER I
WILL NOW SENDER MOVED TO CALL
MEMBERS WERE GONNA MOVE BACK TO
FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT SENATOR
HERTZBERG MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FOUR
OH SIX BY SENATOR STERN AN ACT
RELATING TO OIL AND GAS SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMON SET DEADLINES FOR CERTAIN
PAL JIM ACTIONS PRIOR TIES WILL
RELATED MATERIALS TO BE POSTED
ONLINE AND ADD PROGRESS AND
PROGRESS REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
THE AVAILABILITY OF MATERIALS
ONLINE. AMONG OTHER ELEMENTS AS
RIVALS THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THEN BAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I HATE.
BACKER HI FOR JUST. BRADFORD I
HAVE A I DON'T I PROTESTING HI
DOLLY. GOD HI THERE ALSO HI
ADNAN LASER FIVE DOLLARS GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO I HER TADO.
HI JONES I CAN LONGER. LAYERED
I LABOR HI THE MON I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S. IN I NEWMAN I NELSON.
I TRIED BOTH. PAM HI PORTS IN
CHINO. HI RALPH I RUBIO.
SKINNER I STERN'S NUMBER FIVE
CASKEY HI WINNER I WILL. HI THE
NEW MOVE THE CALL MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS MANNA PRO TEM I
UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE A- ADJOURN
IN MEMORY 2% THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES THANK
YOU SO MUCH- FOR. MY SELF IN
THE REPUBLICAN LEADER I WANTED
TO TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY AND
RISE TODAY TO ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF MRS DONNA
CANNELLA. WHO PASSED AWAY ON
TUESDAY THIS PAST TUESDAY
SEPTEMBER SEVENTH AT THE YOUNG
AGE OF SEVENTY EIGHT. DONNA WAS
THE BELOVED MOTHER OF A FORMER
MEMBER OF THIS BODY CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATOR ANTHONY CANNELLA
WHO REPRESENTED THE TWELFTH
DISTRICT FROM TWENTY TEN TO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. SHE WAS ALSO
THE WIFE OF FORMER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SAL CANNELLA WHO
REPRESENTED PORTIONS OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. THE TWO WERE
MARRIED FOR FIFTY SEVEN YEARS
AND THEIRSWAS A RELATIONSHIP
BUILT ON LOVE ADMIRATION AND
SUPPORT OF ONE ANOTHER AND
THEIR FAMILY. DONNA'S FAMILY
WAS AT THE CENTER OF HER HEART
AND ALL THAT SHE DID IT IN
RETURN HER FAMILY WHICH
INCLUDES HER THREE CHILDREN
NICOLE ANTHONY AND VINCENT AND
NINE GRAND CHILDREN FILLED HER
LIFE WITH JOY. DONNA WAS A
RESPECTED COMFORTING FIGURE IN
THE SERIES COMMUNITY AND HER
ABILITY TO PUT OTHERS AT EASE
NOT ONLY AIDED HER IN HER WORK
IN THE HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY. BUT
ALSO WAS A TRUSTED FOUNDATION
FOR HER HUSBAND IN HIS ROLE AS
AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER. DONNA IS A
TESTAMENT TO WHAT IT MEANS TO
LOVE WITH YOUR WHOLE HEART INTO
THE SELFLESS SACRIFICE THAT SO
MANY OF OUR SPOUSES GIVE THOSE
OF US WHO WORK IN PUBLIC
SERVICE. DONNA'S PASSING WILL
LEAVE A VOID IN THE CANAL OF
FAMILY. BUT HER MEMORY WILL
NEVER FADE NOR WILL THE LOVE
SHE SHARED OVER THESE MANY
YEARS. IT'S FOR THOSE REASONS
THAT I'D ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN
THE MEMORY OF THIS TREMENDOUS
WOMAN DONNA CANNELLA AND WE PAY
OUR RESPECTS TO OUR FORMER
COLLEAGUE SENATOR ANTHONY
CANNELLA. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THINK ABOUT A PRO TEM
PLEASE BE SURE TO BRING HER
NAME FORWARD SO SHE MAY BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. UBER'S
WE'RE STILL UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. SENATOR GLAZER FOR
PURPOSE TO RISE- MADAM
PRESIDENT WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST
A FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN S. B.
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR BE MOVED TO
AN ACTIVE. THANK YOU THE DESK
WILL NOTE DOES ANYONE HAVE
ANYTHING ELSE THEY WISH TO
REMOVE SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I REQUEST FOR
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUBMIT A
LETTER TO THE JOURNAL ON BILL
FIVE THIRTY THAT CLARIFIES THE
INTENT OF THE BILL. THE LETTER
WAS APPROVED BY BOTH HOUSES. I
THINK THEY- FEDERAL MON.
MEMBERS THERE'S A RESOLUTION AT
THE DESK REQUESTING TO DISPENSE
WITH ARTICLE FOUR SECTION
EIGHTY OF THE CONSTITUTION AS
IT RELATES TO ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
FIVE FOUR THE REQUEST HAS BEEN
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
THANK YOU CEREMONY BETTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
RESOLUTION AND THEN CALL THE
ROLL. THE FOLLOWING RESOLUTION
WAS OFFERED BY SENATOR LET
ALONE RESOLVED ABOUT ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX FIVE FOUR PRESENTS A
CASE OF URGENCY AS THAT TERM IS
USED IN ARTICLE FOUR SECTION
EIGHT B. OF THE CONSTITUTION
AND THE PROVISION OF THAT
SECTION REQUIRING THAT THE
BILL. BE READ ON THREE SEVERAL
DAYS IN EACH HOUSE IS HEREBY
DISPENSED WITH AND IT IS
ORDERED THAT SAID BILL BE READ.
THE SECOND AND THIRD TIMES
CONSIDERED ENGROSSED AND PLACED
UPON ITS PASSAGE. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I BASE. BACKER HI BARGES
NO BRADFORD I HAVE A HI CORTEZ
HE- HI DALLY. DOT HI TORONTO HI
EGGMAN GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE.
GROSS HERTZBERG HI WEST SO. HER
TADO I JONES. CAN LONGER
LAYERED I LLEVA HI THE MOON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON. BUT SHOWED
BOTH. PAM I PERSON TINO HI
RALPH. HI RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN AMBERG HI MY CASKEY I
WINNER. I WILL. FIVE TWENTY SIX
NEWS ONE THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED MADAM SECRETARY CAN YOU
READ IT THE RESOLUTION. PLEASE
CALL THE OFFICE MEMBERS. FAITH
DALLY. ADMIN GONZALES. GROVE
WEST SO. JONES CAMCORDER
BELINDA'S. NIELSEN WAS ONCE. A
TROUBLED STERN WELL. HI. WE'RE
JUST WAITING FOR SOME MEMBERS
WHO SNUCK OFF THE FLOOR TO COME
BACK. FIVE TWENTY SEVEN NEWS
ONE THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
MADAM SECRETARY COULD YOU
PLEASE READ THE BILL A SECOND
AND THE THIRD TIME. ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX FIFTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AS AN ACT
RELATING TO OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
AND TO CLAIM THE URGENCY THERE
AT SIX FIFTY MERELY. ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX FIFTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAN AS AN ACT.
RELATING TO. OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND CLEARING THE URGENCY
THERE OF SIX POINT TWO MILLION.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
SUNDERLAND OWN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM MADAM MADAM
PRESIDENT TODAY PRESENT TO YOU
AT EIGHTY SIX FIVE FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAY IS WHICH IS
A CLEAN UP TO HER PREVIOUS
MEASURE AB SIXTY FIVE WHICH
FOCUS ON THE BASIC STEPS
EMPLOYERS MUST TAKE TO CONTROL
WORK SITE SPECIFIC EXPOSURE OF
CODE NINETEEN CLEAN UP TO THIS
MASSIVE MEASURE IS ESSENTIAL
FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
SAFETY OF CALIFORNIA SO THAT WE
CAN MITIGATE THE EFFECTS OF THE
PANDEMIC RECENT AMENDMENTS
REMOVE ALL OPPOSITION AND EVEN
MOVE THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND OTHERS OF THE OPPOSITION
COALITION TO A SUPPORT POSITION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPO.
THANK YOU CEREMONY MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE CENTER
GROVE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL BUT WHEN I READ IT
DURING OUR BREAK AT. WAS VERY
PERPLEXED AND I HAD SOME
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR IF
THAT'S POSSIBLE. THE MOON WE
TAKE A QUESTION. PLEASE
PROCEED. I SUPPORT THE BILL
LET'S GO THERE BUT I WAS KIND
OF CURIOUS- IT SAYS IF YOU
LOOK- AND LET ME EXPLAIN WHY-
LET ME EXPLAIN WHY SO SIX
EIGHTY FIVE LAST YEAR TOOK A
GUARD. OR A MACHINE REGARD-
CODE SECTION OUT OF THE OSHA
TITLE EIGHT AND IT WEAPONIZED
COUPLE OF IT SO THAT AND IN THE
SAME MANNER THAT CAL OSHA COULD
GO INTO A MANUFACTURING
FACILITY AND SHUT DOWN. AGAIN A
BAD PIECE OF EQUIPMENT THAT DID
NOT HAVE A PROPER GARDEN PLACE.
HURTING SOMEBODY CUTTING FF A
FINGER OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT
THEY COULD IMMEDIATELY SHUT
DOWN THAT FACILITY THE USE OF
THAT PARTICULAR- CODE SECTION
TO WEAPONIZE CODED AND TURN IT
INTO A REPORTING REQUIREMENT.
DISK CLEANUP BILL KIND OF GOT
MY ATTENTION AND THE REASON
WHY. IS BECAUSE IT CHANGED THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS TO FORTY
EIGHT HOURS- IN SPORTS TO DATE
YOU KNOW WHATEVER WAS LATTER SO
BASICALLY FORTY EIGHT HOURS
INSTEAD OF SAME DAY. BUT THERE
WERE A LOT OF EXEMPTIONS SO THE
EXEMPTION ON THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. R. A. HEALTH
FACILITY THAT'S ONE THIRTY
EIGHT PAGE SEVEN. ON THE
FOLLOWING PAGE PAGE EIGHT
SECTION TO A COMMUNITY CLINIC
SECTION FOR A TRAVEL CLINIC IS
EXEMPT AN INDIAN TRIBE OR
TRIBAL ORGANIZATION A REAL
HEALTH CARE CLINIC A FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTER A
CHRONIC DIALYSIS CENTER. EIGHT
EIGHT THE EMPLOYER THAT
PROVIDES HEALTH CARE. AN
EMPLOYER THAT PROVIDES ADULT
HEALTH CENTERS HEALTH CARE
HEALTH CARE AGENCY A PEDIATRIC
DAY CARE HEALTH RESPITE
FACILITY A HOSPICE FACILITY
RESIDENTIAL FACILITY WITH
SPECIAL HEALTH CARE NEEDS
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITY FOR
PERSONS WITH CHRONIC LIFE
THREATENING ILLNESSES A
RESIDENTIAL FACILITY FOR THE
ELDERLY SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES A CHILD DAY CARE
FACILITY IN THE LIST GOES ON.
MY QUESTION IS THAT- ARE THESE
VISIBILITY IS EXEMPT FROM THE
REPORTING PERIOD. SECTION B.
THAT REQUIRES OTHER EMPLOYERS
REPORT WITH FORTY EIGHT HOURS.
SO I WILL HAVE TO GET YOU THAT
CONCRETE ANSWER OF IT SINCE I
DON'T HAVE THAT IN FRONT OF ME
AND- I AM CERTAINLY HAPPY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT GETS BACK
TO YOU. THANK YOU AND I AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT ASKING FOR
ASKING THE QUESTION THAT YOU
DIDN'T KNOW I MEAN I REALIZE
THAT YOU'RE JUST- MANAGING FOR
MANAGING THE BILL YOU KNOW
WHAT'S INTERESTING TO ME IS
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU GET THIS
INFORMATION. THE PREVIOUS BILL
FROM LAST TO REQUIRE THESE
ENTITIES WHETHER YOU'RE AN
EMPLOYER AN EMPLOYER TO REPORT
TO YOUR LOCAL AND REPORT TO THE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND
THEN YOU'D REPORT CAL OSHA.
OSHA THREE HUNDRED LOG WHICH IS
REQUIRED BY EMPLOYERS FOR
INJURIES IT WASN'T ON OCEAN
THREE N. LIKE THAT SIMILAR
REPORTING THE SAME DAD WAS THE
SAME- FOR THE SOCIAL IT WASN'T
ON OCEAN THREE HUNDRED LOG ME
MAKE THAT CLEAR IT WAS THE SAME
DATA REQUIRED FOR AN OSHA THREE
HUNDRED LOG. TO REPORT AND
INDEED DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS OR THE CALIFORNIA
CODE DATA WEB BASED WOULD TRACK
ALL THIS INFORMATION- BY
INDUSTRY. AND THE REASON WHY IT
WAS SO CURIOUS TO ME THAT WOULD.
EXEMPT ALL OF THESE- THE SICK
WHICH I'M VERY GLAD WE ARE WE
DON'T GET ME WRONG IT'S HARD TO
MAINTAIN FOR ANY EMPLOYER AND I
COULD IMAGINE THESE EMPLOYERS.
SO FROM JANUARY FIRST TILL NOW
THERE WERE FORTY SMALL PRINT
JUST ONE SECOND. FROM JANUARY
FIRST TO ANOTHER 430-008-0040
EIGHT REPORTED CASES. WHEN YOU
TAKE THESE FACILITIES OUT THERE
ARE HIGHLIGHTED ON THIS REPORT
FORM. THAT ARE IN THIS BILL
THAT EXAM. WE DROP OUR CASE
REPORTING TO NINE THOUSAND
CASES OF COVE IT. SO JUST IT
PEAKED MY CURIOSITY OF WHY. WE
WOULD REPORT THOSE CASES AND IT
WOULD REDUCE OUR NUMBER OF KOBE
CASES. ALMOST INSTANTLY AS SOON
AS THE GOVERNOR BUT HIS
SIGNATURE. ON THIS BILL SO THAT
WAS MY CURIOUS POINT. I SUPPORT
THE BILL I ASKED FOR AND I VOTE
BUT THAT DIDN'T PIQUE MY
CURIOSITY. THANK YOU AND I
WILL- FOLLOW UP IN FACT IF. YES
THANK YOU CENTER GROVE THANK
YOU CENTER THE MON SENATOR PAM
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY SIX FIFTY FOUR- I WOULD
MAKE A NOTE THAT- THE
FACILITIES DESCRIBED BY MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM BAKERSFIELD.
ACTUALLY HAVE OTHER REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS UNDER STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW SO IN MANY WAYS THE
SANCTIONS HAVE TO DO WITH NOT
HAVING DUPLICATE REPORTING
SINCE THEY ACTUALLY FALL UNDER-
THEY HAVE REPORTING
pPLACES AND SO WITH THAT- I
THINK AT LEAST TO ME IT SEEMS
TO MAKE SENSE WE DON'T REDUCE
DUPLICATION- STRICTLY ASPEN
EITHER. THANK YOU SENATOR PENN
CENTER GROVE MADAM PRESIDENT I
LIKE THINK TO GET SENATOR FROM
SACRAMENTO FOR PROVIDING THAT
INFORMATION TO ME- THAT WASN'T
AVAILABLE IN THE BILL ITSELF
AND- LIKE I SAID IT JUST PIQUES
MY CURIOSITY AND I APPRECIATE
THAT INFORMATION THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU MEMBERS ANY FURTHER.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING THEM MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN.
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I FACE HI
BECKER HI FORTUS I BRADFORD I
COME BY ADAM HI FOR TESTING HI
DOLLY. DODD HI TORONTO. AIKMAN
GLAZER. GONZALEZ GROVE HI HURTS
BERG I WENT SO. HI HER TADO I
JONES. CAN LONGER. LAYERED I
FLAVOR. HI THE MON I MACQUARIE-
I MELINDA'S I MEN. I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. A SHOW OF BOTH. I PAN
I FORTUNE TINO. I BROUGHT I
RUBIO I SKINNER HI STERN AMBERG
HI MIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL.
I. PLEASE CALL THE UPSET
MEMBERS. ALAN I. DALLY I.
TORONTO HI AIKMAN GLAZER I
GONZALEZ JONES I. CAMCORDER I
NIELSEN. I STERN HIGHS THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY
FIVE THREE SEVEN NINE ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE
GONNA MOVE BACK TO ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH FILE ITEM THIRTY
SEVEN SENATOR WEINER MEN
SECRETARY PLEAS READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO FIFTEEN BY A FAMILY
MEMBER TO AN ACT RELATING TO
HOUSING CENTER WINNER THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT COLORS I RISE
TO PRESENT EIGHTY TWO FIFTEEN
AS WE ALL KNOW OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS IS THAT A LOT OF HARD
WORK TO ADDRESS. OUR HOUSING
CRISIS HERE IN CALIFORNIA NOW A
BIG PART OF OUR RESPONSIBILITY
IS ENFORCING THE LAWS WE PASSED.
MAYBE TWO FIFTEEN WILL ENSURE.
OUR ABILITY TO ENFORCE THESE
LAWS BY PROVIDING THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. WITH MORE TOOLS
AND INCREASING CLARITY FOR
EVERYONE. THIS INCLUDES THE
LAWS OF THE CITY CAN ENFORCE
IMPORTANT MEASURES KERRY OR
PASSED BY THIS HOUSE
ORIGINATING IN THE CELLS
INCLUDING SENATOR SKINNER'S SB
THREE THIRTY AND MY OWN SP
THIRTY FIVE. ADDITIONALLY THE
BILL ALLOWS THE PUBLIC TO WEIGH
IN ON HOUSING ELEMENTS BY
REQUIRING A THIRTY DAY COMMENT
PERIOD BEFORE CITIES AND
COUNTIES CAN SUBMIT THEM TO A
CD. THE BILL IS SUPPORTED BY A
BROAD COALITION INCLUDING THE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE EQUITY
ADVOCATES REALTORS LANDLORDS
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND BOTH FOR
PROFIT AND NONPROFIT HOME
BUILDERS I ASKED FOR AN IPO.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ARCHULETA. AT KINS. I HATE
NO BACKER. PORGES NO BRADFORD I
COME BY OTHER. CORTESE HI DOLLY
NO DOG. HI TORONTO HI EGGMAN
WESER. GONZALEZ GROSS NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO I HER TADO I
JONES. NO CAMEL UNDER. BLARED I
LIVE ON I LIVE ALONE. REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN.
NIELSEN NO TRUST VOTE NO PAN HI
FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS FIVE RUBIO
I SKINNER I STERN AMBERG I LIKE
HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL KNOW
PLEASE CALL THE OF THE MEMBERS.
ALAN. ARCHULETA. BECKER I
CABALLERO. EGGMAN GLAZER.
GONZALEZ CAN LONGER I THE MON.
NEWMAN STERN. FIVE TWENTY TWO
KNOWS THE L. NINE THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON THE FILE AND-I'M FIFTY EIGHT SENATOR DORADO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN FORTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS AN
ACT RELATING TO FOSTER CARE.
CENTER DRAWS THEM THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE TO
PRESENT A B. ELEVEN FORTY THE
UNACCOMPANIED IMMIGRANT
CHILDREN PROTECTIONS ACT WHICH
WILL CLARIFY THAT THE OFFICE OF
THE STATE OMBUDSPERSON FOR
FOSTER CARE. CAN AND SHOULD
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT AND SERVICES
TO UNACCOMPANIED IMMIGRANT
CHILDREN IN FEDERAL CUSTODY WHO
ARE PLACED IN CALIFORNIA STATE
LICENSED CHILD CARE SETTINGS.
THIS BILL WILL NOT CREATE NEW
RIGHTS FOR FOSTER YOUTH OR
UNACCOMPANIED IMMIGRANT
CHILDREN. IT WILL SIMPLY
CLARIFY THE STATE AGENCY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR WELL
BEING- THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO
OPPOSITION. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT BEAVIS I
ASKED FOR AND I WROTE. FIGURE
CENTER DRAWS- MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING THEM EYES THIRTY SEVEN
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FIFTY
NINE SENATOR- BERGMAN'S
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX SEVENTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALLED IRAN AN ACT
RELATING TO CHILD ABUSE OR
NEGLECT THE NUMBER. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES
A. B. SIX SEVENTY SIX PROVIDE
PROTECTIONS FOR PARENTING
FOSTER MINORS AND NON MINOR
DEPENDENTS BURNING FOSTER YOU
STRUGGLE TO ACCESS BASIC
SUPPORT NEEDS FOR THEM AND
THEIR CHILDREN TO THRIVE THIS
BILL PROVIDES A CERTAIN NOTICES
AND PROTECTIONS ARE TONIGHT
BOTH. THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE. FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON A FILE ITEM
SIXTY SENATOR ALBERT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN FIFTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALMOST AN ACT
RELATING TO FOSTER YOUTH CENTER
NUMBER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS OF AB TEN FIFTY
FIVE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROMMEL'S ENSURES THAT
ALL STUDENTS WITHIN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM INCLUDING THOSE
UNDER THE AUTHORITY OF A TRIBAL
COURT. AND THOSE IN OUT OF HOME
PLACEMENT UNDER VOLUNTARY
PLACEMENT AGREEMENT ARE
AFFORDED THE SAME PROTECTIONS
ENTITLEMENTS AS OTHER YOUTH
URGENT I VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
AMBER MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
SEEING NONE FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
NO ZERO IF THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING ON TO THE
CONSECUTIVE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE RESOLUTION
RESOLUTION FIFTY FIVE. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI ADKINS I FACE I
BACKER. I PURCHASED I BRADFORD
I COME BY ADAM I PROTESTING I
DALLY. I DON HI TORONTO HI
EGGMAN LASER HI CONSOLIDATE
GROWTH. HI HURTS BURKE I WAS SO
I HER TADO HI JONES. I CAN
LONGER I LAYERED I LLEVA HI THE
MOON HI WIRE. I MELINDA'S I MEN
I NEWMAN I NIELSEN I SHOW BOTH
HI PAM I WASN'T YOU KNOW HI
BROUGHT MY REVIEW I SKINNER. I
STERN AMBERG HI LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL I. FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED. ALL.
SENATOR WIENER FOR WHAT PURPOSE
TO RISE MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
NOW I GET BACK TO JUST A MOMENT
OKAY.
MEMBERS IF YOU COULD TAKE
YOUR SEATS PLEASE WE ARE GOING
TO LIFT CALLS ON THE BILLS THAT
WERE IT NOT ABLE TO CLOSE OUT.
REMEMBERS WE'RE STARTING WITH
FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE. AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE. BETTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ARCHULETA
BRADFORD. I. BRADFORD CORTEZ HE.
TORONTO TORONTO. THERE ARE SO.
THANK YOU MAN. GLAZER HERTZBERG.
WEST SO. CAMCORDER I NEWMAN.
PAN ROSS. RUBIO STERN. AMBERG.
FIVE FOURTEEN KNOWS TWELVE THE
MEASURE FAILS MEMBERS MOVING TO
FILE ITEM SEVENTY SIX SP THREE
EIGHTY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. PORCHES. QARTET THESE.
EGGMAN GONZALEZ KAMMERER. I
FORTINO. STERN. FIVE TWENTY SIX
WHO KNOWS EIGHT THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON THE FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SEVEN SP THREE NINETY
TWO PLEASE CALL THE UPSET
MEMBERS. I COMMEND. GONZALES
CAM AUGER I STERN. FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM SEVENTY NINE
SP FIVE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. EGGMAN
GONZALES HERZBERG I CAN LONGER
I STERN. FIVE TWENTY EIGHT NEWS
NINE THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
I'M SEVENTY EIGHT SP FOUR OH
SIX PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. FAITH RIGHT YEAH
PORCHES. HAVE TO RETALIATE THE
POLLS SAY EDMUND GONZALES
GROWTH. CAMCORDER I MELINDA'S.
NIELSEN SURE BOTH. RUBIO. I
STERN FIVE THIRTY NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION
RECONSIDERATION WILL BE GRANTED.
TWO FIVE TWO AB. THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE. MEMBERS YOU HAVE A
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE NUMBER TWO IN
FRONT OF YOU PLEASE TAKE A
MOMENT TO FAMILIARIZE YOURSELF
WITH IT.
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO
ZERO ON RECONSIDERATION.
PRIME
MEMBERS YOU HAVE SUPPLEMENTAL
FILE TOO IN FRONT OF YOU WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE ITEM
EIGHTY US SENATOR SHE'S BEEN-
FIFTY EIGHT NUMBER SIXTY TWO
SENATOR ALSO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL SIXTY
TWO BY SENATOR ALSO AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SB SIXTY
TWO MAKES CLEAR THAT THE
BUSINESS CONTRACTING TO HAVE
GARMENTS IS LIABLE FOR UNPAID
WAGES TO THE SKILLED WORKERS
WHO MAKE THOSE GARMENTS
REGARDLESS OF HOW MANY LAYERS
OF CONTRACTING THE COMPANY MAY
USE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
RESTRICT RECOVERY FROM BUYING
GUARANTORS TO WAGES ONLY. THESE
AMENDMENTS ALSO REMOVE PROPOSED
CHANGES TO THE EXISTING
STRUCTURE OF THE GARMENT
RESTITUTION FUND. I'M PROUD TO
SAY THAT BOTH HOUSES SUPPORT
OUR GOVERNMENT WORKERS
IMMIGRANT WOMEN WHO ARE
BACKBONE OF THE FASHION
INDUSTRY. JUST LIKE ALL OF YOU
THROUGHOUT LA IN CALIFORNIA WHO
WORKS SO HARD FOR TWO YEARS.
ALTHOUGH THIS IS THE LAST DAY I
TRUSTED OUR LEGISLATORS WOULD
DELIVER. WHICH HAS GOT US YES
POLICE SAY THAT IS A LEVEL
HEADED C. LIST ALTHOUGH IT IS A
LOCAL STUDENT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU CENTER
DRAWS SO MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE. CENTER HERTZBERG. IT
BRIEFLY MADAM PRESIDENT I JUST
WANTED TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HER HARD WORK WANT TO THANK MY
FRIENDS AND THAT SAID THAT- FOR
BEING SPONSORS IN THE
COALITIONS THAT WE BUILT ACROSS
MANY COMMUNITIES. ON ISSUES
THAT ARE SO IMPORTANT TONIGHT
JUST TO. WANT TO JOIN THANK HER
AN ISSUE OF THE HOUSE. THANK
YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG MEMBERS
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING THEM
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA I AT
KENS FIVE BABIES NO BACKER. I
PORCHES NOPE BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM I PROTESTING I DALLY. NO
DOG. I TORONTO. AIKMAN GLAZER.
GONZALEZ GROSS. NO HERTZBERG HI
WEST SO HYPER TADO. NO JONES.
NO CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I LIVE
ON THE MOON HI MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S. MAN  NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO A TELEPHONE NO PAN
HI PERSON TINA. HI ROB HI RUBIO.
HI SKINNER. FIVE STERNE NUMBER.
I LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER HI WELL.
NO PLEASE CALL THE UPSET
MEMBERS. TORONTO I RECOMMEND
GLAZER. ONE DOLLAR MELINDA'S NO
STERN WHAT IS TWENTY SIX IN
THOSE TEN THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING THE FILE ITEM EIGHTY ONE
SENATOR PORTENT TINO BEEN
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ANNABEL
FOURTEEN BY SENATOR FORTUNE
TINO AN ACT RELATING TO PEOPLE
HEALTH AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERAPISTS TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. THE NEW BORN TINO
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SP FOURTEEN IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE WITH AMENDMENTS
THAT REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION BY
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TO RECOMMEND BEST PRACTICES AND
IDENTIFIED EVIDENCE BASED. AND
EVIDENCE INFORMED TRAINING
PROGRAM FOR SCHOOLS TO ADDRESS
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH I WAS
HOPING THIS BILL WOULD HAVE THE
YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID-
COMPONENT IN IT UNFORTUNATELY
THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. TOOK THAT OUT- BUT
IT ALSO INCLUDES A VERY
IMPORTANT PROVISION TO MAKE
SURE THAT MENTAL HEALTH IS
TREATED THE SAME AS PHYSICAL
HEALTH THIS IS TRYING TIMES FOR
OUR KIDS- AS THEY GO BACK TO
SCHOOL AND THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUE SHOULD BE TREATED THE
SAME AS PHYSICAL HEALTH. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE
THANK YOU CENTER PORN TINO
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE ALL EYES
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO
ZERO DECEMBER MOMENTS ARE
CONFERRED IN. MOVING TO FILE
ITEM EIGHTY TWO CENTER STARTED
SOMEONE PRESENTING FOR SENATOR
SENATOR STERN. BY PREVENTION.
WE OKAY SENATOR MCGUIRE COME ON
DOWN. THE SALES MANAGER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL SIXTY THREE BY SENATOR
STERN AN ACT RELATING TO FIRE
PREVENTION CENTER REQUIRE THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT
HONORED TO BE ABLE TO PRESENT
TO SOME P. HALF OF SENATOR
STERN AND WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO HIM FOR ALL HIS HARD WORK
SAYS HE SIXTY THREE EMPOWERS
LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS TO TRAIN
VOLUNTEERS AND FIRE PREVENTION
EFFORTS ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
EXTEND REPORTING DUE DATES IN
ADDRESS TECHNICAL IN CHAPTER
NINE ISSUES WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
MCGUIRE MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
THING IN HER NONE FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN NEWS ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
WOMEN'S PARKING CODE IN FILE
ITEM EIGHTY THREE SENATOR PAN
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE OH SIX BY
SENATOR PAN AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH CARE CENTER PM THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS ASK
THE THREE OH SIX WHICH
ADDRESSES OR STD EPIDEMIC IS
BACK IN CONCURRENCE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS LEAVE PROVISIONS
THAT WERE EXPANDED ACCESS TO
THE FAMILY PACK PROGRAM.
CLARIFY THE MEDIC HOUSE
REQUIRED PAPERS HOME IF HE GETS
ANY P. T. THERAPY ONLY TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE RECEIVE FEDERAL
APPROVAL KINDS OF TRAINING
COUNSELORS WILL BE PERFORMING
STD RAPID TESTS AND MAKE
TECHNICAL CLARIFYING CHANGES.
ESPECIALLY ASPIRIN I VOTE ON
ASSEMBLY CONCURRED CONCUR TO
SEVENTY MINUTES THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR PANEL MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING. NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OUR HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I
FACE NO BACKER. HI FORTIS NO
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
PROTESTING HI DOLLY NO DOT. HI
TORONTO I A COMMON GLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATE GROWTH. NO HERZBERG
I WAS SO HYPER TANTO I JONES NO
KAMMERER I LAYERED I LABOUR I
THE MOON. I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S
NO MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO-
TROUBLE NO PAM HI FOURTEEN TO
NO I BROUGHT. HI RUBIO I
SKINNER. FIVE STERN NUMBER FIVE
CASSIE I WINNER I WILL NO FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT NEWS NINE DECEMBER
MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN EIGHTY
FOUR SENATOR CORTESE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE EIGHTY THREE BY
SENATOR CORTEZ HE AN ACT
RELATING TO JUVENILE CENTER
CORTESE THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND SENATORS ROSE PERCENT SP
THREE EIGHTY THREE WHICH IS
BACK IN THE SENATE ON
CONCURRENCE. BUT THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS- BY THE
ASSEMBLY THAT OUR TECHNICAL
NATURE COEXIST BILLS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HAS NO
FORMAL OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU
CENTER CORTESE MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I. ATKINS I
HATE. BECKER I PORCHES.
BRADFORD I HAVE MY OTHER
HYPERTENSIVE I. DALI. GOD I
TORONTO HI ADNAN GLAZER ICONS
ALL AS GROWTH NO HERTZBERG I
WAS SO. I HER TADO I JONES NO
CAN LONGER I LAYERED. I LIVE IN
HI THE MOON I REQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO A TURBO. I CAN I
PERSON TINA I BROUGHT I RUBIO
I'D SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG I
LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL
KNOW PLEASE CALL THE OF THE
MEMBERS. STATE NO FORTUS NO
DALLY NO ADRIAN GONZALEZ
MELINDA'S. STERN BY TWENTY NINE
NO SEVEN THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM EIGHTY FIVE IS
SOMEONE PRESENTING FOR SENATOR
STERN S. B. FOR TWENTY THREE.
THERE WE GO HELLO SENATOR
BECKER MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL FOR TWENTY
THREE BY SENATOR STERN AN ACT
RELATING TO ENERGY CENTER THANK
YOU ARE PRESENT FOR TWENTY
THREE BY HENRY STERN RETURNS TO
THE SENATE WITH ASSEMBLYMEN SIT
NEAR THE BILL CLARIFIES THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
ASSESSMENT. REQUIRED IN THE
BILL ALSO INCLUDES ENERGY
STORAGE AND BE COMPLETED NO
LATER THAN THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE- SOME OTHER OTHER
SMALL MOMENTS- FOCUS ASSESSMENT
FIRM ZERO CARBON RESOURCES LIKE
INDIVIDUALLY OR COMBINATION
DELIVERS YOUR CORPORATE ACTIONS
TO SUPPORT ELECTRIC LECTURES.
ENERGY GRID DURING EXTREME
WEATHER EVENTS I START TO ASK
WE CONCUR WITH THE SIMPLY
MINUTES. THANK YOU SENATOR
BAKER MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OUR DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING
NONE BETTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BASE.
BACKER HI FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
CORTEZ C. I. DALI NO DOG. I
TORONTO HI ADNAN GLAZER AIKENS
AULUS GROWTH NO HERZBERG I WENT
SO I HER TADO. I JONES NO
CAMCORDER I LAYERED I LLEVA HI
THE MOON. MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO THE
TROUBLE HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO.
I. ROSS HI RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN AMBERG HI I. FORECASTING
I WINNER. I WILL HI PLEASE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FAITH NO EKMAN GONZALEZ MON.
MELINDA'S NO STERN. GORGEOUS I
DON'T KNOW. HIGHS TWENTY NINE
KNOWS SEVEN DECEMBER AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN PART I ITEM
EIGHTY SIX. YES THE CENTER
BECKER. I WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST
IN A LETTER TO THE JOURNAL. THE
DELIVERIES BEEN APPROVED BY
BOTH SIDES WITHOUT OBJECTION
THANK YOU. ALLIED I'M EIGHTY
SIX SENATOR GLAZER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SEVEN NINETY TWO BY
SENATOR GLAZER AN ACT RELATING
TO TAXATION FEDERAL RESERVE
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SEVEN NINETY TWO IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES TAKE THAT SUGGESTION OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION. AND
RAISE THE REPORTING THRESHOLD
RETAILERS FROM ONLINE SALES OF
MORE THAN FIFTY MILLION RAISING
THE THRESHOLD WILL CAPTURE
CRITICAL DATA 90% OF INTERTEK
INSTATE ONLINE SALES ARE
STRICTLY S. RIVALS. THANK YOU
SENATOR GLAZER MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I ADKINS I
HATE. HI BECKER HI PORCHES NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T I
PROTESTING I DALLY. I DON I
TORONTO HI EGGMAN LASER I
CONSOLIDATE GROVE. HERTZBERG HI
WEST SO I HER TADO. JONES CAN
LONGER I LAYERED I. LEIVA NO
THE MON. I MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S.
CAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN I GO TO
A VOTE HI PAM I PERSON TINO I.
ROSS. RUBIO HI SKINNER HI STERN
NUMBER HI MIKE HOW SKI I WINNER
I WILL. HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. EGGMAN GONZALES
GROWTH I HER TADO. JONES NO
MELINDA'S NO ROSS. STERN. FIVE
THIRTY ONE NEWS FOR THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS WE'RE
RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS SENATOR WIENER.
RIGHT YEAH OKAY NOW IT'S THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- I- MOVED-
SP THREE FIFTY SEVEN- BE HELD
AT THE DESK WITH THE IDEA OF
MOVING IT TO ENGROSSING AND
ROLLING WHEN WE RECONVENE IN
THE NEW YEAR THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR WIENER THE DESK
WILL NOTE. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THREE
ITEMS PLEASE FILE ITEM TWENTY
NINE. AB ELEVEN OH TWO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW TO THE
ACTIVE. SECOND FILE IN AND
THIRTY TWO AB THREE SIXTY FOUR
ROD REGUS TO THE INACTIVE.
THREE FILE ITEM. THIRTY THREE
EIGHTY NINE SIXTY FIVE LEVIN TO
THE INACTIVE. THANK YOU. THE
DESK WILL NOTE SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUBMIT TWO LETTERS
LETTERS TO THE JOURNAL. THESE
LETTERS ARE TO CLARIFY INTENT
IN SENATE BILLS EIGHTY ONE AND
FIVE TWENTY FOUR THE LETTERS
HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY BOTH
SIDES. WITHOUT OBJECTION SEND A
COVER YOUR- THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUBMIT A LETTER TO THE JOURNAL
REGARDING SB FOUR OH NINE THE
LETTERS BEEN APPROVED BY BOTH.
BOXES WITHOUT OBJECTION SENATOR
ALAN. BENEFITS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUBMIT A LOT OF THE
JOURNAL AND SP THREE FORTY
THREE IT'S BEEN APPROVED BY
BOTH CAUCUSES AND ALSO
STAKEHOLDERS- WITHOUT OBJECTION
THIRD AWAY SO I ALSO REQUESTS
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUBMIT A
LETTER TO THE JOURNAL ON SP.
THREE ELEVEN. WITHOUT OBJECTION
MEMBERS ANYTHING ELSE UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
WELL I
AM THIRTY EIGHT EIGHT ZERO
NINETY EIGHT IS MOVING TO THE
INACTIVE FILE FILE NUMBER FORTY
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY SEVEN IS
MOVING TO THE INACTIVE FILE AP
THIRTY NINE OR EXCUSE ME NUMBER
THIRTY NINE AB THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE IS MOVING TO THE INACTIVE
FILE.
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE WE'RE WAITING ON
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE NUMBER.
THREE
MEMBERS WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR
THE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE NUMBER
THREE WE DO HAVE AN ADJOURN IN
MEMORY IF I CAN ASK EVERYONE TO
TAKE THEIR SEATS. SENATOR
PORTENT TINO PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU-
MADAM PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES
I RISE WITH THE DEEP SADNESS
TODAY. TO ASK THAT WE ADJOURNED
IN THE MEMORY OF A LONGTIME
COMMUNITY LEADER AND PUBLIC
SERVANT ARTHUR CHARLES DIVINE
PART WAS BORN IN LOS ANGELES
AND GRADUATED FROM UC BERKELEY
WITH A BACHELOR OF SCIENCE
DEGREE IN CIVIL ENGINEERING HE
RECEIVED A MASTERS OF PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATION DEGREE FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND WAS A STATE
LICENSE CIVIL STRUCTURAL AND
FIRE PROTECTION ENGINEER. HE
SPENT THIRTY SIX YEARS WORKING
FOR THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
DEPARTMENT OF BUILDING AND
SAFETY DURING HIS TENURE WITH
THE CITY HE SERVED AS THE CHIEF
OF EARTHQUAKE SAFETY DIVISION
CHIEF OF INSPECTION BUREAU AND
ITS EXECUTIVE OFFICER MOST
IMPORTANTLY IT WAS DURING HIS
CAREER WITH THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES THAT HE MET AND MARRIED
THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE. PAUL THE
DIVINE WHO IS A COUNCIL MEMBER
IN THE CITY OF GLENDALE A
TIRELESS COMMUNITY VOLUNTEER
ART SAID THERE IS NOTHING MORE
REWARDING AND GRATIFYING THAN
KNOWING YOU'RE HELPING PEOPLE
AND MAKING A DIFFERENCE BY
GIVING YOUR TIME AND RESOURCES
WITHOUT WANTING EXPECTING OR
RECEIVING ANYTHING IN RETURN.
AFTER RETIRING IN NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN OUR CONTINUED TO
GIVE BACK TO HIS COMMUNITY HE
VOLUNTEERED AT THE WILDLIFE WAY
STATION SERVED AS A VOLUNTEER
ARBOR. ARBITRATOR FOR THE
BETTER BUSINESS BUREAU AN OP ON
SPIN FOR CBS TELEVISION HE ALSO
CHAIRED THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
UNITED WAY CAMPAIGN. A MEMBER
OF THE GLENDALE FIRE FOUNDATION
AND THE GLENDALE POLICE
FOUNDATION ART WAS AWARDED THE
FIRST VOLUNTEER YEAR OF THE
YEAR RECOGNITION. HE ALSO
SERVED ON THE GLENDALE BOARD OF
ZONING APPEALS TO GLENDALE
BUILDING AND FIRE BOARD OF
APPEALS. AND SPENT TWELVE YEARS
ON THE CITY CIVIL SERVICE
COMMISSION. IN THEIR FREE TIME
ART AND PAUL I LOVE TO TRAVEL
VISITING ALMOST EVERY CONTINENT
THEIR TRAVELS HAVE TAKEN THEM
FROM. KATHMANDU TO BALI FROM
SHANGHAI TO RWANDA FROM KOREA
TO ARMENIA AND EVERYWHERE IN
BETWEEN. ART AND PAUL I HAVE
SELFLESSLY DEVOTED THEIR TIME
TO IMPROVING THE QUALITY OF
LIFE FOR GLENDALE RESIDENTS.
THE MAYOR
GLENDALE. ART WAS HER ROCK A
WEE SUPPORTING HER IN HER
ENDEAVORS HIS FAMILY FRIENDS
AND THE COUNTLESS INDIVIDUALS
WHOSE LIVES HE TOUCHED. WOLF
WILL FOREVER BE CHERISHED HIS
MEMORY AND CELEBRATE HIS LEGACY
OF SERVICE FOR THE COMMUNITY IT
WAS A REALLY GOOD GUY. A SAD
LOSS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR FORTINO
PLEASE BE SURE TO BRING HIS
NAME FORWARD SO HE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR SENATOR
MAN. THANK YOU AND PRESIDENT I
JUST WANTED TO FOLLOW UP ON SR
FIFTY TWO RECOGNIZING API
BASEBALL- BY NOTING THAT SHOHEI
OHTANI THE ANGELS STAR-
JAPANESE FIRST. TWO WAY PLAYER
AND THE ALL STAR GAME CAN HIT
HIS LEAGUE LEADING FORTY FOURTH
HOME RUN TONIGHT. THANK YOU.
THAT'S VERY COOL THANK YOU
SENATOR MEN.
MEMBERS WE NEED
ABOUT TEN TO FIFTEEN MINUTES TO
PREPARE THE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO MOVE
AROUND THAT WOULD BE JUST FINE.
PLEASE DO NOT LEAVE THE FLOOR.
DO NOT LEAVE THE RED CARPET.
IT
IS BEING HANDED OUT PLEASE TAKE
YOUR COPY AND PERUSE IT
CAREFULLY.
REMEMBER YOU SHOULD
HAVE YOUR SUPPLEMENTAL FILE
NUMBER THREE IN FRONT OF YOU
WE'RE STARTING WITH FILE ITEM
EIGHTY SEVEN SENATOR BECKER
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIXTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR BACKER AN ACT RELATING
TO ELECTRICITY CENTER BETTER.
THANK YOU I AM SURE THAT SB
SIXTY IS BACK IN CONCURRENCE IS
SIMPLY MOMENTS ADDRESS CHAPTER
OUT ISSUES AND COOK AND ADD CO
AUTHORS I EXPECT TO ASK FOR A
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR BAKER
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA. ATKINS
I BAIT. BACKER HI FOR JUST.
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM.
CORTESE I DALLY. YEAH NO GOD I
TORONTO I THANK MEN GLAZER. I
CONSOLIDATE GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG FIVE WEST SO I HEARD
HOW DO I JONES I CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED HI LABOUR HI THE MON HI
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S. MANY HI
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. KNOW WHAT
YOUR VOTE. PAN I FORTUNE TINO
I. ROSS. HI RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN NUMBER I WAKE COUNTY I
WINNER. I WILL HI PLEASE CALL
THE OFFICE AT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA I BATES I. PORTIS I
CONFIRA I. EGGMAN GONZALEZ
MELINDA'S NO A SHOW BOTH. STERN.
FIVE THIRTY TWO NEWS FOR THESE
EMPLOYMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
PART I ITEM EIGHTY EIGHT
SENATOR PORTENT TINO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE EIGHTY ONE BY
SENATOR PART INTO YOU KNOW AN
ACT RELATING TO LOCAL-GOVERNMENT MAKING APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE AND TAKING AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
SECONDS MEDIALLY. CENTER
PORTENT TINO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. SP THREE
EIGHTY ONE HAS ONLY BEEN SIXTY
YEARS IN THE MAKING AND I'M
PROUD THAT IT'S BACK ON
CONCURRENCE WITH AMENDMENTS TO
MAKE IT ECONOMICALLY VIABLE FOR
THE CITY OF SOUTH PASADENA. THE
PURCHASE SUBSTANTIALLY REALLY
REHABILITATE MAINTAIN AND
ADMINISTER A PORTABLE HOUSING
PROGRAM WHICH HELPS TO ADDRESS
LOCAL THAT LOCAL HOUSING
CRISIS. THE AMENDMENTS ALSO
MAKE SURE THAT THE TENANTS ARE
PROTECTED THE CITY HAS
FLEXIBILITY AND THE STATE HAS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER PORTENT
TINO MEMBERS IN DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING THEN
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN. ARCHULETA I ADKINS
HI BABY HI BECKER I PORCHES I
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM
TORONTO. HI ADNAN GLAZER. I
CONSOLIDATE GROWTH. I HEARD
SPURRED BY WESTERN HYPER TANTO
I JONES I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED
I LABOR HI THE MOON HI MCGUIRE
I MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON. I A SHOW OF BOTH. PAM I
PERSON TINA I. ROSS I RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN NUMBER NINE
FIVE WHITE HOUSE SKI I WINNER.
HI WELL HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALAN I. DALLY I
COMMEND GONZALEZ MELINDA'S.
CONTROL OF BOTH I TURN FIVE
THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY FIVE THIRTY FIVE NO
ZERO THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONFERRED IN FILE ITEM
EIGHTY NINE SENATOR BECKER
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLED BY SENATOR BACK
FOR AN ACT RELATING TO MURDER.
CENTER BECKER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AFTER VERY CLOSE
VOTES AT S. B. SEVEN SEVEN FIVE
IS BACK AND A MEMBER OF THE
ASSEMBLY ADDRESS CONCERNS THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND THEY'RE
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL. ESPECIALLY
AFTER I BOOK. THANK YOU SENATOR
BAKER MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN. R. I. ARCHULETA I
AT KINS I FACE. NO BACKER HI
FORGES NO BRADFORD I HAVE A I
DON'T. CORTESE I DALLY NO DOG.
HI TORONTO HI AIKMAN GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE- NO HERTZBERG HI
WITH SO. I HER TADO NO JONES NO
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LABOR I
THE MOON. I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S
NO MAN I NEWMAN I NELSON. I
WOULD SHOW UP BOTH NO PAN HI
FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS. I RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN NUMBER HI FI
CASKEY HI WINNER I WILL NO IT'S
CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS. BY ADAM
I. EGGMAN GONZALEZ STERN FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT NEWS NINE DECEMBER
MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
SENATOR NELSON. HI SENATOR
NIELSEN NIELSEN I DON'T KNOW
THANK YOU FIVE TWENTY SEVEN
KNOWS TEN THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS IF YOU CAN PRE PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS IF THERE IS NO
FURTHER BUSINESS CENTER ATKINS
THE DESK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. WELL AS I LOOK
AT THE CLOCK IN C. EIGHT FIFTY.
WHAT A DIFFERENCE. BOY THIS
YEAR LOOKS A LOT DIFFERENT AND
I'M SO GLAD- COLLEAGUES I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE HARD WORK AND
THOUGHTFULNESS TODAY AND ALL
YEAR LONG THIS LEGISLATIVE
SESSION WE HAD A ONCE IN A.
GENERATION OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
TRANSFER MORE FOR
TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE AND WE
ABSOLUTELY SEIZE THAT
OPPORTUNITY THROUGH THE BUDGET
OUR BILLS AND THE BREAKTHROUGHS
WE'VE MADE ON DECADES LONG
PROBLEMS TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE MADE
HISTORY. AND I THINK WE
INVESTED WISELY FOR OUR FUTURE.
THERE'S ALWAYS MORE TO DO SO I
KNOW THAT EACH OF YOU WILL USE
THIS INTERIM TO POSITION
YOURSELVES OURSELVES TO BUILD.
ON ANY SUCCESSES AND TO MOVE
FORWARD OR WE DIDN'T MAYBE MAKE
AS MUCH PROGRESS AS WE HAD
HOPED. IN THINKING ABOUT THIS
YEAR I THINK THERE'S A FEW
SPECIAL RECOGNITIONS THAT ARE
IN ORDER FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
BROUGHT US TO THIS POINT AND
I'MGOING TO. MAKE SOME
COMMENTS AND THEN I'M GONNA
TURN IT OVER TO OUR REPUBLICAN
LEADER TO ALSO ADD TO THOSE
COMMENTS AND THEN MADAM
PRESIDENT. WILL WILL BRING IT
HOME AND BRING IT TO CONCLUSION.
I WANT TO START WITH. THE
INCREDIBLE SECRETARY OF THE
SENATE MISS ERIKA CONTRARIES.
IN AN OUTSTANDING LEADER FOR
THE STATE SENATE AND MOST
IMPORTANT FOR ALL THE HUMAN
BEINGS WHO MAKE UP THE SENATE
I'M PROUD TO BE A MEMBER OF
THIS INSTITUTION ON YOUR WATCH.
UNFINISHED BUSINESS WE ARE
GOING TO PASS A LAW TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU COULD HAVE A
SPECIAL CERTIFICATE THAT
ENABLES YOU TO BE PART OF THE
CDC AND THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT ALL ROLLED INTO ONE.
THANK YOU. TWO ARE INCREDIBLE
AND I THOUGHT SHE WAS DUCKING
RIGHT OUT OF SIGHT AS I SAID
THAT BUT NO THERE SHE IS OUR
CHIEF ASSISTANT SECRETARY
BERNADETTE MCNULTY. ALWAYS A
LITTLE NERVOUSNESS AROUND THE
END OF SESSION WITH ALL THE
MOVING PARTS AND THEN AFTER THE
LAST THREE YEARS BUT THEN I
LOOK UP AND I SEE BERNIE AT THE
DIETS AND I REMEMBER OKAY WE
GOT THIS BECAUSE WE GET BURNING.
SO THANK YOU TO OUR INCREDIBLE
DESK STAFF AND ALSO TO ALL
THOSE THINGS NEED TO THOSE THAT
YOU SEE AND ACTUALLY DOES IT
YOU DON'T SEE SO LET ME ALSO
MAKE SURE INCLUDE ENGROSSING
AND ROLLING AND THE MAJORITY
LEADER WILL GIVE YOU A WHOLE
SESSION ON EVERYTHING THEY DO
IF YOU'RE NOT QUITE SURE WHAT
THAT MEANS. BUT I'M ALWAYS
IMPRESSED NOT ONLY BY YOUR
INCREDIBLE HARD WORK UNDER HIGH
PRESSURE BUT ALSO BY HOW CALM
AND UNFLAPPABLE YOU ARE ALL THE
TIME SO THANK YOU ALL FOR ALL
THAT YOU DO. UHHUH A FEW. AND
AT A TIME WHEN WE'VE SEEN
THREATS AND ATTACKS ON OUR
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS TO KEEP
ELECTED OFFICIALS FROM DOING
THEIR JOBS OUR JOBS I WANT TO
THANK OUR CHIEF SERGEANT
KATRINA RODRIGUEZ AND TO ALL OF
OUR AMAZING SENATE SERGEANTS
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
THE CAPITAL SECURITY STAFF FOR
YOUR SERVICE SO LET'S GIVE THEM
A STANDING OVATION. IN A REAL
SPECIAL THANK YOU TO JENNIFER
HATFIELD AND LUKE STARBUCK AND
THE TEAM AT CAPITAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR THEIR EXPERTISE.
AND GREAT PROFESSIONALISM.
DURING THIS DIFFICULT YEAR.
AMAZING PATIENTS THEY HAD FOR
OUR ABILITY TO GET THOSE TESTS
IN ON TIME. WE OWE ENORMOUS
THANKS TO D. G. S. AND OUR
HOUSEKEEPING STAFF FOR THE
DAILY EFFORT THAT KEEPS THE
BUILDING RUNNING AND OF COURSE
THE EXTRA CARE THAT THEY HAVE
SHOWN US AS WE WORK TO KEEP AS
THEY KEEP PEOPLE SAFE FROM CODE
NINETEEN SO ALL OF THE EXTRA
WORK THEY'VE HAD TO DO TO KEEP
US SAFE WE THANK THEM. I WANT
TO THANK OUR LEGISLATIVE DATA
CENTER AND TO THE
TELECONFERENCE CALL MODERATOR
SINCE. ALL WHO ARE HELPING MAKE
THE BRAVE NEW WORLD OF
TECHNOLOGY ASSESSABLE FOR US
AND FOR THE PUBLIC. I WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE OUGHT TO OFFER
SPECIAL THANKS TO THE AMAZING
TEAM AND STAFF THAT I'M
INCREDIBLY FORTUNATE TO HAVE AS
PRO TEM. AND THAT INCLUDES MY
LEADERSHIP TEAM NICK HARTMAN IN
THE CAPITAL PAM I SENT IN MY
DISTRICT DYING GRIFFIS KIMBERLY
RODRIGUEZ CHRIS WOODS NATION
FRIENDS MAKE A LINA WOODS AND
THE EXTENDED INCREDIBLE HARD
HARD WORKING TEAM THAT I HAVE.
AND I WILL END BY THANKING ALL
OF OUR STAFFS. ALL OF YOU MAKE
IT EASIER FOR THOSE OF YOU
TUNING IN AND THOSE OF YOU IN
THE BUILDING YOU MAKE IT EASIER
TO FIND SOLUTIONS AND GET HELP
TO THE PEOPLE THAT WE
REPRESENT. IN A YEAR OR CASE
WORK HAS TAKEN ON ADDITIONAL
MEANING. AND EVEN THOUGH ALL OF
YOU'VE BEEN FACING YOUR OWN
CHALLENGES DURING THIS PANDEMIC
YOUR COMMITMENT TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS NEVER. NEVER
WAVERED. I WANNA I WANNA THANK
THE MAJORITY LEADER THE
ASSISTANT MAJORITY LEADER. THE
PRESIDING OFFICERS THE MEMBER
FLOOR TEAM THE REPUBLICAN
LEADER. AND HIS TEAM OF
INCREDIBLE STAFF AND MEMBERS.
WHO KEEP ASSAULT COMMUNICATING.
AND DOING THE JOB THAT WE NEED
TO DO FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
THAT I WANT TO TURN IT OVER TO
OUR REPUBLICAN LEADER. MR
STAUBACH. SENATOR WILK. THANK
YOU MADAM PRO TEM. ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTRE REPUBLICANS I WANT
TO THANK YOU PRO TEM AND YOUR
STAFF. FOR YOUR OUTSTANDING
EFFORTS THIS YEAR AND RUNNING
VERY SMOOTH HOUSE MUCH
DIFFERENT SESSION- THIS YEAR.
THAN LAST YEAR AND THOUGH WE
DON'T ALWAYS AGREE ON POLICY I
THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE THIS IS
A DIFFICULT JOB. RUNNING THIS
HOUSE AND EDGES YEOMAN WORK
FOR- FOR YOU AND YOUR STAFF.
ALSO MADE I'M GOING TO
REPLICATE SOME OF THIS BUT I
ALSO WANT TO ECHO THE PRO TEM'S
APPRECIATION FOR ALL THOSE WHO
WORK SO HARD TO SUPPORT US. THE
JOB THE ERROR CAN TERRACES
DIED. TO KEEP US IS KOBE FREES
YOU DID THAT WAS JUST
INCREDIBLE. INCREDIBLE EFFORT
NEEDED DESERVE ANOTHER ROUND OF
APPLAUSE FOR THAT. AND
OBVIOUSLY WE ALL KNOW THAT WE
ALL REPORT TO BERNICE OF BERNIE
MCNULTY AND HER- HER STAFF JUST
INCREDIBLE. YOU GET A. I WAS SO
GLAD WHEN KATRINA RODRIGUEZ
DECIDED TO STEP UP AND COME SEE
OUR CHIEF SERGEANT HER AND HER
STAFF KEPT MY A GOODSENATOR
FROM FRESNO SAFE FROM HIS
AMARISTA ADMIRERS THAT STOCK
THE CAPITAL FOR HIM AND SO HE'S
GONNA BE ABLE TO GO HOME TO HIS
FAMILY TONIGHT- KNOWING THAT.
THAT HE'S HE'S SAFE. YEAH I.
YOU GUYS DON'T KNOW THAT'S WHAT
YOU WANT TO TALK TO HIM LATER.
AND THEN ALSO JUST ALL THE ALL
ALL OF OUR HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS- CONVERT HATFIELD
OF COURSE LUCAS STARBUCK WHICH
I'M ALWAYS LOOKING FOR YOU TO
GET THAT CONFIRMATION THAT MY
TEST WAS NEGATIVE EVERY SUNDAY.
AND NO ONE KNOWS MY KNOWS
BETTER THAN HIM I MEAN. HE'S
VERY GENTLE TO WHICH I
APPRECIATE UNLIKE THE PEOPLE
DOWNSTAIRS THIS LAST WEEK NINE
AS MOST UNFORTUNATE. AND THEN
YOU KNOW I THINK MOST PEOPLE IN
THIS CHAMBER NOBODY I DON'T
THINK THE GENERAL PUBLIC KNOWS
THAT WE ARE THE MAJORITY OF THE
MINORITY WE MEET PRIOR TO EVERY
SESSION. AND THE PURPOSES THAT
IS TO HAVE A SMOOTH OPERATION
HERE ON THE ONTHE SENATE FLOOR
I WANT TO THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG. FREDDIE CAN TANA AND
EVERYBODY ON THEIR STAFF FOR
ALL THEIR GREAT WORK. WELL WE
ALWAYS TRANSPARENT. NO NO
GAMESMANSHIP I THINK THAT'S
AGAIN ONE OF THEM AGAIN I'VE
KNOWN I'VE KNOWN MAJORITY
LEADER SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE SO DFINITELY A TRY I
TRUST THEIR- AND THEN I WOULD I
WOULD BE REMISS WITHOUT
MENTIONING YOU KNOW OUR TEAM
VERY PLAST- BLASTS ARE POCKETS
CHAIRS PAT BATES. OUR FLOOR
LEADERS BRIAN JONES IN WITH YOU
KNOW KEVIN BASSETT AND DANIELLE
PARSONS WHO STARTED IN THIS
BUILDING AS MY FELLOW BACK OVER
IN THE ASSEMBLY I THINK WE HAVE
A GOOD TEAM THAT KEEPS.
EVERYBODY IN LINE AND INFORMED
ON OUR SIDE. AND THEN I ALSO
WANT TO. TAKE A KNOWLEDGE OUR
DEDICATED REPUBLICAN POLICY AND
FISCAL AND RULES AND
COMMUNICATIONS STAFF. UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP OF POLICY DIRECTOR
GREG MOM FISCAL DIRECTOR KURT
FEELING A COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR MAXI WHOLE GROWN.
COLBERG I HAD A DOUGLAS THEY
JUST DOING GREAT WORK THIS YEAR
AND I'D BE REMISS WITHOUT
MENTIONING THE DEAN OF THE
SENATE AND THE VICE CHAIR OF
BUDGET FOR US SENATOR JIM
NIELSEN. THE QUICKLY JUST ONE
IMAGE MY PERSONAL STUFF SO THE
THAT DID THE CHIEF OF STAFF TO
THE CAUCUS MISTER JOHN BEAUVAIS
WHO MY PULLED OUT OF RETIREMENT.
AND YOU NEVER SEE HIM BECAUSE
HE IS THE DELEGATE- A DELEGATE
SAID. HE JUST SEES IT JUST
UNBELIEVABLE ANYONE WITH THAT
WHAT WAS ABLE TO- TO ELEVATE I
LEAN- RECUR AS AS MY CHIEF OF
STAFF HAS JUST DONE A
PHENOMENAL JOB AND THOSE WHO
YOU KNOW HER. KNOW HOW GREAT
SHE HAS BEEN IN. MY LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR BALTAR'S OUR CURRENT
NAIL HE'D JUST GOT PROMOTED TO
WINFREY WE GOT TO. YOU KNOW PUT
INTO THIS PUT IT INTO THIS
POSITION HE JUST SITS DOWN AND
CREDIBLE JOB MANAGING ME.
KEEPING ALL OF OUR LEAD STAFF
ON LL OF OUR OFFICES- YOU KNOW
UP TO DATE AND IN AN INFORMED
INTO JUST REALLY WANT TO THANK
HIM. FOR EVERYTHING THAT HE'S
DONE. TELL ME DID YOU KNOW
FINAL THIS THIS THIS IS A
FAMILY THIS WILL BE THIS LIKE
SCHOOL HERE IT'S LIKE ALMOST
LIKE SUMMER BREAK RUGBY GOING
HOME AND I. JUST WANTED TO TELL
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU THAT
YOU KNOW LIKE I CARE FOR YOU-
YOU REPRESENT YOUR DISTRICTS
WELL. HOPE YOU GO HOME GET TO
SPEND TIME WITH FAMILY BUT ALSO
WITH THE PEOPLE THAT YOU
REPRESENT. AND WE'LL COME BACK
NEXT YEAR AND DO THE BEST JOB
WE CAN FOR THE- FORTY MILLION
RESIDENTS THAT THAT WE
REPRESENT. AND WITH THAT TURN
IT BACK OVER TO YOU MADAM
PROTEST. PUT HIM ONE THING I.
CAN'T BELIEVE I LEFT IT UP AND
I WANNA THANK MY GOOD FRIEND
WHO TALKS TRASH BETTER THAN
ANYBODY ON THE BASKETBALL COURT
MY GOOD FRIEND FROM GARDENIA. I
KNOW YOU TALKED MORE TRASH THAN
ANYBODY ON A BASKETBALL COURT
HERE ON THE SENATE CHAMBERS.
THANK YOU SENATOR ATKINS BACK
QUEUE AND THEN IN THAT DEBATE
WILL CONTINUE INTO THE N.
TERMINUS CHEER EVERYBODY WHILE
WE'RE STANDING YOU KNOW IT'S
ALWAYS WE NEED TO FORGET NOBODY
IS WE ISSUE OUR THANKS BECAUSE
IT IS SO HEARTFELT. LET'S
ALTERNATE WAVE IT LAURIE
SHELLEY AS SHE HAS HER A CAMERA
OUT AND SAY THANK YOU FOR THAT
HOURS THAT SHE'S BEEN. TRYING
TO MAKE US LOOK GOOD- ON THE
FLOOR AND ELSEWHERE SO LORIE
SHELLEY THANK YOU- THE TWO HOUR
OR COLLEAGUES WHO ARE NOT WITH
US TONIGHT LET'S WISH THE BEST
TO- SENATOR STERN ALEXANDRA'S
THEY STILL AWAIT THIS CHILD.
ARE THEY WE ALL CANNOT WAIT TO
MEET- CERTAINLY DOES CENTER A
MAN WHO IS NOT WITH US TONIGHT
WE SAID OUR BEST TO THEM I DO
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO OUR
LEGISLATIVE- PARTNERS IT ON THE
GREEN CARPET MISTER SPEAKER-
THE REPUBLICAN LEADER OVER
THERE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON
AND. ALL OF THEIR STAFF LOOK.
IT'S NEVER EASY WHEN GET A
HUNDRED TWENTY OF US TOGETHER
ALL WITH THE MOST PERFECT IDEAS
OF WHAT WE THINK SHOULD HAPPEN
AND THERE IN LIES THE CHALLENGE
OF THE LAST NIGHT OF SESSION.
BUT I THINK WE'VE DONE OUR
CONSTITUENTS PROUD THIS YEAR TO
END AT A REASONABLE HOUR. WITH
THE TYPE OF- STATES PERSON LIKE
CONDUCT THAT WE SHOULD HAVE AS
WE'RE DOING THE PEOPLE'S
BUSINESS SO I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU. TO MY LEGISLATIVE PARTNERS
IN THE ASSEMBLY INTO MISTER
SPEAKER. AND LATIN VERY LASTLY
I THINK WE ALL KNOW OUR SPOUSES
AND OUR PARTNERS A GREAT DEAL
OF THANKS FOR ALLOWING US THE
ABILITY TO DO THIS JOB AND BE
PUBLIC SERVANTS. AND WITH THAT
MADAM PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES AS
WE LEAVE THIS EVENING WE ARE ON
THE EVE OF COURSE AS WE KNOW OF
THE TWENTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF
NINE ELEVEN. I THANK YOU ALL
FOR THE INCREDIBLE MOVING
COMMENTS WHEN WE PAY TRIBUTE TO
THIS SOMBER ANNIVERSARY EARLIER
THIS WEEK. AND AS WE HEAD HOME
TO OUR FAMILIES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES I KNOW THAT WE WILL
ALL HOLD THEM A LITTLE CLOSER.
BECAUSE OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING THIS WEEK AND THE LOSS
THAT WE'VE HAD AN ANNIVERSARY
BEFORE US. THE SENATORS TRAVEL
SAFE AND MADAM PRESIDENT WITH
THAT OUR NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS
SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY JANUARY
THIRD TWENTY TWENTY TWO AT TWO
PM. THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
PRO TEM OF THE SENATE WILL BE
ADJOURNED WE WILL RECONVENE
JANUARY. THIRD TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AT TWO PM IN THE MEANTIME
BE SAFE MEMBERS.